SERIES. HOWEVER. ITEM NUMBER TEN
SB 1235. GONZALEZ HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. FOUR BILLS
ARE ON CONSENT TODAY. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, SB 1252. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN, SB 1288. ITEM
NUMBER 13 SB 1329. ITEM NUMBER
14, SB 1449, AND FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER 15. SB 1435 IS FOR VOTE
ONLY THIS MORNING. WITNESSES
TODAY ARE ASKED TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THREE MINUTES TO
ENSURE THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO
COMPLETE TODAY'S AGENDA IN A
TIMELY FASHION. SEEING NO
QUORUM, LET'S BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE FIRST
REGULAR ORDER BILL. WELCOME,
SENATOR ROTH. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SENATE BILL
895. IT'S OUR MORE PATHWAYS TO
NURSING BILL, WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO SELECT UP TO 15
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS WITH
AN EXISTING, NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED ASSOCIATE DEGREE IN
NURSING PROGRAM, AN ADN PROGRAM
TO OFFER A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
IN NURSING DEGREE. THE BSN, AS
YOU KNOW, FOR OVER 40 YEARS, THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE IN NURSING HAS BEEN THE
BASIC CREDENTIAL FOR EMPLOYMENT
AS A REGISTERED NURSE IN A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER, DUE TO A
PUSH BY CREDENTIALING
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCREASE THE
PERCENTAGE OF NURSES HOLDING BSN
DEGREES TO 80% OF THOSE IN
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES, AN
EFFORT THAT STARTED A DECADE OR
MORE AGO. THE BSN DEGREE IS NOW
BECOMING THE NEW INDUSTRY
STANDARD FOR EMPLOYMENT IN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS AND PERHAPS
IN OTHER HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
A BSN, AS YOU KNOW, ALSO HAPPENS
TO BE A REQUIREMENT FOR
ATTAINMENT OF A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN NURSING AND DOCTORATE OF
NURSE PRACTICE DEGREES THAT ARE
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO BECOME
NURSE PRACTITIONERS, NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND INDEPENDENT
SETTINGS. AND OF COURSE, FACULTY
MEMBERS IN OUR CALIFORNIA
NURSING PROGRAMS. IN IN 2021. IN
CALIFORNIA, A HEALTH IMPACT
REPORT FOUND THAT 18% OF
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS SURVEYED
STATED THAT A BSN WAS REQUIRED
FOR EMPLOYMENT TWICE THE
PERCENTAGE NOTED IN 2017, AND
54.3% REPORTED A PREFERENCE FOR
HIRING A BSN DEGREE NURSES.
SIGNIFICANTLY, 31.5% OF THE NEW
ADN RN SURVEYED STATED THAT THE
LACK OF A BSN DEGREE WAS GIVEN
TO THEM AS THE REASON FOR THEIR
FAILURE TO BE HIRED. THE IMPACT
OF THIS PREFERENCE FOR BSN
APPEARS TO HAVE MOVED TO THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT ARENA, AS
WELL, WITH SOME HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES RECENTLY SUGGESTING
THAT THEY PREFER NURSING
STUDENTS FROM BSN PROGRAMS OVER
NURSING STUDENTS FROM ADN
PROGRAMS. THIS DEMAND FOR
PRODUCTION OF BSN CREDENTIALED
REGISTERED NURSES CONTINUES TO
INCREASE WITHOUT A CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN CAPACITY TO TRAIN
THEM AT OUR PUBLIC, NOT OUR
PRIVATE, BUT OUR PUBLIC NURSING
SCHOOLS. BUT THERE IS A PATH
FORWARD TO HELP SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM, AND THAT PET PATH CUTS
RIGHT THROUGH OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IN 20 2122,
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADN
GRADUATES REPRESENTED OVER 40%
OF THE STUDENTS COMPLETING A
PRE-LICENSE PURE NURSING PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP MEET THE
NEED FOR BSN CREDENTIALED RNS.
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO UTILIZE
EXISTING ADN PROGRAMS TO
SUPPLEMENT THE WORK OF OUR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE BSN PROGRAMS.
TO MEET THIS DEMAND, THE BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE, AS I SAID, THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO SELECT UP
TO 15 CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS WITH AN
EXISTING, NATIONALLY ACCREDITED
ADN PROGRAM TO OFFER A BSN
DEGREE TO UP TO 25% OF EACH ADN
CLASS, OR 35 STUDENTS, WHICHEVER
IS GREATER. WHEN STUDENTS ENTER
THE BSN PHASE OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM AT A DISTRICT NURSING
PROGRAM, THEY WILL HAVE ALREADY
EARNED THEIR ASSOCIATE DEGREE IN
NURSING, PASSED THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL LICENSURE EXAM, THE
NCLEX, AND SECURED THEIR RN
LICENSE. PARTICIPATING STUDENTS
WOULD THEN TAKE THE ADDITIONAL
COURSEWORK NECESSARY TO EARN THE
BSN AT THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
ALLOWING STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AROUND THEIR
CLASS SCHEDULE AND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES. AS YOU KNOW
FROM A MANO, FROM A CURRICULUM
STANDPOINT, THE NURSING CLINICAL
COMPONENT OF THE ADN PROGRAM IS
THE SAME AS THE CLINICAL PROGRAM
APPLICABLE TO BSN PROGRAMS.
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES IN COURSE
CURRICULUM FROM ONE SCHOOL TO
ANOTHER, BUT THE BASIC NURSING
CURRICULA FROM THE NURSING
COURSEWORK. THE STUDY IS THE
SAME, AND THE NCLEX AND RN
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS ARE THE
SAME. THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO PROGRAMS IS ADN AND BSN
CONSISTS OF APPROXIMATELY 30
COURSE UNITS, WHICH GENERALLY
INCLUDE HUMANITIES AND
LEADERSHIP, MANAGEMENT AND
GENERALLY ONE POST LICENSURE,
ONE POST ARE IN LICENSURE,
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORK
ASSIGNMENT, BUT SINCE THESE BSN
STUDENTS ARE ALREADY LICENSED
RNS, NO ADDITIONAL SUPERVISED
CLINICAL PLACEMENT. NO CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS ARE REQUIRED FOR
THIS PILOT PROGRAM. BY
SUPPLEMENTING THE WORK OF OUR
EXISTING PUBLIC AND PRIVATE BSN
PROGRAMS. IN THIS WAY,
ADDITIONAL BSN DEGREE NURSES
WILL BE ADDED TO THE WORKFORCE.
NURSES WHO ARE QUALIFIED TO
BECOME SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
IN THE HEALTH CARE FACILITY AND
WHO ARE QUALIFIED TO BECOME
MASTERS OR DOCTORATE DEGREE
NURSE PRACTITIONERS IN
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE SETTINGS
AND AS NURSING SCHOOL FACULTY
MEMBERS. I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
AMAZING ENGAGEMENT ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. I THINK TOGETHER
WE'VE DEVELOPED AMENDMENTS WHICH
I HAVE AGREED TO TAKE AND ARE
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS
BRIEFLY. THE AMENDMENTS WILL
PRIORITIZE THE SELECTION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS FOR
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND
UNDERSERVED NURSING AREAS ALLOW
FOR THE PROVISIONAL SELECTION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS,
WHICH, WITH NURSING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN CANDIDACY FOR
NATIONAL ACCREDITATION, DIRECT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO DEVELOP A
PROCESS DESIGNED TO ASSIST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS WITH
NURSING PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED BUT ARE
APPLYING FOR NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION AND PRIORITIZE
THOSE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE BILL
WILL ALSO REQUIRE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS SELECTED FOR
THE PILOT TO PRIORITIZE
ENROLLMENT IN THE BSN PILOT
PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS WHO HOLD AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE IN NURSING
DEGREE FROM THAT DISTRICT, AND
WILL REQUIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS SELECTED FOR THE PILOT
TO CONTINUE TO OFFER AN ADN
PROGRAM FOR ALL THOSE WHO DO NOT
WISH TO PURSUE. ULTIMATELY, A
BSN. FINALLY, THE LAO IS
DIRECTED TO DO AN EVALUATION OF
THE PILOT THAT IS DUE IN 2032,
AND THIS SETS A SUNSET DATE FOR
THIS PROGRAM. IF IT'S NOT
EXTENDED ON JANUARY 1ST, 2034.
WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL. RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT DEAN OF NURSING
TAMMY VANTOL AND UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRESIDENT, CHARMAINE MORALES.
WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU. AND WHO
WILL BE GOING FIRST? YOU CAN
FLIP A COIN. WHOEVER WANTS TO GO
FIRST. GO AHEAD. MISS MORALES.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 895. MY NAME IS
CHARMAINE MORALES, AND I SERVE
AS THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATIONS UNION OF
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS, AND
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR SB 895 AS
A NURSE IN UNION PRESIDENT, I
WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE MANY
CHALLENGES FACED BY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSES STRIVING TO
ATTAIN THEIR BSN DEGREES. MORE
THAN HALF OF OUR NURSES AT
UNIACC UCCP MYSELF INCLUDED,
EARN THEIR ADNS AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, AND I DID IT WHILE
JUGGLING THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
RAISING FOUR CHILDREN. MANY
NURSES HAVE SHARED THE DIFFICULT
JOURNEY TO SECURE THEIR BSN WITH
ME, HINDERED BY LIMITED SLOTS IN
CSU PROGRAMS, MANY ARE COMPELLED
TO PURSUE COSTLY PRIVATE
SCHOOLING, RESULTING IN
STAGGERING STUDENT LOAN DEBTS.
THESE FINANCIAL BURDENS, COUPLED
WITH LOST EARNINGS DUE TO DUE TO
DELAYS IN MATRICULATION, HAVE
PLUNGED COUNTLESS NURSES INTO
FINANCIAL DIRE FINANCIAL
STRAITS. FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSE GRADUATES, THE PATH
FORWARD IS OFTEN NARROW, WITH
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
REPRESENTING THE ONLY VIABLE
OPTION FOR BSN COMPLETION. SB
895 STANDS AS A CRUCIAL STEP
TOWARDS RESHAPING THE LANDSCAPE
OF EXORBITANT NURSING EDUCATION
COSTS. THE CURRENT TREND OF
HEALTH SYSTEMS FAVORING BSN
PREPARED NURSES HAS NOT ONLY
EXACERBATED DIVERSITY
CHALLENGES, BUT ALSO HINDERED
WORKFORCE INCLUSIVITY. Kò SB 895
OFFERS A BEACON OF HOPE BY
EMPOWERING NURSES WITHIN THE
PILOT PROGRAM TO REMAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND SERVE THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, WHICH WOULD FOSTER
A MORE DIVERSE AND
REPRESENTATIVE NURSING WORKFORCE
FOR OVER TWO DECADES. NURSE
LEADERS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING A
NATIONAL NURSING SHORTAGE, AND
MANY STATES, INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA, HAVE FALLEN SHORT OF
THE INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE'S 2010
GOALS FOR BSN WORKFORCE
ATTAINMENT, CREATING ANOTHER
STAFFING CRISIS. IN THE PAST
YEAR, UNCP HAS BEEN STEADFAST
DEDICATED TO GROWING, EDUCATING
AND MAINTAINING THE NURSING
WORKFORCE. SB 895 IS PIVOTAL IN
OUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO RESHAPE
THE NARRATIVE AND CULTIVATE A
RESILIENT, EMPOWERED NURSING
WORKFORCE. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, MISS BARNHILL.
WELCOME. YES, THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH. AND THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB 895, THE
PHILOSOPHY OF THE FACULTY AND
ADMINISTRATORS AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGES IS THAT ALL NURSING
STUDENTS DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EARN A BSN. WITH THE SUPPORT
OF SENATOR ROTH, RCC WAS THE
FIRST COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
PARTNER WITH TWO LOCAL CSUS TO
OFFER A RN TO BSN CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS. HOWEVER
HALF OF MY STUDENTS THAT ARE
ADMITTED ARE EXCLUDED FROM FROM
PARTICIPATING BECAUSE THEY
EITHER DON'T MEET THE GPA
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CSUS, OR
THEY HAVE WORK AND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE THE
REALITY FOR SO MANY
NONTRADITIONAL COLLEGE STUDENTS
TODAY. WHAT RESULTS FOR THESE
STUDENTS? MANY OF WHOM BELONG TO
HISTORICALLY MINORITIZED GROUPS,
IS THEY EITHER DON'T COMPLETE
THEIR BACHELOR'S DEGREE AT ALL,
OR THEY SEEK THE AVAILABILITY
AND FLEXIBILITY THAT FOR PROFIT
NURSING PROGRAMS OFFER.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE BENEFITS OF
OPEN ACCESS AND FLEXIBILITY COME
AT A HIGH FINANCIAL COST.
ACCREDITED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE PERFECTLY POSITIONED TO
OFFER STUDENTS A SEAMLESS
PATHWAY TO A BSN DEGREE. ONE
THAT IS ACCESSIBLE, AFFORDABLE
AND HIGH QUALITY. NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION REQUIRES PROGRAMS
TO DEMONSTRATE HIGH STANDARDS OF
EXCELLENCE WITH REGARD TO THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF FACULTY,
AVAILABILITY OF RESOURCES, AND
THE ACHIEVEMENT OF Kò PROGRAM
OUTCOMES. AND LET ME ASSURE YOU
THAT OFFERING THE BSN AT SELECT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL NOT
IMPACT THE AVAILABILITY OF
CLINICAL SPACE TO SUGGEST
OTHERWISE IS FALSE NARRATIVE.
THE CLINICAL COURSEWORK IN A BSN
PROGRAM IS COMPLETED POST
LICENSURE, ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
FULFILL THEIR CLINICAL
REQUIREMENTS AND AN EVEN BROADER
VARIETY OF COMMUNITY SETTINGS
THAT ARE NOT TYPICALLY USED TO
MEET THE CLINICAL OBJECTIVES OF
PRE-LICENSURE PROGRAMS. SO I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY SUPPORT
FOR SB 895, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME, WE'D LOVE FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE TO COME FORWARD
AND STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. GOOD MORNING.
VANESSA GONZALEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
DEAR SENATORS. DEAN GRAFILO WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF LA. AND MR.
CHAIR, PER YOUR WARM, WELCOMING,
ELASTIC WAISTED DENIM IS
TRENDING. THANK YOU. RIGHT. I
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THESE ARE
LEVI'S 505 NÓ ELASTIC IN THE
WAISTBAND. GOOD MORNING, GRACE
COPLAND. ON BEHALF OF PROVIDENCE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING DOCTOR
ELIZABETH RILEY FROM CERRITOS
COLLEGE. SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DOCTOR CHERYL CREARY FROM
EVERGREEN VALLEY COLLEGE IN SAN
JOSE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA, PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF
THE BILL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. JUSTIN
FANS, ON BEHALF OF MERCED
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING JOE.
SIGNS ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, PETER KELLISON,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR HEALTH SERVICES
AT HOME IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
SIERRA COOK WITH SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MOLLY ROBSON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OKAY, I HAVE A LONG LIST.
SO MARK MCDONALD, ON BEHALF OF
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY, CONTRA
COSTA, FOOTHILL, DE ANZA, KERN,
MOUNT SAN JACINTO, PALO VERDE,
PERALTA, SAN DIEGO, SAN
BERNARDINO, SOUTHWESTERN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS, AND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACCALAUREATE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, STEPHANIE GOLDMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, JANICE O'MALLEY WITH
AFSCME CALIFORNIA PROUD CODE
SPONSORS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, ANNA MATHEWS WITH
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MICHELLE RISINGER FROM SIERRA
COLLEGE IN ROCKLIN. AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, CARRIE FOGEL, SIERRA
COLLEGE NURSING STUDENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARIA
BELLO'S LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT CO-SPONSOR AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ASHLEY WALKER WITH
NOSSAMAN, ON BEHALF OF NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND CITRUS COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, LINDA VASQUEZ Ã,
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, BRIAN
RIX WITH THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, DOCTOR
SHERRY LOWEN, SADDLEBACK
COLLEGE. AND FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY STRONG WORKFORCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CASEY ELLIOTT ON BEHALF
OF COAST RANCHO SANTIAGO AND
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. KYLE
HIGHLAND, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MANNY DIAZ,
SAN JOSE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT, VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. FIONA RASHEED WITH
SADDLEBACK COLLEGE IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. DANIELLE LURIA
FROM MIRACOSTA COLLEGE IN
OCEANSIDE, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SABRINA MEANS ON BEHALF
OF PASADENA CITY COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR, DAVID NEVIN,
ON BEHALF OF SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE, ALAN HANCOCK CUESTA,
SANTA BARBARA CITY COLLEGE, AS
WELL AS PROUD CO-SPONSORS, EL
CAMINO COLLEGE AND CERRITOS
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
BEFORE WE GO TO OPPOSITION,
LET'S ESTABLISH A CORE AMOUNT OF
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. NEWMAN HERE. NEWMAN HERE.
OCHOA. BOGUE OCHOA HERE. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. HERE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK PRESENT.
WILK. PRESENT. A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO LEAD OPPOSITION TO ANY
OPPOSITION. WITNESSES HERE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE BILL, TWO
OF YOU CAN TAKE THREE MINUTES
EACH, IF YOU SO CHOOSE. AND I
DON'T HAVE YOU LISTED. SO IF YOU
COULD STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR ANN STOLTZ. I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NURSING PROGRAM
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC AND
I WAS THE DIRECTOR AT FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE TOURO UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF NURSING, AND WAS THE
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, SACRAMENTO, AS WELL.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES OF
NURSING, I'M SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 895 CÁC, AN
WELCOMES DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW
TO ADDRESS NURSING EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE ISSUES AND HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ALL OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE HAVE
INSTITUTED SINCE THE EARLY 2000.
BUT THIS BILL FAILS TO ADDRESS
THE UNDERLYING CHALLENGES
PREVENTING AN INCREASE IN THE
BSN NURSING WORKFORCE AND IN
FACT, SERVES TO INCREASE
EXISTING BARRIERS. THE REASONS
THAT WE CANNOT, AS A SCHOOL
ENROLL, INCREASE OUR ENROLLMENTS
IN OUR EXISTING NURSING PROGRAMS
ARE THE LACK OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND THE LACK OF
QUALIFIED FACULTY. NEITHER OF
THESE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL AND THEREFORE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT ADD A
SINGLE RN STUDENT TO THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE, ADDING THE
ABILITY FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO AWARD THE BSN DOES NOT
INCREASE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF RNS
AND THE ADN GRADUATE IS AN RN
WITH THE SAME SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
AS A BSN PREPARED NURSE.
ADDITIONALLY, THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF BSN
PREPARED NURSES IS BEING MET
THROUGH THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST AT PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES. ACCORDING
TO THE UCSF 2022 SURVEY OF RNS
IN CALIFORNIA, 75.1% OF RN'S ARE
EDUCATED AT THE BSN LEVEL OR
HIGHER. THE COLLABORATIVE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE ONLINE AND
CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT MODELS
WITH PATHWAYS TO THE BSN IN AS
LITTLE AS TWO ADDITIONAL
SEMESTERS, AND WE SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING THE EXPANSION OF
THESE MODEL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE, RATHER THAN
CREATING STANDALONE PROGRAMS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
DISINCENTIVIZE THE
INTERSEGMENTAL PIPELINE MODELS
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF BSN
PREPARED NURSES, I PROPOSE THAT
RATHER THAN INVESTING IN A FEW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, WE SHOULD
FOCUS RESOURCES ON EXPANDING
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AND PIPELINE
PROGRAMS TO LEVERAGE EXISTING
PATHWAYS AND INCENTIVIZE NURSES
TO TAKE ON FACULTY ROLES AND
HOSPITALS TO ACCEPT MORE
STUDENTS, ACCORDING TO RESEARCH
FROM UCSF. THE NURSING SHORTAGE
IN THE STATE IS EXPECTED TO BE
RESOLVED IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS,
WHICH BEGS THE QUESTION OF WHY
ADD MORE BSN PROGRAMS IF THE
ISSUE IS RURAL ACCESS? THERE ARE
PLETHORA OF ONLINE BSN PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY OFFERED BY MULTIPLE
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE. SO,
IN SHORT, A SENATE BILL 895 DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE NURSING SHORTAGE
AND MAY HAVE UNINTENDED UPSTREAM
EFFECTS THAT DECREASE THIS
CRITICAL SUPPLY OF RNS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE
AND, I PROPOSE THAT YOU VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I AM
RAMONA TARR. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR HERE TO PRESENT
ASSISTANCE POSITION ON SENATE
BILL 895. WHILE THE CSU IS
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF SENATOR
ROTH'S ATTEMPTS TO PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S
WORK, NURSING WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES, THE CSU BELIEVES
THAT SB 895 WILL NOT ACCOMPLISH
ITS INTENDED GOALS. THE CSU
PRIDES ITSELF IN PROVIDING
PROGRAMS TO EDUCATE AND TRAIN
CALIFORNIA'S NURSING WORKFORCE
AT ALL LEVELS. HOWEVER, THE
STATE FACES SYSTEMATIC AND
INFRASTRUCTURAL CHALLENGES,
WHICH HINDERS ALL NURSING
PROGRAMS FROM GROWING AND
EXPANDING. SPECIFICALLY, THE
LIMITED AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND OVERREGULATION BY
THE STATE'S BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. BOTH IMPACT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH IN OUR NURSING PROGRAMS.
THESE CHALLENGES ARE NOT UNIQUE
TO THE CSU AND WILL BE EQUALLY
AFFECT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHILE LIMITING THE STATE'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF NURSES AND ADD TO THE
CHALLENGES WE ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING. THE CSU BELIEVES
THAT ADDRESSING THESE SPECIFIC
ISSUES WILL BENEFIT ALL PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE NURSING PROGRAMS. TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES FACING
THE STATE, THE CSU HAS DEVELOPED
SOLUTIONS AS SUCH AS PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE INCREASED
ACCESSIBILITY, AS WELL AS
ACCELERATED PATHWAYS FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THESE PATHWAYS AND
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS OFFER
CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT, WITH MANY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
STREAMLINING THE PATHWAY FOR
STUDENTS SEEKING THEIR
ASSOCIATE'S AND BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN NURSING AT AN
ACCELERATED RATE. THE CSU HAS
ALSO DEVELOPED A ROBUST
INFRASTRUCTURE IN NURSING
EDUCATION THAT EASES ACCESS,
FLEXIBILITY AND NO LONGER LIMITS
STUDENTS EDUCATION TO THE REGION
WHERE THEY LIVE. THESE
INFRASTRUCTURES ALLOW FACULTY TO
TEACH ONLINE AND EVEN AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT THOSE
STUDENTS ARE AT. THESE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS BENEFIT
STUDENTS IN RURAL REGIONS AND
PROVIDES A FLEXIBILITY FOR
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS AS WELL.
THE CSU HAS THE CAPACITY TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT, BUT IS
HINDERED BY THOSE EXTERNAL
BARRIERS. THE CSU BELIEVES IN
FURTHER INVESTMENT IN THESE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS PROVIDES A
RETURN ON INVESTMENT THAT WILL
BENEFIT ALL SEGMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE, BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THE STUDENTS THAT SEEK TO ENTER
THE NURSING WORKFORCE. WHILE
THIS LEGISLATION AIMS TO CREATE
MORE BSN GRADUATES, IT DOES NOT
INCREASE THE STATE'S NURSING
WORKFORCE SUPPLY OR NURSING
PROGRAM CAPACITY FOR THE REASONS
STATED ABOVE, AS WELL AS A
STRONG OBJECTION TO DUPLICATION
OF PROGRAMS AND THE PRESIDENT
THIS BILL WILL CREATE. THE CSU
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO
VOTE TO SB 895. I THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
AN OPPOSITION POSITION TO THE
BILL? PLEASE COME FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ALEX
GRAVES WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES, REPRESENTING
90 PRIVATE, NONPROFIT COLLEGES,
INCLUDING ABOUT TWO DOZEN THAT
HAVE NURSING PROGRAMS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. STEVE RAINE,
REPRESENTING THE ACADEMIC SENATE
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 895, WE REQUEST A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS BRIAN HOWE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, THIS IS A ONE TIME
THAT WE ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH
THE MANAGEMENT WITH THE CSU,
THIS IS THE ONE ONE ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE TO OPPOSE, WE APOLOGIZE
TO THE SENATOR, BUT THIS BILL
CREATES A CHILLING EFFECT FOR
OUR WORKFORCE, YOU KNOW, VERSUS
THIS, BACHELOR. AND THEN WHAT
NEXT? SO WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER, THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT THIS MEASURE
POSES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
LET'S COME BACK TO THE DSP. AND
SO LET ME START FIRST BY SAYING
TO SENATOR ROTH, THANK, THANK
YOU FOR WORKING, SORT OF
CLOSELY. AND WITH A LOT OF BACK
AND FORTH WITH ME AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL, AND I'LL
HOLD I HAVE SOME OTHER QUESTIONS
WHICH I'LL HOLD. LET ME
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, CONCERNS FOR THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL, SENATOR
OCHOA. YES I'M GOING TO GO. SO
FIRST, I COMMEND YOU FOR WORKING
ON ON THIS MEASURE. I KNOW IT'S
CHALLENGING. ON THAT, WE HAD
EARLY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT YOUR
INTENT ON ON MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. I'VE ALSO
I'M VERY COGNIZANT AS TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR CURRENT
SCHOOLS HAVE IN THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT OF OUR NURSES, THE
ABILITY FOR THIS BODY, THE
LEGISLATURE, TO ALLOW YOU TO
EXPAND, VERY MUCH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE, THE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU FOLKS FACE ON THAT, IN THAT
COMPONENT, ON THAT END. SO THERE
IS SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD DO TO
EXPAND OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS, TO
BE ABLE TO DO MORE IN THAT. AND
I IF I RECALL CORRECTLY, I THINK
IN ONE OF OUR EARLIER MEETINGS,
WE HAD TALKED ABOUT, IN OUR
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS, WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT, ALSO, IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY, I THINK IT WAS IN
THAT CAPACITY, ON WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS AN ACCURATE COUNT OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT WAS THE CASE OR
NOT. IF ANYBODY HERE HAS THAT
INFORMATION, I'LL BE WANTING TO
HEAR IT ON THAT END. BUT I, I
BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS THE CASE.
IT WAS, NOT QUITE AN ACCURATE
ACCOUNT OF WHERE OUR NURSES
COULD BE TAKEN. SO THEY HAVE A,
YOU KNOW, THE OPPOSITION HAS A
VALID POINT IN WHICH, YOU KNOW,
IF WE WERE TO CREATE THIS
PROGRAM, WE STILL HAVE THE ISSUE
OF THE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. NOW,
THAT COULD BE REMEDIED BY
UNDERSTANDING WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS AN ACCURATE COUNT OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE OUR CURRENT SYSTEMS
IN MOVING FORWARD. ON THAT END,
THE OTHER QUESTION, I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF, YOU WANT ME TO ANSWER
THEM ONE AT A TIME OR. OH, SURE.
YES BECAUSE I DO HAVE A COUPLE,
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL,
REMEMBER THIS, BILL, THIS PILOT
PROGRAM ONLY APPLIES TO
ASSOCIATE DEGREED NURSES WHO ARE
PASSED THE EXAM AND ARE LICENSED
AS RNS. SO THEY ALREADY HAD
THEIR CLINICAL PLACEMENT. YOU
DON'T YOU'RE NOT ADMITTED INTO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAM AS AN RN ADN CANDIDATE
WITHOUT A CLINICAL PLACEMENT.
THESE FOLKS HAVE MOVED THROUGH
THE PROGRAM, AND THIS IS THE ADD
ON AT THE END. AFTER THEIR
LICENSED. SO I UNDERSTAND I
MEAN, I'M LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION TALK ABOUT CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO AND DOES NOT
INTERFERE ONE BIT WITH ANYBODY'S
CLINICAL PLACEMENT. DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY A CLINICAL PLACEMENT FROM A
CSU SCHOOL OR A PRIVATE SCHOOL
PUBLIC FOR PROFIT OR NONPROFIT.
SECONDLY, I DO AGREE THAT THERE
IS A DEFICIT IN THE STATE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
ARE. AND SO FOR THAT REASON,
WE'RE MOVING A CLINICAL
PLACEMENT BILL THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR THAT
REQUIRES HEALTH FACILITIES, BOTH
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS LICENSED
BY HCA TO REPORT BOTH CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS THAT ARE UTILIZED AND
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE, TO HCI AND THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING, AND GIVES
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
THE AUTHORITY TO WORK WITH THE
SCHOOLS DIRECTLY TO TRY TO
LOCATE AVAILABLE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS, NOT TO DISPLACE
ANYBODY WHO HAS ONE, BUT TO
LOCATE AVAILABLE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND MATCH THOSE UP
WITH NURSING SCHOOLS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE. SO WE'RE WORKING ON
THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT ISSUE,
BUT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPACT
ANYONE'S CLINICAL PLACEMENT OR
THE AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS OR THE UTILIZATION OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS, BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL ARE NURSES LICENSED, THEY
NEED NO CLINICAL PLACEMENTS.
PERFECT. GREAT POINT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU IS WHAT TIMELINE
WOULD THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS NEED TO EVEN SCALE UP
TO THE BACHELOR LEVELS PROGRAM,
AND WOULD THERE BE FACULTY
HIRING NEEDS? WOULD YOU NEED A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF ACCREDITATION
FOR THAT? IT'S ABOUT, WELL, IT
VARIES, BUT PROBABLY 12 TO 18
MONTHS IS GOING TO TAKE TO GET
PROGRAMS RAIMES SET UP.
CREDENTIALED IS WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. I GUESS IT DEPENDS
ON HOW FAST YOU MOVE AND HOW
EXPERIENCED YOU ARE. OTHER WILL
NEED TO BE THE BSN PIECE WILL
NEED TO BE CREDENTIALED IN ORDER
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
SELECTED TO AWARD A BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE IN NURSING DEGREES. SO
THERE WILL BE THAT. THE THOUGHT
IS THAT PERHAPS THESE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT ARE SELECTED CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO DEVELOP A
UNIFORM ADDITIONAL CURRICULUM TO
COVER WHATEVER IT IS. THE 30
EXTRA HOURS, SO THAT IT'S A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL, TO HELP EACH
OTHER MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
IF THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION AS
TO FACULTY, REMEMBER THESE ARE
30 HOURS. SOME OF THE ONE OF THE
COURSES ARE MAYBE MORE THAN ONE
ARE HUMANITIES. THAT'S WHAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TEACH, IN
RIVERSIDE, RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE, THE CHANCELLOR TELLS
ME, HAS MORE EMPLOYED PHDS THAN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
RIVERSIDE. SO FACULTY MEMBERS
ARE QUALIFIED. THERE ARE FACULTY
MEMBERS. SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S A FACULTY MEMBER HIRING
REQUIRED, I WOULD SUSPECT IT
WOULD BE FAIRLY MINIMAL. AND BY
THE WAY, THE THIS PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO BE REVENUE NEUTRAL.
SO DISTRICTS THAT ARE SELECTED
FOR THE PROGRAM SIGN UP TO THE
PROPOSITION THAT THEY HAVE TO
FUND THE PROGRAM WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES. AND ACTUALLY, THAT'S
WHERE MY NEXT QUESTION, WAS
HEADING. ACCORDING TO THE LAO
NOTES THAT THE NURSING PROGRAMS
ARE COSTLY TO OPERATE AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ARGUMENT
FROM PROPONENT PROPONENTS OF SB
895 AND THE COST TO THE STATE
FOR THE EXPANSION OF BSN TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, THAT WILL BE
NONEXISTENT. AND THAT THAT, OF
COURSE, IS A MISUNDERSTANDING OF
THE PROGRAM. REMEMBER IN ORDER
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PILOT
PROGRAM AND ENTER IT, YOU HAVE
TO BE AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE NURSE,
PASS THE NCLEX WITH AN RN. THE
EXPENSIVE PART OF THE PROGRAM IS
THE NURSING CLINICAL PIECE, THE
BRICK AND MORTAR, THE LOW
STUDENT TO FACULTY RATIOS, THE
EXPENSE OF THE EQUIPMENT AND THE
SIMULATION EQUIPMENT THAT ARE
REQUIRED FOR THE CLINICAL PIECE
OF UNDERGRADUATE NURSING
EDUCATION. WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THIS. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY ARE NURSES,
WHO HAVE THE MAY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IF THIS BILL HAPPENS
TO PASS, TO TAKE A HUMANITIES
COURSE, AND NURSING LEADERSHIP
AND NURSING MANAGEMENT COURSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN. USUALLY IT'S
ABOUT ONE COMMUNITY HEALTH,
PROGRAM WHERE YOU LINK UP WITH A
NURSE OR YOU LINK UP IN A CLINIC
, YOU'RE NOT DEALING WITH
SIMULATION LABS. YOU'RE NOT
WORKING IN HOSPITALS WHERE THE
HIGH EXPENSE OF NURSING
PROGRAMS, IN FACT, EXISTS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL, ANSWERS. AND ONE
LAST QUESTION, MR. CHAIR, IF YOU
INDULGE ME A BIT, I'M JUST GOING
TO CURIOUS AS TO THE OPPOSITION
FROM THE ACADEMIC SENATE AS TO
WHY THEY'RE IN OPPOSITION TO IT.
IF YOU DON'T MIND. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME BACK. STEVE REIN, ACADEMIC
SENATE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. A LOT OF
REASONS. BUT I'LL JUST SAY FOR
ONE, COST EXPANDING EXISTING CSU
NURSING DEGREE PROGRAMS WILL BE
LESS EXPENSIVE FOR THE STATE
THAN AN EXPENSIVE PILOT PROGRAM
TO OFFER A BSN THROUGH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE HAVE EXISTING
CAPACITY IF OUR SPACES ARE
LIMITED BY THE BOARD OF NURSING,
WE CAN'T OFFER MORE STUDENTS
PLACEMENT. THE OBVIOUS SOLUTION
IN MY MIND IS TO OFFER MORE
NURSING PLACEMENT OPTIONS OR
DEGREE PROGRAM ADMITS IN CSU
PROGRAMS. WE CURRENTLY ALSO HAVE
EXCESS CAPACITY IN THE 80
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE OF NURSING TO
BSN PROGRAMS THAT CSU'S ALREADY
HAVE. SO THAT'S A QUICK SUMMARY.
I COULD GO ON IF YOU'D LIKE. NO,
I'M GOOD WITH THAT. THANK YOU.
AND ONE FINAL, AND I'M NOT SURE
WHO THIS GOES TO. YOUR SECOND
FINAL QUESTION. GO AHEAD. IS
THAT. YES. SORRY. MY FOLLOW UP.
JUST JUST ENLIGHTENING, IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MANY OF OUR
NURSING PROGRAMS ACTUALLY HAVE
WAITING LISTS TO BE ABLE TO,
MOVE FORWARD IN, IN, IN
DIFFERENT AT DIFFERENT
UNIVERSITIES. CURRENTLY. I'M
KIND OF CURIOUS IF ANYBODY KNOWS
THE STATISTICS AS TO THE WAITING
LIST TO BE ABLE TO ENTER THOSE
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY IN PLACE. AND
THE REASON BEING IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, COVID REALLY SHOWED US THE
FACT THAT WE ARE IN EXTREME
SHORTAGE. AND I KNOW THE
ESTIMATES ARE THAT WE WERE GOING
TO BE UP TO PAR BY 2026, BUT
CURRENTLY MOVING FORWARD AS
POPULATION GROWS AND HOPEFULLY
WE KEEP OUR CALIFORNIANS INSTEAD
OF FLEEING THE STATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE NEEDING, MORE NURSES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. SO, I COULD
ANSWER THAT. I CAN ANSWER FOR MY
PROGRAM. SO WE CURRENTLY ADMIT
40 EACH SEMESTER, AND WE HAVE WE
TURN AWAY ABOUT 300, 350 JUST
FOR ONE PROGRAM AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC. AND IT'S
AN IT'S A MISS, AN ENTRY LEVEL
MISS N N DEGREE PROGRAM, ONE
OTHER ISSUE IS THAT THE IF
THEY'RE GOING TO OFFER THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE CERTIFICATE,
THERE ARE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND RIGHT
NOW THOSE ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET. THEY'RE NOT TRACKED AS AS
MUCH AS THE CLINICAL HOSPITAL
PLACEMENTS. BUT THE RN
PLACEMENTS ARE VERY, VERY RARE
AND HARD TO GET. SO I WOULD I
WOULD DISAGREE THAT, IT WON'T
IMPACT CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. IT
WILL AT THE  N LEVEL. MAY I
RESPOND TO THAT? YES YOU MAY.
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT. IT WAS MY
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT AS
PART OF A BSN PROGRAM, THERE'S
SOME COMMUNITY HEALTH, COURSE
THAT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN BY THE
NURSE IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR
THE BACHELOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE
IN NURSING. THIS IS NOT INTENDED
TO EVEN BEGIN TO APPROACH A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. SO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT, BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL.
WELL AND TO THAT POINT, IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND EXPANDING RIGHT?
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
AMBIGUITY, YOU KNOW, AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS AS TO WHAT THIS IS,
WHAT THIS ISN'T RIGHT. AND
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
WORKFORCE CHALLENGE AND A
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT. SO IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CLARIFYING LIKE,
WELL, WHAT YOU KNOW, THIS BILL
IS NOT INTENDED TO ADDRESS OR
SOLVE THE SHORTAGE. CORRECT?
RIGHT. IT'S INTENDED TO ADDRESS
A CHANGING ENVIRONMENT IN THE
NURSING FIELD, IN THE WORKPLACE
WHERE WHERE HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
FACILITIES, EITHER BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THEY NEED TO FOR
CREDENTIALING REASONS OR
ACCREDITATION REASONS, OR FOR
ANY OTHER REASON ARE MOVING
TOWARD PREFERENCING BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE DEGREE NURSES. AND OF
COURSE, WE'RE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHERE 40% OF THE
RN'S THAT COME OUT OF OUR OUR
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE ARE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE NURSES. AND SO
IF WE DON'T MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS SOMEHOW, WHETHER
IT'S EXPANDING EXISTING BRICK
AND MORTAR FACILITIES AT THE CSU
OR LET THE PRIVATES TAKE THE
MARKET OR WORK ON A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS, THAT MAKES SOME SMALL
INCREMENTAL CHANGE. WHERE ARE
OUR ASSOCIATE DEGREE NURSES
GOING TO WORK IN THE FUTURE?
CONVALESCENT CARE FACILITIES. WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO ADJUST OUR,
OUR PROGRAMS TO MEET THE DEMAND.
THE EVER EVOLVING DEMANDS OF THE
WORKPLACE. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROGRAM DOES. IT DOESN'T. WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO MEET THE OVERALL
SHORTAGE OF NURSES. WE'RE NOT
CREATING, A BSN PROGRAMS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE THE
COLLEGE TAKES IN STUDENTS IN A
LARGE SCALE AND, AND TRIES TO
COMPETE WITH THE CSUS. WE'RE
WE'RE IT SHOULD BE A TEAM EFFORT
HERE. AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
I'M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED, IF I
MAY CONTINUE, MR. CHAIR, YOU'RE
NOT. YOU'RE WELL ON YOUR WAY. GO
AHEAD. I'M A LITTLE, AS THEY
SAID IN ANIMAL HOUSE. YOU'RE ON
A ROLL. I'VE BEEN AROUND A LONG
TIME, AND I'VE WORKED ON THESE
HEALTH CARE ISSUES IN AND OUT OF
THE LEGISLATURE FOR A LONG TIME.
AND I REMEMBER THE EARLY 2000
WHEN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY DECIDED TO CHALLENGE
THE MASTER PLAN ITSELF AS AN
INSTITUTION, AND IT WAS
CHANCELLOR CHARLES REED AT THE
TIME WHO DECIDED THAT CSU SHOULD
BEGIN OFFERING AN EDUCATION
DOCTORATE DEGREE. WELL, THOSE OF
YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE MASTER
PLAN KNOW THAT DOCTORATE DEGREES
WERE, AT THE TIME RESERVED FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM, AND THERE WAS A BIG
FIGHT AND THE ARGUMENTS MADE BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AT THE TIME WERE, WE NEED TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE
WORKPLACE. WE EDUCATE
UNDERGRADUATE TEACHERS. WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER ADVANCED
DEGREES UP THROUGH THE EDUCATION
DOCTORATE IN ORDER TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF THE WORKPLACE. THE
DEBATE OCCURRED RIGHT HERE IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
, WHERE YOU SEE, OBVIOUSLY WAS
OPPOSED, CITING THE MASTER PLAN.
AND OF COURSE, YOU SEE
ULTIMATELY LOST. AND THE CSU WAS
AWARDED THE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO AWARD ED.D. THE
SAME PROGRAM AND PROCESS MOVED
THROUGH THE MOVE THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE. WHEN WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT DOCTOR OF PHYSICAL
THERAPY, WHICH THE WORKPLACE WAS
DEMANDING, AND DOCTOR OF NURSING
PRACTICE, WHICH THE WORKPLACE
WAS DEMANDING. AND IN FACT, WE
NEED MORE OF FOR OUR NURSING
FACULTY AT ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
PUBLIC. AND I APPRECIATE YOU.
AND SO THAT SORT OF JURISDICTION
ARGUMENT CONTINUES. RIGHT. IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A SUBTEXT HERE. AND IF
I COULD SOME CLARIFICATION. SO
MR. RAINES FROM THE CSU MADE THE
ARGUMENT THAT THE CSU WOULD BE A
LESS EXPENSIVE, SORT OF
INSTITUTION TO DO THIS, BUT BUT
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHY
NOT, SENATOR ROTH, FOCUS ON MORE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE CSU AS AS
A SORT OF AN INTRINSIC COMPONENT
OF THIS BILL? WELL, AS YOU KNOW,
THE PIPELINE PROGRAM REFERENCED
IN YOUR EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WAS A PIPELINE PROGRAM
THAT MY TEAM AND I FACILITATED
IN OUR OFFICE DISTRICT OFFICE IN
RIVERSIDE, CALIFORNIA, STARTING
WITH A MEETING WITH THE I THINK
IT WAS THE EXECUTIVE VICE
CHANCELLOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM, THE
PRESIDENTS OF CAL STATE
FULLERTON AND CAL STATE SAN
BERNARDINO, THE NURSING SCHOOL
DEANS, THE PROVOSTS, AND THROUGH
A SERIES OF MEETINGS. WHAT
RESULTED WAS AN EFFORT TO BUILD
THAT WAS SUCCESSFUL COMMON
CURRICULUM TO PROVIDE FOR DUAL
CREDENTIALING OF FACULTY MEMBERS
AND DUAL AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
DUAL ENROLLMENT OF STUDENTS
REFERENCED BY THE RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE NURSING DEAN. SO WHEN
STUDENTS AND THE PROGRAM WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN RIVERSIDE, IT WAS
BRIEFED TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLORS,
ALL OF THEM. IT WAS THEY TOOK IT
ON THE ROAD NATIONALLY. IT'S THE
SUBJECT OF A PEER REVIEWED
JOURNAL ARTICLE ON THE SUCCESS
OF PIPELINE PROGRAMS, AND IT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO CAN AND FIND
THEMSELVES ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE PROGRAM
ARE THE PROBLEMS THAT THE RCC
NURSING SCHOOL DEAN HIGHLIGHTED.
ONE, WE HAVE CSU ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS THAT NOT ALL
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAN MEET IN TERMS OF GPA
AND THE LIKE WE HAVE WE HAVE A
FLEXIBILITY ISSUE WITH THE WAY,
IN SOME CASES, THE CSU PIPELINE
PROGRAMS AND THE COURSES THAT
CSU OFFER, ARE STRUCTURED IN
TERMS OF WE HAVE, IN MANY CASES,
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE PLACE BOUND. THEY HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE SICK OR
ILL NEED CARE. THEY HAVE JOBS
THAT THEY NEED TO WORK IN ORDER
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. AND
THEY CANNOT BE THAT FAR FROM
THEIR HOME. WITH RESPECT TO
ONLINE ACCESS, WE KNOW THAT
HERE, WITH ALL THE DEBATES THAT
WE ENGAGE IN ON BROADBAND ACCESS
ONLINE, WORKS FOR SOME STUDENTS.
IT DOES NOT WORK FOR OTHERS
EITHER, BECAUSE THE BROADBAND IS
NOT SUFFICIENT OR THEY DON'T
LEARN EFFECTIVELY THAT WAY. AND
SO WE HAVE PRESENTLY ABOUT 40 TO
50 STUDENTS SPLIT BETWEEN FULLER
IN RIVERSIDE, SPLIT BETWEEN
FULLERTON AND SAN BERNARDINO AT
THE CAL STATES IN THE PIPELINE
PROGRAM. THE STUDENTS THAT WANT
THE PIPELINE PROGRAM SELECT THE
PIPELINE PROGRAM. REMEMBER, THEY
ALSO HAVE TO PAY CSU FEES, NOT
JUST COMMUNITY COLLEGE FEES, IN
ORDER TO PARTICIPATE, THERE'S NO
STATUTORY PROHIBITION ON THE
EXPANSION OF PIPELINE PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT I SAY TO MY FRIENDS AT
CSU AND THE AND THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IS IF YOU WANT TO
EXPAND THE PIPELINE PROGRAMS, I
WILL HELP YOU. BUT WE ENGAGED IN
OUR EFFORT, I DON'T KNOW, FIVE,
SIX, SEVEN YEARS AGO, AND
THERE'S BEEN PLENTY OF TIME TO
ALLOW PLENTY OF EXPANSION IN
PIPELINE PROGRAMS WHERE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WANT THEM AND
WHERE THERE'S A DEMAND BY THE
STUDENTS. MR. CHAIR, I
APPRECIATE THAT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, A FEW
COMMENTS? SURE KEEP BRIEFLY
PLEASE. SO IN REGARDS TO THE YOU
KNOW, WHAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN, THIS IS
NOT A DEBATE IN REGARDS TO WHO
OWNS WHAT. THE DEGREE WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR MORE BSN STUDENTS, WHETHER
IT BE AT THE CSU OR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR, OUR OPPOSITION IS MORE
IN REGARDS TO THE SUPPORT
NEEDING FOR NURSING EDUCATION.
THERE IS A SEVERE LACK OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. THAT'S ONLY
GOING TO BE COMPOUNDED BY THIS
ISSUE. THIS ISSUE WILL ALSO
COMPOUND THE NEED FOR QUALIFIED
FACULTY. OUR GOAL IS TO INCREASE
THE ACCESSIBILITY FOR ALL
STUDENTS, AND IN REGARDS TO
PLACE BOUND AND THE AVAILABILITY
OF ACCESS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS OR STUDENTS IN RURAL
AREAS. WE DO HAVE PROGRAMS WHERE
FACULTY ACTUALLY TEACH AT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S NOT NEW FOR
US. IT'S PART OF OUR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. AND THANKS TO SENATOR
ROTH'S OFFICE, WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO INNOVATE ON THOSE PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS TO ALLOW OUR FACULTY TO
GO TO THOSE STUDENTS. SO IT'S
NOT JUST AN ONLINE
ACCESSIBILITY. OUR FACULTY CAN
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS WITH MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THIS WITH. AND THEN LASTLY, IN
REGARDS TO TUITION AND FEES THAT
STUDENTS HAVE TO PAY, WE'RE
REALLY COMMITTED TO INCREASING
ACCESSIBILITY TO ALL STUDENTS,
AND A LOT OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
WORKED ON GETTING PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIPS AND GRANTS FOR OUR
STUDENTS IN ORDER TO LOWER THE
FEES OR EVEN GET THEM THEIR FEES
TOTALLY ELIMINATED. WE RECENTLY
REVISITED OUR STUDENT
UNDERGRADUATE GRANTS TO ALLOW
STUDENTS THAT ARE PART TIME TO
ALSO RECEIVE THOSE GRANTS TO
LOWER THEIR TUITION. SO THERE'S
A VARIETY OF MECHANISMS, I
THINK, IN TOOLS THAT ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE WITHIN OUR CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN
CONTINUALLY BE INVESTED ON. AND
I THINK IT'S A MORE EFFECTIVE
AND TURN AROUND TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THESE SORT OF PROGRAMS
THAT WON'T TAKE 18 MONTHS. IT
WILL TAKE A MOUSE SIX MONTHS AT
A MINIMUM TO GET THESE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS UP AND
EXPANDED A LITTLE BIT MORE. I
APPRECIATE THAT. MR. YOU CAN
COME FORWARD. I'M SORRY. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A PROPER
HEARING. RIGHT. SO SORRY WE YOU
LOST YOUR SEAT HERE AT THE
TABLE. YEAH TAMMY HALL, DEAN OF
NURSING AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE I WAS JUST GOING TO
COMMENT ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PIECE. I'VE. EXCUSE ME. I WAS
VERY FORTUNATE TO BE AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE GRADUATE
MYSELF, BUT VERY FORTUNATE TO GO
TO VERY INNOVATIVE SCHOOLS FOR
MY BACHELOR'S, MASTER'S, PHD, SO
ON. AND I'VE SEEN THIS DONE, THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PIECE, THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH PIECE, AND VERY
INNOVATIVE WAYS. AND, AND,
AGAIN, THESE ARE LICENSED
NURSES, FOR INSTANCE, FOR ME, I
DID MY LEADERSHIP AND PUBLIC
HEALTH THROUGH MY EMPLOYER. SO
IT BENEFITED MY EMPLOYER AS WELL
. I DIDN'T NEED EXTRA CLINICAL
SPACES. I JUST WORKED WITH MY
EMPLOYER. SO I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT ON THAT. OKAY. YOU KNOW,
BEFORE WE LEAVE THIS AND SENATOR
CORTEZ, YOU HAVE A QUESTION,
WITH RESPECT TO QUALIFIED
FACULTY, YOU AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED, I MEAN, THIS IS
ACTUALLY PART OF THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS PROGRAM,
RIGHT? TO EXACTLY. AT SOME
POINT, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE AND I'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH MY FRIENDS AT
CSU ABOUT THIS, THE ONE THING
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES NEVER
WILL BE ABLE TO DO IN MY
LIFETIME AND BEYOND IS AWARD
MASTER'S DEGREES IN NURSING AND
DOCTORATE IN DOCTORATES IN NURSE
AND DOCTORS OF NURSE PRACTICE,
BOTH OF WHICH ARE REQUIRED ONE
TO BUILD A CADRE OF MORE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS, INCLUDING NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN INDEPENDENT
SETTINGS WHO CAN GO INTO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND GO INTO
COACHELLA AND EASTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND THE DESERTS IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WHERE THERE
ARE FEW DOCTORS AND ALSO THE
DOCTOR OF NURSE PRACTICE DEGREE
TO BUILD MORE FACULTY IN NURSING
PROGRAMS. WE'RE WORKING ON THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS TO TRY TO
LOCATE THEM IN FQHCS AND CLINICS
, REMOTE CLINICS WHERE WE CAN
PUT NURSING STUDENTS TO TRAIN
THE CSUS AND THOSE AND THE
PRIVATES THAT ARE ABLE TO AWARD
MASTER'S DEGREES AND DOCTOR
DEGREES. WE NEED THEM TO,
FRANKLY, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
CONCENTRATE THEIR EFFORTS AND
BOOST THEIR PRODUCTION. AND OF
COURSE, THE POOL HAVING MORE
BACHELOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE
NURSES IN THE POOL WILL GIVE US
MORE PEOPLE WHO POTENTIALLY WE
CAN RECRUIT INTO THOSE PROGRAMS
TO INCREASE THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE IN THE ADVANCED
PRACTICE AREAS. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ. YEAH. THANK YOU.
SO I'M LEGISLATIVELY VERY
INVESTED IN THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ISSUE, AND I DO THINK
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT FOLKS
WANT TO DEBATE IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH THIS BILL, TOUCHES UPON
THAT ISSUE, IT'S A SEPARATE
LEGISLATIVE ISSUE. I ALWAYS WE
SEE IT A LOT, BUT THERE'S A LOT
OF TIMES WHEN WE SEE SOMEBODY
COMING THROUGH WITH A BILL,
THAT'S FOCUSED ON, YOU KNOW, A
VERY SPECIFIC AREA. AND THE
OTHER ISSUES SURROUNDING, YOU
KNOW, THIS PARTICULAR SPACE, IN
THIS CASE, EDUCATION SPACE, YOU
KNOW, WANT TO BE TALKED ABOUT. I
MEAN, THIS THESE, THESE
COMMITTEES TEND TO BE A FORUM
FOR. OH, BOY. YOU KNOW, WE GET A
CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT ALL THESE
OTHER ISSUES. I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
ON THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
LEGISLATION, AND I APPRECIATE
SENATOR ROTH MENTIONING THAT IN
HIS COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN, BUT, WHAT I, WHAT
I'M NOT CLEAR ON AND IT'S JUST
NOT COMPUTING FOR ME. AND IT'S
GOING TO IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
MEAN I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BECAUSE UNTIL I GET
THIS RESOLVED IN MY MIND, ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER, I'LL EITHER
CONTINUE SUPPORTING THE BILL
LATER OR I WON'T, OR RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO, TO RECONSIDER, BUT WE
HAVE A NURSING SHORTAGE. WE KNOW
THAT THAT'S WHAT THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ISSUES ALL ABOUT,
THAT'S IN PART WITH THIS ISSUE
IS ALL ABOUT. WE HAVE
OUTSTANDING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LIKE THE ONE SQUARE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT, I'VE LIVED NEXT
TO FOR MOST OF MY LIFE IN SAN
JOSE THAT HAVE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED. THERE'S
NO REASON THEY CAN'T HELP WITH
THIS PROBLEM. AND I LIKE SENATOR
ROTH'S POINT ABOUT THIS SHOULD
BE A TEAM EFFORT, I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
TO FACULTY, OF COURSE. THAT'S
THAT SHOULD BE A CONCERN. BUT IF
WE HAVE A NURSING SHORTAGE AND
WE HAVE OPEN POSITIONS, AT THE
CSU, AND WE'RE GETTING
BOTTLENECKED BY CLINICAL
PLACEMENT AND THESE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALSO HAVE CAPACITY,
THEN WE SHOULD BE PUTTING A LOT
OF PEOPLE TO WORK. I MEAN, THIS
ISN'T SHOULDN'T BE A CASE OF
SCARCITY. THIS SHOULD BE A CASE
OF BOTH SYSTEMS SHOULD BE
THRIVING. GIVEN ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE SHORTAGE THAT WE HAVE. I'M
JUST DOING, YOU KNOW, SORT OF
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE,
ARITHMETIC, NOT REALLY MATH.
JUST SAYING, LOOK, HOW COULD YOU
BE DOING A GOOD THING IF WE'VE
GOT A NURSING SHORTAGE BY, YOU
KNOW, BOTTLENECKING EITHER
SYSTEM, WHICH IS CAPABLE, QUITE
CAPABLE OF PRODUCING NURSES IN A
HURRY, OTHER THAN WHATEVER THOSE
BOTTLENECKS ARE. SO I THINK THE
TEAM EFFORT SHOULD BE ON ALL
SIDES. CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, YOU KNOW, REMOVING THE
BOTTLENECKS AND GETTING THE
SYSTEMS BACK. WELL, IN THE CASE
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES, YOU KNOW,
GETTING THEM OPERATING AT THEIR
FULL COMPETENCY IN TERMS OF
EDUCATING NURSES, AND AS FAR AS
THE CSU'S GETTING THEM RUNNING
ON FULL CYLINDERS AGAIN, ON ALL
CYLINDERS AGAIN, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THAT THAT'S THAT'S JUST
SYMPTOMATIC OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE. SO AGAIN, I'M GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL. I'M OPEN
TO HEARING MORE FROM, CFA. AND
YOU KNOW, FOLKS WORRIED ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, WORKER PROTECTION AND
POSITION PROTECTION AND, YOU
KNOW, POSITION CONTROL AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND
PERHAPS THAT WILL CHANGE MY MIND
BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN I SEE THE
BILL AGAIN. BUT I THINK RIGHT
NOW WE NEED TO KEEP THIS GOING
AND TRY TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES, AND APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD AND
TACKLING A THORNY ISSUE. YOU CAN
EITHER RESPOND OR SAVE IT FOR
YOUR CLOSE. YOU RESPOND. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. YOU KNOW, IF WE WERE
OPENING 15 NEW NURSING SCHOOLS
AND FILLING FACULTY SLOTS IN
NURSING SCHOOLS, THAT I THINK
THAT WOULD BE ONE THING. BUT
REMEMBER, WE ALREADY HAVE
NURSING SCHOOLS THAT WHAT 80
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF THEM UP TO 15TH
MAY BE SELECTED FOR THIS PILOT
PROGRAM IF THEY QUALIFY. BUT THE
PILOT PROGRAM DOESN'T INVOLVE
ANY UNDERGRADS AT NURSING
EDUCATION OR TRAINING, WHICH IS
FACULTY INTENSIVE, WHERE YOU
HAVE LOW STUDENT TO FACULTY
RATIOS, LOW STUDENTS, HIGH
FACULTY, VERY EXPENSIVE, THE
IMPACT ON THE FACULTY SITUATION
AT CSUS, THE PRIVATES OR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SHOULD NOT BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL, GIVEN THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF COURSEWORK
COURSE HOURS THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN FOR THE BSN, NON-CLINICAL.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND FROM
MY PART, I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO NOTE
HERE, WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS A PILOT PROGRAM. I THINK THE
ORIGINAL CONCEPT WAS A
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER. WE'VE
REDUCED IT TO 15. WE'VE WE'VE
PLACED SOME PARAMETERS AROUND IT
THAT I THINK YOU JUST TOUCHED
ON. SO NATIONAL ACCREDITATION
AND LEFT TO THE DISCRETION OF
THE CHANCELLOR AT THE END OF THE
DAY, TO CHOOSE THOSE SCHOOLS,
BUT ALSO WITH AN EYE ON, I
THINK, SORT OF THE ESSENTIAL
FEATURE WHICH IS THE PLACE BOUND
NATURE AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
COME WITH THAT, WHICH IS WHY THE
PILOT MAKES SENSE FOR MY PART.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, I MEAN,
THERE'S NOTHING MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE ABOUT THIS PILOT AND
THE CSU KIND OF REDOUBLING ITS
EFFORTS. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW, OVER TIME,
I THINK WE'VE COME TO AN
AGREEMENT THAT THIS IS, IN FACT,
A GOOD APPROACH. THIS IS WHY I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY,
BUT IT'S, AGAIN, RELATIVELY
SMALL CONTRIBUTION BY WAY OF
WORKFORCE. RIGHT. SO 15 OR UP TO
15 TIMES APPROXIMATELY 40. BSNS.
OVER TIME. AND THE PILOT HAS
BEEN DELIBERATELY STRUCTURED TO
ALLOW FOR THE RAMP UP. RIGHT.
AND SO WE WILL SEE, I THINK
AFTER THE SIX YEARS, WE WILL SEE
IF THIS IS A GOOD APPROACH. WE
WILL SEE IF THIS CHANGES THE
DYNAMICS, ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
PLACES THAT ARE, GEOGRAPHICALLY
ISOLATED, WHERE THERE'S PLACE
BOUND STUDENTS, IF IT INCREASES
THE NUMBER WHO MOVE FROM THE ADN
INTO THE BSN PATHWAY. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE CSU'S CONCERN. I
DO APPRECIATE THE LARGER ISSUE
OF, YOU KNOW, THE DISCUSSION. WE
STILL NEED TO HAVE TO RENDER
CLEAR WHAT IS WHAT ARE, YOU
KNOW, THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF CSU C.C.C.
AND IN SOME OTHER CONTEXT, THE
UC BY WAY OF THE KINDS OF
DEGREES OR OFFERINGS THEY THEY
MAY PRESENT, SO WITH THAT, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE, I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION TODAY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. NO ONE
SEEMS TO DISAGREE. THE PUBLIC'S
THE PRIVATES, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, THE HEALTH CARE
COMMUNITY THAT WE NEED MORE
CREDENTIAL NURSES NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE. THE STUDIES AND SURVEYS,
THE WORKPLACE. THE GROWING TREND
TO PREFER BSN STUDENTS IN
HOSPITAL CLINICAL PLACEMENT
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
OF ALL TELL US EXACTLY THAT. SO
GIVEN OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
BUDGET CHALLENGES AND THE HIGH
COST OF SETTING UP AND EXPANDING
UNDERGRAD NURSING PROGRAMS, BOTH
IN TERMS OF THE COST OF THE
EQUIPMENT, THE BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITIES, AND THE LOW STUDENT
TO FACULTY RATIOS, WHY NOT TRY
USING THE UNDERUTILIZED TEAM
MEMBER WITH CAMPUSES MOST
ACCESSIBLE TO STUDENTS? ONE WITH
A CADRE OF FULLY TRAINED AND
LICENSED ADNS READY TO EARN THE
RELATIVELY FEW TWO HUMANITIES
AND LEADERSHIP COURSE UNITS
REQUIRED FOR THE AWARD OF THE
BSN CREDENTIAL AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS THEY
PERFORM CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY DUTIES IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE USE WE USE ALL THE TOOLS IN
OUR TOOL CHEST TO ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL NEED, AND THE TIME TO
TRY IT IS NOW. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE POINT IN
TIME. THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT,
WE NEED A MOTION. THE MOTION IS
FROM SENATOR BOGUE, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE. ITEM ONE, SB 885 ROTH,
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE
OCHOA. BOGH. OKOBOJI. CORTESE.
CORTESE AYE. GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. THAT
MEASURE HAS THREE VOTES. WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS AND STAFF, THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. AND I WILL NOTE, I
THINK THIS IS THE LAST TIME THAT
WE WILL SEE YOU IN THIS
COMMITTEE. SO, YOU KNOW,
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK. NEXT WE HAVE, SB 1115.
SENATOR LIMÓN, WELCOME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, SB 115 TÍNH 1115
PROVIDES PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES IN LITERACY AND
MATHEMATICS FOR TEACHERS AND
STAFF TO HELP CLOSE THE WIDENING
GAPS IN STUDENT ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AND DISPARITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA, APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRD OF BLACK STUDENTS,
AMERICAN INDIAN STUDENTS, AND
HISPANIC LATINO STUDENTS PASSED
LITERACY STANDARDS IN 2023
EXAMS, RESPECTIVELY. LESS THAN
20% PASSED MATH STANDARDS. IN
ADDITION, THE SMARTER BALANCED
SUMMATIVE ASSESSMENTS THAT TEST
LITERACY AND MATHEMATICS HAVE
REPORTED A DECREASE IN STUDENTS
MEAN SCORES FROM 2019 TO 2023,
GOING FROM 51.1% TO 46.6% IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND FROM
39.7% TO 34.6% IN MATH. FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE MET OR
EXCEEDED THE STANDARDS. AS
EFFORTS CONTINUE TO BE MADE TO
REACH ASSESSMENT GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA, EDUCATORS AND STAFF
PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE ON THE
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF
STUDENTS. SB 1115 AIMS TO
SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS BY
PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CREDENTIALED
EDUCATION STAFF IN LITERACY AND
MATHEMATICS. WITH ME TODAY IS
OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, TONY THURMOND, TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATEWIDE. LITERACY
CO-DIRECTOR NANCY BRYNELSON TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. WELCOME, MR.
SUPERINTENDENT. ALWAYS NICE TO
SEE YOU, YOU HAVE THE CUSTOMARY
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT IS PROVEN TO HELP RAISE THE
PROFICIENCY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. IT IS NOT A NEW
SUBJECT THAT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
HAVE EXPERIENCED AN ACHIEVEMENT
GAP OVER MANY DECADES, A GAP
THAT WAS EXACERBATED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. BUT WE KNOW THAT
ROBUST PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAINING FOR THOSE WHO TEACH
MATH AND FOR THOSE WHO TEACH OUR
KIDS TO READ CAN CLOSE THAT GAP
AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE READY TO READ BY THIRD GRADE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE READY
FOR BRIGHT FUTURES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE EXPERIENCE
FOR MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS
THAT ONE TEACHER GETS TRAINING
AND IS EXPECTED TO COME BACK TO
THE SCHOOL AND DO A TURNAROUND
TRAINING FOR OTHERS. THAT'S NOT
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO CLOSE THE
LITERACY GAP OR THE MATH
NUMERACY GAP FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WHAT WE PROPOSE IS AMBITIOUS
THAT WE COULD PROVIDE TRAINING
FOR MORE THAN 300,000 EDUCATORS
ACROSS ALL GRADE SPANS, AND THAT
IT WILL HAVE RESULTS WE
ENCOURAGE WITH THE FUNDING THAT
WOULD BE RECEIVED TO PROVIDE
THIS PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
DISTRICTS TO USE TRAININGS THAT
ARE PROVEN THAT GET RESULTS FOR
STUDENTS TO HELP THEM IMPROVE
THEIR PROFICIENCY, WE KNOW THAT
OUR KIDS HAVE BEEN THROUGH TOUGH
TIMES ACADEMICALLY AND MENTALLY,
BUT WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF BEING SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN WE PROVIDE RIGOR AND WE
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THEIR
EDUCATORS TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
AND CLOSE LEARNING GAPS. AND SO
WE ENVISION A BOLD ACTION TO
HELP MORE THAN 300,000 EDUCATORS
GET PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, I CHANGE IS
HERE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
IS THAT CORRECT, ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND
EXPRESS A POSITION OF SUPPORT
FOR THE MEASURE? MR. CHAIR,
WHILE THOSE, FOLKS ARE COMING
FORWARD, I WANTED TO,
REGRETFULLY ANNOUNCE THAT A
MEMBER, A FORMER MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATURE, PASSED AWAY, THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT, THE FORMER
STATE SUPERINTENDENT, DYLAN
EASTON, WHO SERVED AS
SUPERINTENDENT AT, FROM 1995 TO
2003 AND SERVED IN THE ASSEMBLY
FROM 1986 TO 1994, WERE FLYING
FLAGS AT HALF MAST FOR HER
TODAY, AND WE WILL BE HAVING A
MOMENT TO HONOR HER MEMORY THAT
WE WILL INVITE ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE. I APPRECIATE
THAT, SO SORRY TO HEAR THAT. I I
KNEW AND ADMIRED DYLAN EASTON
VERY MUCH, VERY SAD. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE? PLEASE COME
FORWARD, AND YOU MAY COME TO THE
TABLE IF YOU LIKE. YOU'VE UP TO
THREE MINUTES. GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY IN
OPPOSITION, CHRISTINA SALAZAR.
WITH CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER,
WE'RE ACTUALLY A TWEENER, WE
AGREE THAT WE NEED MORE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
EDUCATORS, BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON IT
MENTIONED SCIENCE OF READING,
AND IT ALSO NAMES TWO COMMERCIAL
PROGRAMS. AND THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE WE STAND. OKAY. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION, PLEASE? GOOD MORNING
. JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION. WE DO NOT
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION YET AND
HAVE BEEN COMMUNICATING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. WE HAVE THE
SAME CONCERNS THAT WE'VE
EXPRESSED THAT CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER HAS AND HOPE TO HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
A PATH TO MOVE FORWARD. IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND, IF YOU IF YOU
COULD ELABORATE JUST A LITTLE
BIT ON THOSE CONCERNS, SPECIFIC.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT TARGETING
SCIENCE OF READING. WE HAVE A
LOT OF VERY EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS
THAT WE CURRENTLY ALREADY HAVE
IN LAW THAT ACTUALLY INCORPORATE
SCIENCE OF READING, AND WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFYING VENDORS
. WE THINK THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
HAVE A MUCH MORE BROAD APPROACH.
SPECIFICALLY, THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE VERY POSITIVE LONG TERME
IMPACTS ON ENGLISH LEARNERS.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE.
LET'S COME BACK TO COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE? NO, NONE. NONE
ZERO. OKAY. JUST REALLY QUICK,
ON THE QUESTION, SUPERINTENDENT
THURMOND SO WE WANT TO YOU WANT
TO FOCUS ON EDUCATORS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN, IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERNS AS TO THE PREPARATION
PART OF ENSURING THAT OUR
TEACHERS HAVE THE RIGHT
PREPARATION BEFORE THEY GET INTO
THE CLASSROOM? BECAUSE THIS IS
AFTER THE FACT, BUT WHAT HAVE WE
LOOKED INTO, OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE SAME TYPE OF TRAINING
THAT YOU'RE HOPING TO SEE, PRIOR
TO COMING INTO THE FIELD. THANK
YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR, WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY
DOES WHAT YOU'RE ASKING. IT
RECOGNIZES THAT THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING HAS
SAID THAT ALL NEW TEACHERS
SHOULD KNOW CERTAIN THINGS ABOUT
HOW TO TEACH CHILDREN TO READ,
BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S BEING
DONE FOR THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
EDUCATING IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND
THIS PROVIDES THE SAME RIGOROUS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
THAT THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IS SAYING ANY
TEACHER OR ANY NEW TEACHER
SHOULD HAVE, AS IT RELATES TO
HELPING A STUDENT LEARN TO READ,
I WOULD SAY THAT WE THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION THE
SCIENCE OF READING, BECAUSE THAT
IS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A WAY OF
HELPING STUDENTS TO HAVE
SUCCESS, TO HAVE ACCESS TO
PHONICS AND TO OTHER THINGS THAT
HELP THEM. BUT THE LANGUAGE OF
THIS BILL IS VERY BALANCED IN
THAT IT TALKS ABOUT THE SCIENCE
OF READING, AND IT TALKS ABOUT
THE ELA, THE ELA ELD FRAMEWORK,
WHICH IS A SEMINAL PIECE THAT
HAS BEEN CREATED TO TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THE COMPONENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO HELP STUDENTS LEARN
HOW TO READ. AND SO WE THINK
THAT IT'S BALANCED AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO OUR PARTNERS, WHO
WITH WHOM WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT,
WE THINK THAT WE CAN DO THIS IN
A WAY THAT ACCELERATES THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS WHO NEED, A GREAT
SUPPORT TO LEARN HOW TO READ,
AND WE CAN DO IT IN A WAY THAT
IT MEETS THE NEEDS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS. AND WE HAVE GIVEN
EXAMPLES, THIS IS NOT A MANDATE
IN ANY WAY, BUT WE'VE GIVEN
EXAMPLES OF TRAINING THAT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO HAVE GREAT RESULTS
IN HELPING STUDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND TRAININGS THAT
HELP STUDENTS WHO COME FROM
ENGLISH LEARNER BACKGROUNDS. AND
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE FOR
YOU FOLLOW UP ON THAT. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ANOTHER
LITERACY BILL THAT IS COMING IN
THAT IT WOULD BE ADDRESSING THE
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS, IN THE
ASSEMBLY THROUGH ASSEMBLYWOMAN
RUBIO. HOW DOES THIS COMPARE TO
YOUR PARTICULAR BILL THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING HERE TODAY? I THINK
THAT THE BILL, WHICH IS
CURRENTLY, BEEN PAUSED AND WON'T
BE HAVING A HEARING IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WILL COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AGAIN NEXT YEAR, I
THINK THAT THE BILL ACTUALLY
MAINTAINS MANY SIMILARITIES. IT
CALLS OUT THE NEED FOR THE
SCIENCE OF READING AND FOR
PHONICS. IT TALKS ABOUT CHANGING
, CURRICULUM MATERIALS THAT
EDUCATORS GET ACCESS TO HELP
THEM BE READY FOR TEACHING
STUDENTS TO READ. I WOULD SAY A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
OURS IS THAT BOTH BILLS FOCUS ON
LITERACY, BUT OURS ALSO TALKS
ABOUT MATH BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY
TEACHERS WHO TEACH MATH WHO WILL
SAY, I KNOW MATH, BUT I'M NOT
CONFIDENT TEACHING IT. AND WE
THINK THAT THERE SHOULD BE RIGOR
AND TRAINING AND SUPPORT FOR
THOSE WHO TEACH MATH, AS WELL AS
THOSE WHO TEACH OUR KIDS TO
READ. SO MY FINAL QUESTION, SO
GOING BACK TO THE TO MY FIRST
QUESTION, WHICH IS DO WE NEED TO
RELOOK? AND ARE YOU WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR,
CALIFORNIA TEACHING
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THIS
TRAINING, MOVING FORWARD? SO
THEY'RE COMING IN TO THE FIELD
KNOWING WHAT YOU WANT TO
CURRENTLY TEACH OR OUR TEACHERS
WHO ARE ALREADY IN IN THE FIELD.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS OUR
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING HAS ALREADY DONE
THAT WORK. AND MISS NELSON TO MY
RIGHT, HAS HELPED THE COMMISSION
THÀNH THROUGH THAT PROCESS. AND
I'D LIKE TO GIVE HER A MOMENT TO
TALK ABOUT THAT, BECAUSE THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SB 488 DID REQUIRE
CHANGES IN THE CREDENTIALING OF
TEACHERS, SEEKING A MULTIPLE
SUBJECT, SINGLE SUBJECT AND
EDUCATION SPECIALIST CREDENTIAL.
AND SO NEW ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS FOR LITERACY HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED AND ADOPTED BY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. AND THEY ARE IN
EFFECT AS OF THE FALL OF 2024. A
NEW LITERACY PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT IS IN DEVELOPMENT AND
WILL BE IN EFFECT REPLACING THE
OLDER READING INSTRUCTION
COMPETENCE ASSESSMENT THAT, IN
JULY OF 2025. SO IN MANY WAYS,
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING TODAY
ALIGNS WITH MUCH OF THE WORK
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS DONE.
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO START
SEEING CANDIDATES CGRTS COME
FORWARD OUT OF THESE, REVISED
PROGRAMS FOR CREDENTIALING.
OKAY. SO BASICALLY, YOU'RE JUST
UPDATING WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE,
APPROVED DURING THE
CREDENTIALING. TEACHING PROGRAM
AND NOW ALLOWING OUR, OUR
TEACHERS WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
FIELD PRIOR TO THIS, BE UPDATED
WITH THE NEW WITH THE NEW
STANDARDS OF THE SCIENCE OF
READING. IS THAT CORRECT? THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT, AND WE THANK
SENATOR LIMÓN FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL, AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN IT, AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU'LL TAKE BOLD ACTION TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS ACCELERATE THEIR
PROFICIENCY IN BOTH LITERACY AND
IN MATH. I APPRECIATE THAT. SO I
JUST, YOU KNOW, ONE POINT I
THINK TO, TO TOUCH ON IS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR, SORT OF
PREDICATE THAT YOU KNOW, THAT
THE EXISTING MODE OF KIND OF THE
TRAIN, THE TRAINER ISN'T WORKING
PARTICULARLY WELL. RIGHT? WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS WHO ARE
ALREADY IN THEIR JOBS. BUT
THAT'S THAT'S NOT INEXPENSIVE.
RIGHT. AND SO I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S MONEY IN THIS BUDGET FOR
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION. BUT, YOU
KNOW, IS THERE AN ESTIMATE AS TO
WHAT THE FISCAL IMPACT, IF YOU
WERE TO SUCCEED WITH THE BILL?
YOU KNOW, WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT
BY WAY OF COST TO DO THIS?
RIGHT? WE CAN GIVE YOU SOME UNIT
COSTS, WHAT IT WOULD BE TO TRAIN
PER TEACHER AND THEN JUST
MULTIPLY THAT OUT BY, YOU KNOW,
OUR GOAL IS TO REACH MORE THAN
300,000 TEACHERS AND I WOULD SAY
THAT THAT COST IS SIGNIFICANT, I
WOULD SAY THAT WHILE THE STATE
HAS ISSUED MONEY FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT BEFORE,
THERE HAS NOT BEEN AN ALLOCATION
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR, A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF TEACHERS
AND EDUCATORS, I SHOULD SAY
EDUCATORS, BECAUSE THIS COULD BE
FOR TEACHERS OR CLASSIFIED STAFF
OR READING COACHES AND OTHERS
PRINCIPALS, OTHERS WHO ARE
ENGAGED. THERE HASN'T BEEN THE
TYPE OF INVESTMENT THAT'S NEEDED
FOR US TO REALLY MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP, AND SO WE CAN GIVE YOU AN
ESTIMATE PER TEACHER. YOU'VE
GIVEN ME SORT OF THE BASIS,
RIGHT? 300,000 TIMES THIS AMOUNT
OF MONEY IS A LARGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY. AND SO MY UNDERSTANDING
IS, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY $20 MILLION IN
THIS BUDGET, BUT THAT'S PROBABLY
NOT SUFFICIENT TO KIND OF MEET
THE GOAL. SO YOUR CHALLENGE IS
GOING TO BE A FISCAL CHALLENGE
IN THIS, YOU KNOW, CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT, WHICH WHICH IS
REAL, BUT I THINK NOT. YOUR MAIN
MOVEMENT BEALL OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY. I JUST WANTED TO GET THAT
ON THE RECORD, SO THANK YOU.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, MR. CHAIR,
WE AGREE THAT THE COST MAY BE
HIGH. WE THINK THE COST IS
GREATER. I WOULD TAKE THE I
WON'T DISAGREE. I JUST THINK OUR
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED. RIGHT? I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU. GIVEN
THE DEFICIT, WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE MIGHT NEED TO BE OPTIONS
PURSUED, LIKE DELAYING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OR THE START. BUT
WE AGREE THAT WHILE IT MIGHT BE
A LARGE COST, THE REWARD WILL BE
EVEN GREATER AND THE COST IS
EVEN GREATER IF WE ALLOW
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO MOORLACH
TO PROFICIENCY, I WOULD MAKE THE
SAME ARGUMENT. THANK YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE FACING A
REAL FISCAL CHALLENGE THIS YEAR.
MR. PERRY, I UNDERSTAND YOU HAD
A ME TOO, THAT YOU WANTED TO END
. YES. THANK YOU, CHAIR MEMBERS
AND APOLOGIES FOR BEING TARDY,
MAX PERRY, ON BEHALF OF
COLLABORATIVE CLASSROOM CORE
LEARNING AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
SUPPORTERS AND SPONSORS AND ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE? THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, WITH THAT, YOU KNOW,
APPRECIATE THE BILL. GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY WITH THE KIND
OF OBSERVATION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
FISCAL CHALLENGE THAT THIS WILL
INTERSECT WITH SENATOR LAMONT,
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL, I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
I THINK OUR SUPERINTENDENT HAS A
CLOSED FOR ME IN A IN A GREAT
WAY. BUT I ALSO WANT TO JUST LET
YOU KNOW THE, THE TWEENERS KNOW
THEY'RE, YOU KNOW, BOTH GABE AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER ARE
ORGANIZATIONS WE WORK REALLY
CLOSELY WITH. SO WE'RE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD AT
A COMMITTEE TODAY. AND SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I THANK
SECRETARIES. YOU MADE THEM.
EITHER OF YOU. OKAY. SENATOR
CHOBOQ HAS MADE A MOTION. AND,
MADAM ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHILE ITEM TWO, SB 1115
LIMÓN THE MOTION IS Dð PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ
I. GLASER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK. THANK YOU, THAT
BILL CURRENTLY HAS THREE VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
SUPERINTENDENT. NEXT AGAIN FOR
SENATOR LIMON, WE HAVE SB 1195,
AND IF YOU HAVE SUPPORT
WITNESSES, THEY CAN COME FORWARD
TO THE TABLE. GREAT. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PLEASE. OKAY.
I PRESENT TO YOU SB 1195, A BILL
THAT ENSURES STUDENTS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE AN ADVANCED
PLACEMENT AP EXAM. THE AP EXAM
IS DESIGNED TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO
SHOWCASE THEIR PROFICIENCY IN
PARTICULAR SUBJECTS AND EARN
COLLEGE CREDIT BASED ON THEIR
PERFORMANCE. THE COLLEGE BOARD
ADMINISTERS THE AP EXAM ONCE A
YEAR DURING A TWO WEEK PERIOD IN
MAY. WHILE SOME STUDENTS MAY
QUALIFY FOR LATE TESTING IN MAY,
MANY ARE LIMITED TO THE TWO WEEK
PERIOD, WHICH CAN BE CHALLENGING
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE UNDER A
BLOCK SCHEDULE. IN THE FALL
BLOCK SCHEDULE, STUDENTS HAVE TO
WAIT ROUGHLY A WHOLE SEMESTER
BEFORE THEY CAN COMPLETE THE MAY
EXAM, WHICH CAN LEAD TO ALMOST A
FIVE MONTH LEARNING LOSS FOR
STUDENTS, WHICH THEN, WOULD THEN
THEN WE SEE THAT IT HAS A
SCORING GAP AMONGST
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS. THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY THAT OPERATES A
BLOCK SCHEDULE TO REQUEST THAT
THE COLLEGE BOARD, TO PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE TESTING DATE TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO TAKE AN
AP COURSE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE THE EXAM IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE COMPLETION OF THE
COURSE. WITH ME TODAY, WE HAVE
DIANNA VU FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MR. WELCOME. YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
DIANNA VU, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND OUR MORE THAN
17,000 MEMBERS ACTS, IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB 1195, WHICH
PROVIDES A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO GET JUST A LITTLE
CLOSER TO THE MIC. THIS IS
BETTER. MUCH BETTER. OKAY. THANK
YOU, WHICH PROVIDES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY STUDENTS ENROLLED IN ADVANCED
PLACEMENT COURSES OPERATING ON
BLOCK SCHEDULES. ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL ASPECTS OF SB 1190 1195
IS ITS RECOGNITION OF THE
LEARNING RETENTION CHALLENGES
THAT STUDENTS ON BLOCK SCHEDULES
FACE. THE NEARLY FIVE MONTH GAP
BETWEEN THE END OF THE COURSE IN
DECEMBER AND THE TRADITIONAL AP
EXAM PERIOD IN MAY CAN LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT LEARNING LOSS BY
PROVIDING AN ALTERNATIVE TESTING
DATE CLOSER TO THE COURSE'S END,
STUDENTS CAN BETTER RETAIN THE
INFORMATION THEY'VE LEARNED.
ULTIMATELY ENHANCING THEIR
PERFORMANCE ON THE AP EXAM.
MOREOVER SB 1195 ALSO ADDRESSES
EQUITY CONCERNS BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THE DISPARITIES THAT EXIST
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND FROM
DIFFERENT SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS. STUDENTS FROM LESS
RESOURCED SCHOOLS MAY LACK
ACCESS TO EXTENDED LEARNING OR
COURSE REVIEW OPPORTUNITIES,
PUTTING THEM AT A DISADVANTAGE
WHEN FACING THE TRADITIONAL MAY
AP EXAM, OFFERING AN ALTERNATIVE
TESTING DATE SHORTLY AFTER THE
COURSE COMPLETION LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD, GIVING ALL
STUDENTS A FAIR OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
EARNING AND EARN COLLEGE CREDIT.
THIS PROVISION ENSURES THAT THE
SUCCESS IN AP COURSES IS NOT
LIMITED BY A STUDENT'S ZIP CODE
OR FINANCIAL MEANS.
ADDITIONALLY, ONE OF THE KEY
STRENGTHS IN SB 1195 IS ITS
EMPHASIS ON FLEXIBILITY. BY
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH THE
OPTION TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TAKING
THE AP EXAM AT THE END OF THE
SEMESTER OR DURING THE REGULAR
MAY TESTING PERIOD. THE BILL
EMPOWERS STUDENTS TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON THEIR
PREPAREDNESS AND PERSONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS FLEXIBILITY,
NOT ONLY ACCOMMODATES THE
DIVERSE NEEDS OF STUDENTS, BUT
ALSO HELPS ALLEVIATE THE STRESS
AND PRESSURE ASSOCIATED WITH
HIGH STAKES TESTING BY GRANTING
STUDENTS THE AUTONOMY TO SELECT
THE TESTING DATE THAT WORKS BEST
FOR THEM, SB 1195 PROMOTES A
MORE STUDENT CENTERED APPROACH
TO EDUCATION BY ADDRESSING
ISSUES RELATED TO LEARNING,
RETENTION, EQUITY AND EDUCATION,
AND FLEXIBILITY. THE BILL SEEKS
TO ENHANCE STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
ENSURES THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED
IN THEIR AP COURSEWORK. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE ON SB 1195. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
YOU'D LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANYBODY OPPOSED
TO THE MEASURE, ALSO SEEING
NONE. WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DAIS, I WILL START. SO I, I
TRULY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO, AND I AND I THINK
IT'S A REALITY THAT IF YOU TAKE
AN AP COURSE, YOU HAVE TO WAIT
FIVE MONTHS TO TAKE THE EXAM,
YOU'RE CLEARLY NOT GOING TO BE
AS WELL PREPARED AS IF YOU TOOK
IT AT THE, YOU KNOW, AT THE
COMPLETION OF THAT COURSE. BUT
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE ENDEAVORING TO
DO IS TO FIND LEVERAGE, TO SORT
OF INVITE OR OTHERWISE COMPEL
THE COLLEGE BOARD TO MEET THIS
NEED. SO THIS IS SORT OF
STRANGELY REMINISCENT OF A BILL
I DID YESTERDAY, IN A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE THAT, YOU KNOW, SOUGHT
TO FIND THAT SORT OF INDIRECT
LEVERAGE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
WHICH YOU HAD THE GOOD QUOTE IN
POLITICO, I MIGHT ADD, SO HOW TO
THINK ABOUT THIS, YOU KNOW, SO
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, WE CAN ASK
THE COLLEGE BOARD TO DO THIS,
BUT, YOU KNOW, HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY COMPEL THEM OTHERWISE
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL? SO WE HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD GOOD CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COLLEGE BOARD, AND SO
THEY'RE NOT HERE, BUT WE'RE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. AND I
THINK, THERE IS A SHARED
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT THE
EXAMS ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE, THAT, YOU KNOW, OF
THE COURSE THAT THEY TOOK AND
UNDERSTAND FOR ANYONE NOT JUST
STUDENTS, YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A
STUDENT. THERE IS LEARNING LOSS.
AFTER SEVERAL MONTHS OF NOT
USING, NOT PRACTICING, RIGHT,
NOT READING, NOT BEING IN THE
COURSE. AND SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S
OUR HOPE THAT AT SOME POINT THAT
THEY WOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
SUPPORTIVE. BUT WE ARE HAVING
GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. SO
THUS FAR. ALL RIGHT. SO, SO IF
WE THE OTHER ISSUE, I THINK, IS
SORT OF THE, YOU KNOW, THE
BASIS, ON WHICH THAT INVITATION
IS KIND OF EXTENDED. SO AT THE
LÀ LEVEL, I COULD SEE WHERE
YOU'D HAVE, YOU KNOW, LOTS AND
LOTS, NOT SURE IF THAT'S MORE
PERSUASIVE THAN DOING IT, YOU
KNOW, THROUGH SOME CENTRALIZED
CHANNEL, BUT WE CAN WE CAN WORK
THAT OUT. BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
ON. YES I THINK IT'S AN
EMINENTLY VALID GOAL, IT'S SORT
OF A SHAME THAT IT'S JUST NOT
THE DEFAULT THAT THEY DO THIS
NOW. RIGHT. BECAUSE AGREE. I
MEAN, RIGHT. I THINK IT'S A
SHAME IT DOESN'T HAPPEN NOW. BUT
I THINK THAT THERE IS AN
OPENNESS TO CONSIDERING WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO HAPPEN. TO YOUR
POINT ON WHETHER IT'S A
CENTRALIZED, YOU KNOW, DOES IT,
YOU KNOW, IS IT MORE LIKE A, YOU
KNOW, A REGIONAL ALL SAT LIKE
KIND OF MODEL, RIGHT? WHERE
SOMEONE DOES IT AS OPPOSED TO
EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL? I THINK
WE'RE REALLY OPEN TO HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WHAT WE
WANT IS FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE IN THESE CLASSES TO BE ABLE
TO ACCURATELY REFLECT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND GET THIS COLLEGE
CREDIT AS APPROPRIATE, BY TAKING
THE EXAM AFTER THE IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THE COMPLETION, AS OPPOSED
TO WAITING MONTHS. AND SO THAT'S
OUR ULTIMATE GOAL AND WE'RE OPEN
TO IDEAS. AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO IF THE RESPONSE TO THE
COLLEGE BOARD IS LIKE, YES, WE
CAN DO THAT. BUT ONLY ON A KIND
OF A REGIONAL BASIS, WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE THINKING THERE BY WAY
OF NO, NO, NO, NO, SORRY, I WAS
RESPONDING TO YOUR COMMENT ABOUT
I UNDERSTAND, BUT I COULD SEE
WHERE YOU KNOW, IF YOU HAD
SCHOOLS KIND OF UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THAT SAID, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A PARTICULAR ÁP OFFERING
AND WE'RE ON A BLOCK SCHEDULE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE THREE
STUDENTS, TEN STUDENTS. YOU
KNOW, THE COLLEGE BOARD MIGHT
SAY, LOOK, THAT'S AWESOME. WE'LL
OFFER A TEST IN FRESNO.
SACRAMENTO. HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
I MEAN, IT SEEMS THAT DOESN'T
SEEM UNLIKELY. RIGHT? I THINK
THAT'S STILL NOT OUR ULTIMATE
GOAL. OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IS THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO TAKE
THE EXAM AT THE SCHOOL SITE.
WHY? BECAUSE THAT IS THEIR
SCHOOL. SO WE KNOW ESPECIALLY
FOR A LOT OF RURAL COMMUNITIES,
IT WOULD BE REALLY DIFFICULT TO
GET TO, YOU KNOW, EVEN AN URBAN
CITY. AND SO WE OUR ULTIMATE
GOAL IS TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
DO IT AT THE SCHOOL SITE. BUT I
THINK WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
WANT TO JUST INCH OUR WAY TO BE
ABLE TO BE TO OFFERING THESE
CLASSES, THESE SORRY, THESE
EXAMS ON A MORE REGULAR BASIS,
PARTICULARLY FOR A LOT, I MEAN,
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS IN OUR
STATE WHO ARE TAKING THEM, I
UNDERSTOOD EARLIER. SO WE'RE
OPEN TO IT. BILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATION, YOU KNOW, ENTITY,
THE COLLEGE BOARD. SO IT'S
BEYOND CALLING UPON THEIR SORT
OF GOODWILL. YOU KNOW, THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD. BUT I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE IT FORWARD. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTESE, MADAM,
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR ITEM THREE. SB 1195 LIMÓN.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS. NEWMAN A
NEWMAN IOTO BOG. OKOBOJI.
CORTESE. CORTESE. I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK
. VERY GOOD. SO THAT MEASURE HAS
THREE VOTES. NO. NO VOTES. WE'LL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR THE TIME BEING.
I UNDERSTAND, SENATOR LIMON, YOU
ARE GOING TO DO THE GOOD DEED
AND PRESENT SB 1471 ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN, I AM YES, ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR STERN, I WILL
START BY ACCEPTING THE CHAIR'S
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED ON
PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS. SB
1471 PROPOSES TO OFFER TEACHERS
THE OPTION TO FACILITATE A 62ND
MOMENT OF QUIET REFLECTION AT
THE START OF EACH SCHOOL DAY,
INVITING STUDENT PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S FAST PACED AND NOISY
WORLD, IT CAN BE CHALLENGING TO
FIND MOMENTS OF PEACE. THIS
SIMPLE YET POWERFUL PRACTICE
ALLOWS STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS TO
PAUSE, CENTER THEMSELVES, AND
CULTIVATE A SENSE OF
MINDFULNESS. THIS QUIET TIME
WILL OFFER STUDENTS AND
EDUCATORS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TRANSITION AND FOCUS ON THE DAY,
HELP DEVELOP THE ABILITY TO HOPE
CGRTS FOCUS. ALLOW THE BRAIN TO
ABSORB NEW INFORMATION, HELP
STUDENTS TO SELF-REGULATE AND
RELIEVE TENSION AND STRESS, AND
IS ALSO BENEFICIAL FOR THE
NEURODIVERSE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
BE SENSITIVE TO SENSORY STIMULUS
. SOMETIMES STUDENTS JUST NEED A
MINUTE, AND EDUCATORS DO, TOO.
SB 1471 PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
AT SCHOOL, AND ALLOW FOR A
MOMENT OF MINDFULNESS WITH US
TODAY, PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IS GARY COOPER ON BEHALF
OF SAVING LIVES, CAMARILLO. MR.
COOPER, WELCOME. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, AS SENATOR LIMÓN
STATED, I AM REPRESENTING TODAY
SAVING LIVES. CAMARILLO, SAVING
LIVES. CAMARILLO IS A COALITION
IN HER DISTRICT THAT IS MADE UP
OF EDUCATORS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOLKS, RELIGIOUS LEADERS. AND
BASICALLY THEIR MISSION IS TO
DEAL WITH YOUTH DRUG ADDICTION
AND ALCOHOL ADDICTION. AND
THEY'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF SB
1471, THE BILL BASICALLY, WITH
THE BILL, CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT TOO MANY YOUNG
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS DO NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTAKE IN
EVEN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
TO BE WITH THEIR OWN THOUGHTS
BEFORE STARTING THEIR DAILY
LIFE. THE QUIET MOMENT, AS WE
LIKE TO CALL IT, WILL OFFER THE
STUDENTS A MINUTE TO VOLUNTARILY
REFLECT ON A POSITIVE VALUE THAT
WE HOPE WILL BE SHARED BY THEIR
PARENTS OR GUARDIAN. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING WE ARE VERY STRONG ON,
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS AND
FAMILIES ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THIS. THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
THE SCHOOLS ARE JUST FOISTING ON
THEM. WE WANT THE PARENTS AND
THE GUARDIANS AND THE FAMILY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS. OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE REPORTED THAT STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN QUIET MOMENTS
HAVE DISPLAYED IMPROVED GRADES
IN SCHOOL, BETTER BEHAVIOR AT
HOME AND IN SCHOOL, AND
INCREASED RESPECT FOR THEIR
TEACHERS AND PARENTS. IT HAS
DECREASED ANXIETY, BULLYING,
DISRESPECT, OPPRESSION AND CRIME
AND DRUG USE. SO FOR THAT
REASON, IT IS THE HOPE OF THE OF
THE SAVING LIVES. CAMARILLO THAT
IT WILL BE RECOGNIZED IN
COMMUNITIES AS A POSITIVE WAY TO
ENHANCE THE MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
WELL-BEING OF STUDENTS IN A
NON-THREATENING ENVIRONMENT. AND
FOR THAT REASON, WE SUPPORT
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB 1471 AND DO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU. HAVE
ANY OTHER, FOLKS HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION FOR THIS MEASURE? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO VOICE OPPOSITION FOR THE
MEASURE? I SEEING NONE. I WILL
COME BACK TO THE DAIS. THERE'S
MORE TO THIS STORY, RIGHT? I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, SO, YOU KNOW,
SAVING LIVES. CAMARILLO IS THE
LISTED SPONSOR. YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED OVER THE YEARS. SO IF YOU
DON'T MIND, BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT, WHAT'S THE GENESIS OF
THIS IDEA COMES FROM WHERE THE
GENESIS OF THE IDEA. YES. YOU'RE
RIGHT, THERE'S MORE TO THE
STORY. BUT IT'S BEEN PICKED UP
IN 35 STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE GENESIS OF THIS IS THE
LUBAVITCHER REBBE IN NEW YORK,
AND HE FROM THE CHABAD COMMUNITY
BELIEVED THAT EDUCATION AND
STUDENT EDUCATION, OAN AND
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH WAS VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT. AND HE CREATED
THIS MANY, THIS IDEA MANY, MANY,
MANY YEARS AGO. AND MANY STATES
HAVE PICKED IT UP, WHETHER IT'S
BE WITH THE JEWISH COMMUNITY OR
NON-JEWISH COMMUNITY, THE
CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY, THEY'VE
PICKED IT UP AS AN IDEA, YOU
KNOW, TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THAT
QUIET MOMENT AND THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING POSITIVE. THIS IS NOT,
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY, VERY CLEAR THIS IS NOT A
JEWISH BILL. THIS IS NOT A
CHRISTIAN BILL. THIS IS NOT A
RELIGIOUS BILL. THIS BILL IS
ONLY FOR STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THERE'S NOTHING TO BE
IMPLIED BY THIS AS SAYING THAT
THERE'S ANY PRAYER INVOLVED.
THIS IS ONLY FOR A VOLUNTARY
MOMENT FOR THE STUDENTS TO THINK
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT, BUT HOPEFULLY DO IT
QUIETLY. AND THAT WILL HELP THEM
DURING THE COURSE OF THEIR DAY
AND HOPEFULLY THEIR LIFE. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. BUT BUT THERE
IS SOME CONCERN IN, YOU KNOW, IN
THAT VERY DELICATE FIRST
AMENDMENT SPACE, YOU KNOW, ABOUT
RELIGION AND ITS INTERSECTION
WITH PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS,
ESPECIALLY SCHOOLS. SO HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT, NO SCHOOL WHO
EMPLOYS A MOMENT OF QUIET
REFLECTION, ACTUALLY DOES THAT
IN THE SERVICE, EXPLICITLY OR
IMPLICITLY, OF A RELIGIOUS
DOCTRINE? WE'VE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR IN THE BILL AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE TAKING,
THAT THIS BILL WILL BE ADHERING
TO ALL FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
DEALING WITH THE INDEPENDENCE OF
SCHOOL AND CHURCH. SO THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE BILL IMPLYING
THAT THERE'S ANYTHING RELIGIOUS.
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOTHING IS, YOU KNOW, PUT
IN STATUTE THAT'S IMPLYING OR
REQUIRING ANY RELIGIOUS
ACTIVITIES. SO ANY AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED BY THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED TO
MAKE SURE TO COVER THAT EXACT
ISSUE. RIGHT. AND SO JUST TO
CLARIFY, ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
STERN, I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED OR HE HAS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS. SENATOR LIMÓN HE
HAS. YES, HE HAS. OKAY. VERY
GOOD. OKAY, OKAY. I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, THOSE CONCERNS WILL
PERSIST. I THINK THEY WILL BE A
BACKDROP TO ANY FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS OR DELIBERATIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL. I YOU KNOW, I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT. DO YOU
HAVE A QUESTION OR YOU WANT TO
MAKE A MOTION? YES. I THINK WE
SHOULD AMEND IT TO ENSURE THAT
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
BEGINS WITH THAT 60S OF Þ WE DO.
WE OFTEN BEGIN WITH SIX, SEVEN
MINUTES. WE'RE WAITING FOR
PEOPLE, WAITING FOR PEOPLE TO
SHOW UP, BUT IT'S QUIET
REFLECTION. I JUST MEANT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK YOU SHOULD LEAD
THE WAY, SENATOR NEWMAN, AND
MAKE THE, THE, SENATE COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION AN EXAMPLE OF, YOU
KNOW, THIS THIS BILL. I'D BE
HAPPY TO MEET OUR OUR COMMITTEE
RULES EVERY YEAR. MAYBE THAT'LL
BE SOMETHING WE CONSIDER AT THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR, AND CAN
I CONSIDER THAT A MOTION,
SENATOR? ABSOLUTELY. ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
OCHOA. BOGH DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR? OKAY. VERY
GOOD, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM SIX, SB
1471. STERN. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. I OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK THAT
MEASURE HAS TWO VOTES, FOUR ZERO
AGAINST. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO COME BACK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, SENATOR
LIMÓN. THANK YOU, MR. COOPER, WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
AGENDA ITEM. IF I COULD FIND MY,
SENATOR. EXCUSE ME. IF POSSIBLE.
I DON'T SEE AN AUTHOR ANYWAY. SO
SENATOR CHUBBUCK, JUST YOU AND
ME HAVING FUN ON EDUCATION,
LET'S DO IT. LET'S SEE, AND THAT
IS SB 14 1013. I'M SORRY, IS
THAT THE FIRST Þ? THAT'S THE
FIRST ONE. I'M SORRY. SO. OKAY.
SB, YOU HAVE TWO SB 1368.
ALTHOUGH DO YOU WANT ME TO WAIT?
I COULD DO IT'S YOUR TWO BILLS
YOU CHOOSE FROM EITHER.
WHICHEVER ONE WORKS FOR YOU.
WELL, CAN DO THIS ONE. YOUR
SERVICE.
AND FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
REGULARLY ATTEND, I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES MEETING
SIMULTANEOUSLY. AND FOR WHATEVER
REASON, MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SIT ON THOSE OTHER
COMMITTEES. AND THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THEIR ABSENCE RIGHT
NOW. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
SOMEWHERE WATCHING. THANK YOU.
MILLIONS WATCHING. YOU CAN REST
ASSURED MANY ARE WATCHING. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY. I'M
EXCITED TO BEGIN THE DISCUSSION
REGARDING AN IMPORTANT RESOURCE
FOR OUR YOUTH. SB 1368 WOULD
UPDATE THE COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL
HEALTH AND HIV PREVENTION
EDUCATION REQUIRED FOR STUDENTS
IN SEVENTH TO THROUGH EIGHTH
12TH GRADE TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT LICENSED
PREGNANCY CENTERS AS PART OF THE
INSTRUCTION ON LOCAL RESOURCES
FOR SEXUAL HEALTH AND PREGNANCY.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACT
REQUIRES EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
LOCAL RESOURCES, HOW TO ACCESS
LOCAL RESOURCES AND PUPILS,
LEGAL RIGHT TO ACCESS LOCAL
RESOURCES FOR SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE, SUCH
AS TESTING AND MEDICAL CARE FOR
HIV AND OTHER SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS, AND
PREGNANCY PREVENTION AND CARE
IN. FOR INFORMATION ON LICENSED
LOCAL PREGNANCY CENTERS HAS NOT
BEEN PRESENTED TO STUDENTS IN
GRADES 7 TO 12, DESPITE THE
VARIETY OF SERVICES THESE
CENTERS OFFER, THESE CENTERS
SERVE WOMEN AND COUPLES FACING
UNPLANNED PREGNANCY WITH
EMPATHETIC REASSURANCE AND FREE
SERVICES THAT MAY INCLUDE
MEDICAL SERVICES LIKE PREGNANCY
TESTING, ULTRASOUND AND STD
TESTING, OPTIONS COUNSELING,
COMMUNITY REFERRALS, PRENATAL
MEDICAL CARE AND PRACTICAL AID.
WE HAVE A LOOMING PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE CENTERS ARE FILLING THIS
GAP WHERE WE NEED MORE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS, PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
AREAS, LOW INCOME AREAS, AND FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE FEDERAL
HEALTH RESOURCES AND SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION REPORTS THAT MORE
THAN 13.1 MILLION CALIFORNIAN
RESIDENTS LIVE IN A PRIMARY CARE
SHORTAGE AREA. MANY WOMEN KNOW
WHERE TO GO TO GET AN ABORTION.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN GO TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, BUT MOST WOMEN DON'T
KNOW THAT. FREE RESOURCES FROM
PREGNANCY CENTERS EXIST. THERE
ARE 166 PLANNED PARENTHOOD
LOCATIONS, WHICH ARE PRIMARILY
IN URBAN AREAS, AND 98 LICENSED
PREGNANCY CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE CERTAINLY IS ROOM FOR ALL
WHEN IT COMES TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. IN FACT, MANY
PREGNANCY CENTERS REPORT THAT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WILL REFER
WOMEN TO PREGNANCY CENTER CARES
IF A WOMAN REFUSES AN ABORTION
AND WANTS TO KEEP HER BABY.
YOUNG WOMEN IN CRISIS BEAR THE
HEAVY WEIGHT OF MAKING LIFE
CHANGING DECISIONS, OFTEN IN
SECRET. LICENSED PREGNANCY
CLINICS ALLOW WOMEN TO TALK
ABOUT ALL THEIR OPTIONS WITH A
MEDICALLY LICENSED, SYMPATHETIC
PERSON IN HOPES THAT THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO MAKE A DECISION WITH A
CLEAR CONSCIENCE AND HAVE A FULL
SUPPORT SYSTEM BEHIND THEM ALONG
THE WAY. I LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THE
BILL WILL NOT WILL NOT REPLACE
CURRENT CURRICULUM OR REMOVE
EXISTING RESOURCE INFORMATION
FROM INSTRUCTION OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
WEBSITE. IT SIMPLY BRINGS INTO
PARITY THE RESOURCES OFFERED TO
STUDENTS, GIVING THEM
INFORMATION ON BOTH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND LICENSED
PREGNANCY CENTERS. LICENSED
KEYWORD. BECAUSE WITH DIVERSE
OPTIONS, WE CREATE INFORMED
FUTURES. BUT LET'S ALLOW THE
STATISTICS TO SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES. IN 2019, PREGNANCY
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDED
SERVICES AND MATERIALS VALUED AT
MORE THAN $14.3 MILLION, SERVING
93,957 WOMEN, MEN, YOUTH AND
FAMILIES. THERE WERE 33,802 YES,
TWO FREE PREGNANCY TEST, 22,264
FREE ULTRASOUNDS PERFORMED BY
REGISTERED NURSES AND MEDICAL
SONOGRAPHERS, 4571 TOTAL STD STI
TESTS PERFORMED BY RN'S 77%
FEMALE AND 23% MALE. THESE
SERVICES. THESE MEDICAL SERVICES
. TOTALED 7,341,844, BUT WERE
FREE OF CHARGE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE FREE MATERIAL,
THE FREE MATERIAL ITEMS HAVE
ALSO MADE AN IMPACT, PROVIDING A
TOTAL OF 187,127 TOTAL FREE BABY
ITEMS TO FAMILIES IN NEED,
56,100 PACKS OF DIAPERS, 31,931
PACKS OF BABY WIPES, 97,176 NEW
AND USED BABY CLOTHING OUTFITS,
1180 NEW CAR SEATS AND 740 NEW
STROLLERS. ALL OF THIS IS MADE
POSSIBLE BY THE AMAZING STAFF
BEHIND THESE CENTERS. 2579 OF
WHOM ARE COMPLETE VOLUNTEERS.
THESE CENTERS ARE LICENSED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. ADDITIONALLY,
SOME ARE ALSO ACCREDITED BY THE
ACCREDITATION ASSOCIATION OF
AMBULATORY HEALTH CARE, ALSO
KNOWN AS TRIPLE A, H, C, TRIPLE
A, H, C WAS FOUNDED MORE THAN 40
YEARS AGO TO ENCOURAGE AND
ASSIST HEALTH CARE ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE THE HIGHEST
ACHIEVABLE LEVEL OF CARE FOR
RECIPIENTS BY CONTINUOUSLY
ADDING NEW STANDARDS WHILE
UPDATING EXISTING STANDARDS TO
REFLECT CUTTING EDGE AMBULATORY
CARE KNOWLEDGE AND PRACTICE.
TRIPLE AHC IS ONE OF THE MAIN
NATIONWIDE ACCREDITATION
ORGANIZATIONS FOR US HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. HIS LICENSE,
PREGNANCY CENTERS OFTEN HAVE
MEDICAL TEAMS THAT CONSIST OF AN
OBGYN GYN PHYSICIAN, A NURSE
PRACTITIONER LIKE REGISTERED
NURSES, AND ARDMS LICENSE
SONOGRAPHERS. THERE IS PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTS HOW
RESOURCEFUL THESE CENTERS ARE IN
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO SPREAD
BETTER AWARENESS AMONG THEM TO
OUR YOUTH. JOINING ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PREGNANCY CENTERS, WE HAVE
KATHLEEN JONES, WHO IS CEO OF
LIFE CHOICE PREGNANCY CENTER IN
SAN BERNARDINO. WE ALSO HAVE
KELLY BRADFORD, WHO WILL SPEAK
ON THE PERSPECTIVE OF A
PREGNANCY CENTER CLIENT. WELCOME
TO BOTH OF YOU. PLEASE, THREE
MINUTES EACH. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN JONES AND I AM THE CEO.
CEO FOR LIFE CHOICE PREGNANCY
CENTER, A STATE LICENSED
COMMUNITY MEDICAL CLINIC IN SAN
BERNARDINO. I'M ALSO BOARD
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF PREGNANCY CARE. I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB 1368 AND
GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR OKUBO'S
HEART AND PASSION FOR EDUCATING
THE YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA. LIFE
CHOICE PREGNANCY CENTER, AS WELL
AS OTHER PREGNANCY CARE CENTERS
AFFILIATED WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF PREGNANCY CARE, ARE
FULLY COMMITTED TO EDUCATING,
INFORMING, AND GUIDING STUDENTS
REGARDING HUMAN DEVELOPMENT,
SEXUALITY, PREGNANCY,
CONTRACEPTION, AND SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES AND
INFECTIONS. THE 98 LICENSED
PREGNANCY. PREGNANCY CARE
CLINICS ACROSS OUR STATE ARE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE AND FREE TO
EVERYONE IN NEED OF ASSISTANCE
AND EDUCATION. THESE CENTERS AND
CLINICS PROVIDE PREGNANCY
TESTING, ULTRASOUNDS, MATERIAL
RESOURCE ASSISTANCE, INCLUDING
MATERNITY CLOTHES, BABY CLOTHES,
ACCESSORIES, DIAPERS, WIPES,
FOOD, FORMULA AND THIS IS JUST A
SMALL SAMPLING OF THE MATERIAL
AID WE PROVIDE AT NO COST TO OUR
CLIENTS. OUR COMMUNITY, AND THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S PREGNANCY
CARE CENTERS AND CLINICS PROVIDE
INFORMATION, EDUCATE OCEAN AND
MATERIAL ASSISTANCE WHILE
DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY HEALTH
CARE AND SUPPORT. ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS DESERVE A COMPLETE
LISTING OF THE AVAILABLE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES DURING THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH AND
HIV PREVENTION EDUCATION, WHICH
SHOULD INCLUDE PREGNANCY CENTERS
AND CLINICS. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
AYE ON SB 1368 TO ENSURE THAT
OUR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE FULLY INFORMED
ABOUT ALL COMMUNITY RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM MAKE
EDUCATED, INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR SEXUAL HEALTH. MR.
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND A YES VOTE ON SB
1368. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS KELLY
BRADFORD. I AM 44 YEARS OLD AND
I HAVE HAD FIVE ABORTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP, I WAS MISLED AND TOLD THAT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WAS THE ONLY
PLACE FOR ME TO GO TO RECEIVE MY
CARE FOR MY PREGNANCY OTHER THAN
THE HOSPITAL. WHEN I WENT TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, THEY DID NOT
SPEAK WITH ME ABOUT CONTINUING
MY PREGNANCY OR PROVIDE PRENATAL
CARE, SUPPORT OR RESOURCES IS
NOT. ONE TIME DID THEY SIT DOWN
WITH ME AND EDUCATE ME ON MY
OPTIONS OTHER THAN ABORTION? NOT
ONCE DID THEY SHOW ME WHAT AN
ABORTION ACTUALLY IS AND WHAT
THE DIFFERENT STAGES OF ABORTION
LOOK LIKE, DEPENDING ON HOW FAR
ALONG I WAS, BECAUSE IF THEY
DID, I KNOW I WOULD HAVE MADE
SOME DIFFERENT DECISIONS WHEN I
LEARNED ABOUT ALTERNATIVES,
PREGNANCY CENTER AND OTHERS LIKE
IT, I WAS BLOWN AWAY BY THE
QUALITY OF CARE THEY THEY'RE
PROVIDING AND THE TIME THEY TAKE
TO SIT DOWN WITH EACH PATIENT TO
GO OVER THEIR OPTIONS. WHEN
FACED WITH AN UNPLANNED
PREGNANCY. BUT I WAS ALSO
BAFFLED BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW
PREGNANCY CENTERS EXISTED WHEN I
WAS FACED WITH AN UNPLANNED ONE
AND NEEDED HELP THROUGH MY
EXPERIENCE WITH ALTERNATIVES
PREGNANCY CENTER, I'VE
PERSONALLY BEEN ABLE TO MEET
WOMEN WHO ALSO CHOSE TO ABORT
AND ARE STILL BATTLING WITH THAT
DECISION. MANY YEARS LATER, AND
HAVE ASKED THE SAME QUESTION AS
ME. WHERE WERE THE PREGNANCY
CENTERS WHEN WE NEEDED THEM? BUT
BECAUSE OF ALTERNATIVES, I HAVE
RECEIVED FREE PRENATAL CARE.
WHEN I WAS FACED WITH AN
UNPLANNED PREGNANCY AND HEALING
THROUGH THEIR ABORTION RECOVERY
CLASSES, SB 1368 IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL. THAT MEANS MORE
THAN MANY OF YOU UP HERE TODAY
WILL EVER KNOW. WOMEN DESERVE TO
KNOW ALL OF THEIR OPTIONS, AND
PREGNANCY CARE CENTERS PROVIDE
VITAL INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE THE BEST DECISION FOR
OURSELVES AND OUR UNBORN CHILD,
WHETHER IT'S TO BE A PARENT TO
CHOOSE ADOPTION OR ABORTION.
IT'S ONLY FAIR AND JUST THAT WE
GIVE OUR STUDENTS ALL OPTIONS.
SO, SENATORS, PLEASE DO WHAT IS
RIGHT AND MAKE THESE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO OUR YOUTH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MISS BRADFORD.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
SAMAR PALKO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JEANETTE
CHEN, PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF PREGNANCY CARE, AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MIKE MURRAY REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SOPHIA LAURIE WITH
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL AND
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DEACON
JOHN WILSON, LOS ANGELES AND IN
SUPPORT OF WOMEN WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH DIFFICULTIES, I THINK
THEY NEED TO THANK YOU. IS THIS
YOUR POSITION? THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS MATT NEWTON. I'M A
PASTOR HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AS
WELL AS HAVE A DAUGHTER AND IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO.
MY NAME IS CAROLINE LAURIE. I'M
A PARENT OF FOUR TWO IN PUBLIC
SCHOOL AND A RETIRED L.A.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TEACHER.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS MISTY
JONES, AND I AM A MOTHER. I WAS
ALSO I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR. I WAS
ALSO A TEEN MOTHER AND I AM NOT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. YOU'RE
NOT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT. YOU'LL WE'LL GET TO
OPPOSITION WHEN WE. SHE'S GONE,
SO LET'S MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ARE THERE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, ARE THERE
ANY IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE WE HAD ONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. I'LL START.
SO, SENATOR CHO, I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO, YOU'VE
YOU'VE MADE AT DIFFERENT TIMES
AN EMPHASIS ON THE WORD
LICENSED. LICENSED PREGNANCY
CENTERS. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
BILL REFERS ONLY TO PREGNANCY
CENTERS, GENERALLY SO LICENSED.
WE HAVE AN AMENDMENT THAT SAID
IT SHOULD BE LICENSED AND IS
THAT IS THAT AMENDMENT Dð. IS
THE COMMITTEE AWARE OF THAT? THE
COMMITTEE IS NOT AWARE OF THAT
AMENDMENT? I'M PRETTY SURE WE
HAVE THE AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT IT WAS LICENSED. THE
DEADLINE WAS MONDAY LAST WEEK.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
DEADLINE FOR AMENDMENTS PASSED
PRIOR TO YOUR SUBMITTING THAT
LANGUAGE. WELL THE INTENT AND I
PROMISE YOU, IS IT WAS
SUBMITTED. IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
LATE, IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN LATE,
BUT THE INTENT IS TO ONLY
INCLUDE LICENSED, PREGNANCY
CENTERS. THAT WAS THE INTENT
FROM THE VERY GET GO. HOW IT DID
GET MISSED UP ON THE ORIGINAL
LANGUAGE. I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
HAPPENED, BUT WHEN I WAS MADE
AWARE OF IT AND I READ THAT, WE
DID ENSURE THAT WE HAD AN
AMENDMENT IN SAYING THAT IT WAS
AMENDED. SO. OKAY, I THINK IF IT
PASSES THE COMMITTEE, YOU FOLKS
ARE ABLE TO AMEND IT MOVING
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT. OKAY THAT'S
FAIR, AND SO I GUESS I'LL GIVE
YOU A CHANCE TO CLOSE, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS I CAN'T MOVE
IT. SENATOR CORTEZ IS NOT
INCLINED TO, WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT
FOR ANOTHER MEMBER TO COME BACK
TO MAKE THE MOTION. SO GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE. ABSOLUTELY. WELL I
WANT TO SEE YOUR EXCITEMENT
THERE, CHAIRMAN NEWMAN, ON THIS
BILL, SO, MOST IMPORTANTLY, I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN
ABSOLUTE AGREEMENT THAT THESE
ONLY CATER TO LICENSED MEDICAL,
PREGNANCY CENTERS, YOU KNOW, ONE
OF THE BEAUTIES ABOUT BEING,
BEING BEING ABLE TO SERVE IN
THIS CAPACITY AS A SENATOR IS
THE AVAILABILITY TO, TO
INFORMATION, THE ABILITY TO TALK
TO MANY STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN DIFFERENT SPACES.
AND I HAVE TO BE HONEST, I DID
NOT ACTUALLY KNOW ABOUT
PREGNANCY CENTERS UNTIL I WAS
ACTUALLY BROUGHT FORTH WITH THE
IDEA OF CARRYING THIS PARTICULAR
BILL, AND IT COMPELLED ME TO
ACTUALLY ATTEND AND VISIT ONE OF
MY ACTUALLY, MY LOCAL PREGNANCY
CENTER. AND I WAS SO IMPRESSED
WITH THE WORK THAT WAS THAT I,
THAT I WAS EXPOSED TO FROM THE
FACT THAT IT WAS A WARM
ENVIRONMENT, CARING ENVIRONMENT,
NON-JUDGMENTAL, AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THAT THERE IS THIS
I KNOW YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR
QUESTION WAS WE ALREADY HAVE A
FACILITY THAT, YOU KNOW, WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD THAT OFFER
SERVICES. THAT WAS NOT MY
QUESTION. Ó SORRY. IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE THESE SERVICES AVAILABLE,
BUT WE DON'T HAVE IS THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A LICENSED
PREGNANCY CENTERS THAT ACTUALLY
PROVIDE SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
PREGNANCY AND AFTER THE BIRTH OF
THOSE BABIES. WITH ALL OF THE
FACTS THAT I IN THE DATA THAT I
PRESENTED TODAY, WE ARE A
LEGISLATURE FULL OF DATA. WE
LIKE TO HAVE DATA THAT BACKS
MUCH OF OUR LEGISLATION, WHICH
IS WHY WE'VE INCLUDED EVERYTHING
THAT THEY ALL OF THE SERVICES
THAT THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDE. IT
IS ANOTHER ADDITIONAL RESOURCE
THAT WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
ACCESS TO. AND IN THE
UNDERSTANDING OF DI DIVERSE
OPTIONS, EQUITY, AS MENTIONED
EARLIER BY KAYLEE OR KELLY
BRADFORD. AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR YOUR BEING SO
VULNERABLE TODAY AND SHARING
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. IT IS
VERY POWERFUL, AND INCLUSION,
INCLUDING DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
AND APPROACHES TO MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT PREGNANCY, OR
ABORTION FOR THAT MATTER, FOR
CHOICE. BUT WHAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES, WE DON'T HAVE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE. AND I
BELIEVE AS LEGISLATORS, AS WE
LEARN ABOUT THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND TO OUR TO OUR TO THE YOUNG
WOMEN AND OLDER WOMEN, WHOEVER
MIGHT HAVE AN UNPLANNED
PREGNANCY TO MAKE SURE AND
ENSURE THAT OUR SYSTEMS ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THE ABILITY TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES AND
AWARENESS OF IT. AND WITH THAT,
I WILL, CLOSE WITH SENATE BILL
1368 WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ALONGSIDE THE
RESOURCES THEY ALREADY PROVIDE,
GIVEN THAT LICENSED PREGNANCY
CENTER MANAGEMENT AND STAFF
OFFER EXTENSIVE INFORMATION AND
CONFIDENTIAL SERVICES TO YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE FACING DIFFICULT
PREGNANCY DECISIONS AT NO COST,
THIS SHOULD BE A RESOURCE
OFFERED TO STUDENTS UNDER THE
STATE'S CURRICULUM. STUDENTS
RECEIVE STATE MANDATED
EDUCATION, DESERVE TO KNOW ALL
AVAILABLE OPTIONS SO THEY CAN
MAKE FULLY INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT ALL THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
THEIR SEXUAL HEALTH. THIS IS A
COMPANION TO WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IN SYSTEMS WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. A COLLABORATOR IN IN
IN ENSURING THAT OUR YOUNG WOMEN
HAVE ALL OPTIONS AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT MATTER ON HOLD UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS PRESENT. THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE,
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION. AND WE HAVE. DO YOU
WANT ME TO KNOW? ACTUALLY,
SENATOR GROVE IS ACTUALLY SHE'S
BEEN WAITING. SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND. AND SHE IS IN THE HALL,
AND CHAIRMAN. SENATOR GROVE LEFT
AGAIN. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, NICE TO SEE YOU. NICE
TIE. FOR ME. OKAY. AND WITH THAT
. CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE, AND
BEFORE YOU START, I APOLOGIZE. I
HAVE TO GO PRESENT ANOTHER BILL
AND REVENUE. TAX AND SO I WILL
HAND THE GAVEL TO MY VICE CHAIR
AND I WILL BE BACK AS SOON AS I
CAN. AND YOU'RE GOING TO LEAVE
YOU IN SPIRIT. OKAY YEAH, WELL,
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
WELCOME, SENATOR ARCHULETA. GLAD
TO. AND, MEMBER, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT MY BILL.
AND TODAY I'M PRESENTING SENATE
BILL 1388, WHICH ESTABLISHES
THAT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT CANNOT HOLD
UNRESTRICTED FINANCIAL RESERVES
OVER 16.7% OF ITS ANNUAL
OPERATING BUDGET, UNLESS THREE
GOALS ARE ACHIEVED BY THE
DISTRICT NUMBER ONE. THEY
PARTICIPATE IN THE PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM, AND
NUMBER TWO, THEY PARTICIPATE IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PART TIME
OFFICE HOURS PROGRAM. AND NUMBER
THREE, 75% OF ITS TEACHING HOURS
ARE TAUGHT BY FULL TIME FACULTY.
IF THE SCHOOL COMPLIES WITH
THESE THREE GOALS, THEY WOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM THE CAP. IF A
DISTRICT CHOOSES NOT TO USE
UNALLOCATED FUNDS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS TO BENEFIT STUDENTS
LEARNING AND FACULTY STABILITY,
THE FUNDS WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
TO NON-SUPERVISORY STAFF TO
ENCOURAGE STABILITY FOR STAFF
MEMBERS WHO MAY CURRENTLY
PROVIDE SOME OF THESE SERVICES,
UNCOMPENSATED. IN THE PAST
DECADE, CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
TO PROVIDE PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE, COMPENSATION
FOR OFFICE HOURS, AND TO ENSURE
THAT MOST TEACHING HOURS ARE
BEING PERFORMED BY FULL TIME
FACULTY. DESPITE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INVESTED BY
THE STATE, THE PROGRAMS, WHICH
PROVIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS WITH THESE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND REIMBURSEMENT, ARE
UNDER UNDER-SUBSCRIBED AND
UNDERUTILIZED, WITH MANY
DISTRICTS CHOOSING NOT TO USE
THE GENEROUS STATE RESERVE
FORCES AT ALL. ONLY AROUND HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA 73 COLLEGE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
PARTICIPATE IN THE PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM.
DESPITE PARTIAL OR FULL
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE STATE
WITH SUCH STRONG FINANCIAL
BACKING FROM THE STATE, IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE THAT MANY PART TIME
FACULTY ARE NOT AFFORDED
EMPLOYER HEALTH INSURANCE. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PART TIME
OFFICE HOURS PROGRAM SIMILARLY
PROVIDES UP TO 50% REIMBURSEMENT
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS,
WHO COMPENSATE THEIR PART TIME
FACULTY FOR OFFICE HOURS.
HOWEVER, OVER 20 SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
DESPITE STATE FUNDING.
CONSEQUENTLY, THERE ARE MANY
ADJUTANT OR PART TIME FACULTY AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE STILL NOT
PROVIDED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND STUDENTS WHO STILL DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO OFFICE HOURS FOR
THEIR COURSES OR A STABLE
FACULTY, IN SPITE OF CALIFORNIA
INVESTMENTS. AND WE ALL KNOW THE
MENTOR, THE PROFESSOR, WHEN HE
SPENDS, HE OR SHE SPENDS TIME
WITH YOU. SHE JUST MIGHT. OR HE
JUST MIGHT CHANGE YOUR COURSE OF
ACTION TO STAY IN SCHOOL.
IMAGINE A YOUNG LADY OR YOUNG
MAN WALKING INTO THE TO THE
FACULTY ROOM TO SIT DOWN SOBBING
BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY FOR WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE. AND THAT MENTOR, THAT
PROFESSOR BECAUSE HE'S GIVING UP
HIS TIME 2 OR 3 HOURS IN SOME
CASES, IS NOT BEING COMPENSATED.
AND YET THE TIME AND EFFORT
PROVIDED TO THAT STUDENT OPENS
UP ANOTHER DOOR AND THE STUDENT
EVENTUALLY STAYS IN SCHOOL AND
BEGINS HIS OR HER LIFE, TO
CONTINUE ON. BUT YET THAT
TEACHER WAS NOT COMPENSATED FOR
MORE THAN 30 YEARS. FOR MORE
THAN 30 YEARS, CALIFORNIA'S
ESTABLISHED THAT DISTRICTS
SHOULD HAVE 75% OF ALL HOURS OF
INSTRUCTION TAUGHT BY FULL TIME
FACULTY, AND HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TOWARDS
THAT GOAL. SO THE STATE HAS DONE
ITS PART. DESPITE THIS RECENT
YEARS HAVE ACTUALLY SEEN A
DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF
TEACHING HOURS TAUGHT BY FULL
TIME FACULTY, WITH ONLY A
HANDFUL OF THESE DISTRICTS
CURRENTLY AT THE 75% LEVEL.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CONTINUE TO
ACCRUE RECORD LEVEL LOCAL
RESERVES DURING THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD OF 2020 2020 TO 2023. THE
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS WITH
RESERVES IN EXCESS OF 33% HAS
DOUBLED. NEARLY 1 IN 4 SCHOOLS
HAVE OVER 40, AND TEN DISTRICTS
CARRY NEARLY RESERVES OF OVER
60. AND REMEMBER, THE NUMBER THE
CAP WAS 16.7. AND WE'RE TALKING
RESERVES IN EXCESS OF 60. THOSE
MONIES COULD BE USED TOWARDS, AS
WE SAID, INSURANCE, FULL TIME
FACULTY AND CERTAINLY TAKING
CARE OF THOSE TEACHERS AND
PROFESSORS WHO WORK WITH THE
KIDS. AFTER HOURS. SENATE BILL
1388 PROMOTES FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY WITHIN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS, WHILE ALSO
DIRECTLY BENEFITING FACULTY AND
STUDENTS BY SETTING A REASONABLE
LIMIT ON UNRESTRICTED GENERAL
FUND BALANCES. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS DO NOT HOLD EXCESS
FUNDS UNLESS THEY FIRST ENSURE A
BASELINE LEVEL OF SUPPORT FOR
THEIR STAFF AND THEIR STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS JIM
MULLER, PRESIDENT OF A F T LOCAL
1931 AND PROFESSOR OF
MATHEMATICS AT SAN DIEGO AND
GROSSMONT CHEMEKETA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, AS WELL AS DAVID
HAWKINS, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, INDEPENDENCE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME, IF I MAY, VERY MUCH,
SENATOR ARCHULETA, AND PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR NAME AND YOUR,
AFFILIATION AND PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, DAVID HAWKINS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INDEPENDENTS. WE REPRESENT
12,000 COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY, TEACHING, ROUGHLY A
HALF MILLION STUDENTS. I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT SENATE BILL 1388
DOESN'T CAP, A DISTRICT'S
RESERVE, IT SIMPLY SETS A LEVEL
THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS
ALREADY DETERMINED. IS ADEQUATE.
THE 16.7% DISTRICTS WILL STILL
BE ALLOWED TO EXCEED THAT SIMPLY
BY COMPLYING WITH FUNDAMENTAL
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE FOR DECADES, THAT
THE DISTRICTS HAVE NOT COMPLIED
WITH, ONE OF THEM BEING THE 75%
OF INSTRUCTION BE TAUGHT BY FULL
TIME FACULTY. THAT PART TIME
FACULTY BE ARE COMPENSATED FOR
OFFICE HOURS. SO OUR STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO ACADEMIC
COUNSELING AND MENTORING. AND
THEN THE HEALTH CARE ISSUE.
HERE'S WHAT HAS OCCURRED. OVER
RECENT YEARS. WE DON'T BELIEVE
THIS IS A LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE.
WE THINK THIS IS A LOCAL CONTROL
ISSUE THAT HAS LACKED ANY SORT
OF OVERSIGHT OR ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS. THE
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
EXCEEDED 33% IN THEIR BUDGET, IN
THEIR UNRESTRICTED BUDGET
RESERVES, HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED.
CURRENTLY, ONE OUT OF EVERY FOUR
DISTRICTS HAVE BUDGET RESERVES
IN EXCESS. AGAIN UNRESTRICTED
BUDGET RESERVES THAT CAN BE USED
FOR PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS AND
FACULTY 1 IN 4 EXCEED 40. WE
HAVE TEN DISTRICTS THAT NOW
EXCEED 60% IN UNRESTRICTED
RESERVES THAT COULD BE USED FOR
OTHER PURPOSES. ONE OF THESE
ISSUES, HAS TO DO WITH THE 75%
RULE IN REGARDS TO INSTRUCTIONAL
FACULTY. SO THIS IS A GOAL THAT
YOU ESTABLISHED BACK IN 1988.
YOU HAVE YOU HAVE GIVEN $450
MILLION TO INCREASE THAT
PERCENTAGE. A RECENT STATE AUDIT
THAT WE SPONSORED THAT CAME OUT
FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR, SHOW
THERE'S ACTUALLY A DECLINE IN
THAT PERCENTAGE. AND WHAT THE
AUDITOR FOUND FOR THE DISTRICT,
THAT THEY AUDITED IS THAT
DISTRICTS WERE EITHER NOT
SPENDING THE FUNDS CORRECTLY OR
SIMPLY WEREN'T SPENDING THEM AT
ALL. ANOTHER CONSEQUENCE OF
ALLOWING DISTRICTS TO HAVE LOCAL
CONTROL WITHOUT ANY ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT OR ACCOUNTABILITY, HAS
BEEN AN INCREASE IN FULL TIME
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS DURING
A PERIOD WHERE YOU'VE HAD A 20%
DECLINE IN STUDENT ENROLLMENT,
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS
UNRELATED TO STUDENT OUTCOMES,
OR STUDENT SUCCESS PROGRAMS
INCREASED BY 45. SO WE'RE NOT
ASKING TO LIMIT AND CAP THE
DISTRICTS. WE SIMPLY WANT THE
DISTRICTS TO INSTILL THE
PRIORITIES THAT THIS BODY HAS
GIVEN HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO INITIATE AND PUT SOME
CONTROLS OVER THE LEVEL OF
RESERVES BASED ON THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M JIM MILLER. I'M A FACULTY
MEMBER AT SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE
IN THE AREAS OF MATHEMATICS,
ENGINEERING AND PHYSICS. I'M
ALSO PRESIDENT OF OUR LOCAL, AND
I'M AN ACTIVE OFFICER IN THE
STATEWIDE UNION CFT UNION OF
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS AND
EDUCATORS. WE REPRESENT OVER
120,000 MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, AND THE SENATOR LAID IT
OUT PERFECTLY. THE ARGUMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND I'LL
JUST BE THE WINDOW DRESSING TO
HIS COMMENTS, AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES, HAVING BEEN IN
EDUCATION FOR MANY DECADES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WORLD, ALL OF
US IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WORLD, AS WELL AS EDUCATION IN
GENERAL, WE GET INTO THAT
PROFESSION BECAUSE WE WANT TO
HELP STUDENTS AND WE WANT TO
SERVE STUDENTS. AND TO THAT END,
WE'VE SPONSORED SEVERAL PIECES
OF LEGISLATION OVER THE YEARS,
GOING BACK TO 1988, AB 1725, THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REFORM BILL.
ONE OF THE MAIN TENETS IN THAT
BILL WAS TO GET TO 75% OF ALL
INSTRUCTION BEING TAUGHT BY FULL
TIME FACULTY, COMPARED TO PART
TIME FACULTY. THAT'S BEEN OVER
30 YEARS. AND THAT NEEDLE HAS
NOT MOVED AT ALL IN THAT 30 YEAR
TIME PERIOD. WE HAVE NOT MADE
ANY PROGRESS TOWARDS THAT GOAL
AS A STATEWIDE SYSTEM, WE THERE
ARE SEVERAL STUDIES THAT THAT
SHOW THE NUMBER ONE DETERMINING
FACTOR FOR STUDENT SUCCESS IS
FACULTY CONTACT. THE MORE
FACULTY CONTACT STUDENTS HAVE,
THE MORE SUCCESSFUL THEY'RE
GOING TO BE. THAT'S WHY WE'VE
PUT THESE, LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
FORWARD AND WHY THEY'VE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE GOVERNOR IS TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL. OUR ADJUNCT FACULTY,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEIR
NUMBERS DIMINISHED AT THE
EXPENSE OF HAVING MORE FULL TIME
FACULTY, THEY STILL REMAIN THE
MAJORITY OF OUR EMPLOYEES IN
TERMS OF HEADCOUNT. OUR ADJUNCT
FACULTY OUTNUMBER OUR FULL TIME
FACULTY 2 TO 1. BECAUSE OF THAT,
WE'VE HAD TO ADD OTHER
INCENTIVES TO MAKE THEM WANT TO
STAY IN THE WORKFORCE, AS WELL
AS FEEL PART OF THE INSTITUTION.
THÀNH SUCH AS THE OFFICE, OUR
PROGRAM AND THE HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM. SO ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE
TO PROVIDE A MORE SOUND,
PHYSICAL, EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT AND COMMITMENT TO
THE INSTITUTION OF OUR FACULTY
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE A
BETTER SERVICE TO STUDENTS SO
OUR STUDENTS CAN SUCCEED SO THEY
CAN BE TRAINED APPROPRIATELY TO
SEEK OUT WORKPLACE JOBS OR
TRANSFER ONTO FOUR YEAR COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. DESPITE ALL OF
THESE EFFORTS, DESPITE THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE, DESPITE THE
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS, AS
MENTIONED, THERE ARE FAR TOO
MANY DISTRICTS WHO, INSTEAD OF
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE FUNDING
MADE AVAILABLE, HAVE INSTEAD
OPTED TO EITHER SPEND IT ON
OTHER THINGS OR TO JUST SAVE IT.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE NOT
INTENDED TO BE SAVINGS AND LOAN
INSTITUTIONS. THEY'RE INTENDED
TO BE THERE TO SERVE STUDENTS.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO WRAP UP,
OKAY. WE'RE YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM, DISTRICTS THAT WERE, YOU
KNOW, TAKING AWAY THEIR FAVORITE
F WORD FLEXIBILITY. AND WE ARE
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T USED THE
MONEY WHERE IT'S BEEN INTENDED
TO BE USED OVER ALL THESE YEARS.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. SO WE URGE
YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU. SO
WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB 1388
HERE IN ROOM 2100, BRIAN HOWE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, ON BEHALF OF 29,000
MEMBERS, WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANNA MATTHEWS, FORMER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT, ON
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, REPRESENTING
7000 PART TIME AND FULL TIME
FACULTY MEMBERS. PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. KATIE
HARDIMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THÀNH,
REPRESENTING 310,000 MEMBERS. WE
ARE ALSO A CO-SPONSOR OF THE
BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF SB 1388,
WE'RE NOT CONTINUE WITH ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1388.
GOOD MORNING, ANDREW MARTINEZ,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
MUST BE OPPOSED TO SB 1388. WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR MEETING WITH US AND
HAVING A CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL, WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL
BECAUSE WE ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
CONCERNED THAT THIS WILL TAKE
AWAY OUR ABILITY, OUR COLLEGE
DISTRICTS, ON BEHALF OF OUR 73
DISTRICTS, 116 COLLEGES, THE
ABILITY TO ADDRESS A FISCAL
CRISIS, SHOULD IT COME UP IN THE
FUTURE, AND THAT IT TAKES AWAY
THE LOCAL DISTRICTS ABILITY TO
MANAGE THEIR BUDGETS AS THEY SEE
APPROPRIATE. I THINK THE
PANDEMIC HAS CERTAINLY BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR OUR COLLEGES AS WE
RETURN BACK TO NORMAL, THE
INFLUX OF REVENUES COMING IN
FROM THE STATE AND FEDERAL HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN A BLESSING TO US,
BUT IT'S ALSO BEEN A CHALLENGE
FOR US TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE IN
A SITUATION WHERE WE ARE
MANAGING THOSE DOLLARS
APPROPRIATELY. AND SO I THINK
YOU MIGHT SEE THAT THAT'S PART
OF THE REASON WHY RESERVES ARE
GOING UP SO SIGNIFICANTLY AS WE
ARE TRYING TO SPEND DOWN THOSE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE A CERTAIN TIME
LIMIT TO THEM, ATTACHED TO THEM.
AND ALSO, HONESTLY, WE ARE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WAS
PROPOSED FOR US IN JANUARY, AND
WE HOPE THAT IT HOLDS INTO INTO
THE MAY REVISION AS WELL. BUT WE
ARE VERY COGNIZANT OF THE FACT
THAT, THIS YEAR IS NOT LOOKING
GREAT FOR THE STATE. NEXT YEAR
ALSO IS GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE
IN THE FOLLOWING TWO YEARS AS
WELL. WILL BE A CHALLENGE
FISCALLY FOR THE STATE AND
THEREFORE A CHALLENGE FOR US AS
WELL, WE ARE VERY COGNIZANT OF
THE FACT THAT OUR SISTER
INSTITUTIONS, CSU, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM, AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FACE DEFERRALS THIS
YEAR AS PART OF THE EARLY
ACTIONS AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT'S ALWAYS A POTENTIAL
POSSIBILITY IN THE FUTURE FOR US
AS WELL GOING FORWARD, GIVING US
THE TOOLS AND ABILITY TO MANAGE
THAT, THAT DEFERRALS, IF THEY
COME INTO THE FUTURE, WOULD BE
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
AVOID DOING FURLOUGHS, LAYOFFS
AND SO FORTH. THE 16.7% WAS
INTENDED TO BE A MINIMUM LEVEL
OF RESERVES RECOMMENDED TO THE
COLLEGES TO HAVE ON HAND. IT WAS
NEVER MEANT TO BE A CAP, SO
PLACING THAT CAP IN PLACE WOULD
BE A TREMENDOUSLY CHALLENGING
FOR US GOING FORWARD, AND
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU CAN GO ABOVE
IT IF YOU HIT THOSE THREE
POINTS, BUT IT WILL BE A
CHALLENGE FOR US GOING INTO THIS
FISCAL CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACING US IN THE FUTURE. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
HAVE THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
HANDLE EMERGENCY, ENSURE THAT
OUR DISTRICTS HAVE THE FISCAL
CONTROLS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
VOTED ON BY THEIR CONSTITUENTS
TO HAVE THAT THOSE REMAIN IN
PLACE. WE MUST BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MICHELLE MCKAY
UNDERWOOD. ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
, IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD PLACE AN
ARTIFICIAL AND INFLEXIBLE LIMIT
ON THE DISTRICT'S RESERVES. THIS
IS AN AFFRONT TO LOCAL CONTROL
THAT PREVENTS DISTRICT LEADERS
FROM MAKING LOCAL FUNDING
DECISIONS IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF PRUDENT FISCAL OPERATIONS.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES A
GREAT JOB OF HIGHLIGHTING THE
MANY FUNDING UNCERTAINTIES THAT
COLLEGES FACE. THEIR SHORTFALLS
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN STATE
FUNDS AND LOCAL FUNDS, AND
STUDENT FEES, NONE OF WHICH ARE
GUARANTEED TO BE BACKFILLED BY
THE STATE. SO WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO PLAN FOR THAT AND BE ABLE TO
SMOOTH OVER THOSE DEFICITS. WE
BELIEVE THE POLICY IS ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS AS THE STATE FACES A
BUDGET GAP IN THE TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. SHOULD
DISTRICTS BE REQUIRED TO
LIQUIDATE THEIR RESERVES AND
THEN BE HIT BY DEFERRALS, YOU
KNOW, WE WOULD BE VERY CONCERNED
THAT WE WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
FEWER RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
WEATHER THAT STORM, AND THAT
WOULD RESULT IN MORE DRACONIAN
CUTS THAN SHOULD THOSE RESERVES
HAVE BEEN PRESERVED IN ORDER TO,
YOU KNOW, MAKE OR MAKE WISER
DECISIONS, SHOULD WE BE HIT WITH
DEFERRALS? AS STATED, THE 60
16.7% LEVEL IS A MINIMUM FOR
FISCAL STABILITY, WHICH BENEFITS
COLLEGES, STUDENTS AND STAFF. I
THINK ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS TO
SORT OF REFLECT ON THE
CONVERSATION THIS MORNING IS
THAT IF THE GOAL IS TO, YOU
KNOW, MANDATE SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE HAS MADE
OPTIONAL, WE THINK THAT TYING IT
TO A RESERVE CAP IS REALLY A
TENUOUS LINK, THAT WE THINK
THERE COULD BE OTHER WAYS TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION HAPPEN
THAN TO FORCE THE RESERVES TO BE
WITH, DRAWN DOWN. SO ON BEHALF
AGAIN, OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS, WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1388 HERE IN
ROOM 2100. WELCOME THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD, ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY, CONTRA COSTA,
KERN, PALO VERDE AND SAN
BERNARDINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
DAVID NEVIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLAN, HANCOCK AND CUESTA
COLLEGES, IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING. KYLE HIGHLAND, ON
BEHALF OF THE SIERRA JOINT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE MIRACOSTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CASEY ELLIOTT, ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT, IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, MANNY
DIAZ REPRESENTING SAN JOSE.
EVERGREEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING, KATE STALLETTO
REPRESENTING WEST VALLEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO ALL OUR WITNESSES
IN BOTH IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM 2100 FOR
SB 1388. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS. DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS, SENATOR CORTESE NO.
OKAY. SO KHÓ Þ, WE HAVE A MOTION
TO MOVE THE BILL. CLOSED. I
GUESS WE CAN, WHAT'S THAT? I'M
NOT SURE IF WE SHOULD TAKE UP
THE MOTION. I'LL LEAVE IT TO THE
CHAIR. SURE ABSOLUTELY. I THINK
I JUST HAVE ONE ONE QUESTION
SLASH COMMENT ON, ON ON THIS
PARTICULAR CONCERN THAT WE HAVE,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CAPPING, I
AM CONCERNED WITH THE BUDGET
DEFICIT THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
FACING, AND IT'S PROJECTED TO
PROCEED IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS AND SO FORTH. DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT NOW WOULD BE THE
BEST TIME TO DO TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD, CONSIDERING THE
FACT THAT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO KIND OF
NAVIGATE, YOU KNOW, THE
UNCERTAINTIES, MADAM CHAIR.
FUTURE, WHEN DO WE TURN THINGS
AROUND AND MAKE THEM RIGHT?
BECAUSE WE HAD A WRONG. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT STUDENTS HUNDREDS
UPON HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS,
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THAT LOOK
UPON THE PROFESSORS AS THAT
MENTOR. AS I MENTIONED AT. AND
WHEN THEY'RE NOT THERE, THE
QUESTION IS WHY AREN'T THEY
THERE? BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PAID
TO WORK AFTER HOURS AND THERE'S
NO REASON FOR THAT BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ALLOCATED
THE FUNDS. AND WHEN WE DO HAVE A
PROFESSOR HERE, WE HAVE
PROFESSORS IN THE SYSTEM THAT
HAVE BEEN TEACHING, FIVE, TEN,
15, 20 YEARS, AND THEY'RE STILL
PART TIME. WHY BECAUSE THEY'VE
FOUND A SYSTEM IN A WAY, TO GET
AROUND THE FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THAT PURPOSE. AND
YET, AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE
TEACHERS OR PROFESSORS THAT ARE
WITHOUT HEALTH INSURANCE. AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY CALL THEM,
FREEWAY FLIER TEACHERS, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO GO FROM ONE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO ANOTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO MAKE A
LIVING. AND THAT'S NOT RIGHT,
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD BE STABLE IN
ONE COLLEGE AND ONE COLLEGE ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
MILLIONS AND AGAIN, I SAY, THIS
IS NOT TODAY'S PROBLEM. THIS
PROBLEM HAS BEEN GOING ON. AND
SO WHEN YOU YOURSELF WERE UP
HERE JUST A MINUTE AGO, YOU WERE
FIGHTING FOR SOMEONE WHO NEEDED
HELP. WELL, I'M UP HERE FIGHTING
FOR THOUSAND OF PEOPLE WHO NEED
HELP. THE TEACHERS, THE FACULTY,
THE STUDENTS AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
WE CAN'T OVERLOOK WHAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR SOCIETY, AND IT'S IN DIRE
NEED OF HELP, NO DOUBT. BUT WE
NEED THAT TO BE PROVIDED TO THE
TEACHERS, THE PROFESSORS AND
EVERYONE ELSE. AND WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE NUMBERS OVER THE YEARS,
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
GIVEN ALLOCATED SPECIFICALLY TO
INCREASE THEIR TEACHER NUMBERS.
AND THERE IS A LINE ITEM AND IT
SAYS 3 MILLION FOR TEACHERS, 2
MILLION FOR TEACHERS, THREE. AND
IT GOES RIGHT DOWN THE LINE. AND
YET THEY DIDN'T DO IT. WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO KEEP THAT
RESERVE AS HIGH AS THEY COULD
KEEP IT 5060, SOME EVEN HIGH AS
80% STATISTICALLY, WHEN 16% IS
FINE AND IF THEY WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE, FINE. SO
WE'RE NOT PUTTING A CAP ON IT.
WE'RE JUST SAYING TAKE CARE OF
THOSE STUDENTS AND THOSE
TEACHERS THAT ARE WORKING SO
HARD TO PRESERVE, TO PRESERVE
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. SO SO
THIS BILL, 1388, IS NOT TYING
THE HANDS OF THE, THE SCHOOL
BOARDS. IT'S ACTUALLY TELLING
THEM THAT IT'S OKAY TO DO WHAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. MANDATED
ALMOST BY THE STATE MONIES ARE
GIVEN SPECIFICALLY, WHAT IF THE
MONEY WAS GIVEN FOR, HEALTH CARE
AS AN EXAMPLE, THAT WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER AND
THEY DIDN'T USE IT SHAMEFULLY?
WELL, IF IT'S ALLOCATED, THEN
LET'S USE IT FOR THAT. AND THE
STATE HAS DONE THAT. THE THE
REGENTS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT,
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT, THAT PUT
THIS ON THE TABLE, SO IT'S TIME
NOW THAT WE ADJUST AND WE GO
BACK, WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE DONE. AND IF THE SCALE GOES
UP AND DOWN, SO BE IT. BECAUSE
IF WE'RE TALKING 20 YEARS BACK,
30 YEARS BACK, IT'S SOMETHING
THEY DID WRONG. WE'VE GOT TO
CORRECT IT AND NOW IS THE TIME
TO DO IT. SO, AS THE CHAIR JUST
WALKED IN, I WANT HIM TO KNOW
THAT THE FACULTIES THAT OR THE
MEMBERS THAT THAT WERE IN
OPPOSITION, NOT ONE MENTIONED
THE STUDENTS, NOT ONE MENTIONED
HEALTH CARE. OH, I'M SO SORRY
THAT WE'VE HAD PEOPLE FOR 20
YEARS WORKING AND WE HAVEN'T
GIVEN THEM A FULL TIME JOB. NØ
NHÀ SAID THAT NO, THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MONEY IS
THERE, BUT NO ONE TALKS ABOUT
THE STUDENTS AND THE MENTORS
THAT ARE NEEDED. SO LET'S TURN
THIS CLOCK AROUND AND MAKE SURE
WE GO BACK TO WHERE WE STARTED
TO TAKE CARE OF THE STUDENTS,
THE FACULTY, AND CERTAINLY TO DO
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. AND
THAT'S WHY I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
SENATE BILL 1388. AND I THINK
THAT GOING FORWARD WITH AND
TAKING IT ON TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WILL OPEN UP QUITE A
FEW DOORS FOR THE STUDENTS AND
FACULTY IN THE FUTURE. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WELL, ACTUALLY, A LITTLE MORE, A
LITTLE MORE. MR. HAWKINS, I
THINK YOU HAD SOMETHING YOU
WANTED TO. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU. STARTLING FIGURE CAME TO US
YESTERDAY IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE. THEY DID AN
ANALYSIS OF THE RESERVES.
DISTRICT RESERVES EXCEED $3
BILLION, $3.1 BILLION OF FUNDS
THAT COULD BE USED TO HELP
STUDENTS AND FACULTY. WE THINK
THAT'S ABSURD AND SHOULD NOT BE
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED. $3.1
BILLION. SENATOR NEWMAN,
APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR
ARCHULETA, I BELIEVE THAT WAS
YOUR CLOSE. IT WAS, SIR, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, I'VE
GOT A MOTION FROM SENATOR
CORTESE, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
EIGHT, SB 1388. OUR ARCHULETA
MOTION IS Dð PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH NOT
VOTING. CORTEZ CORTESE. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS TWO
VOTES, FOUR ZERO AGAINST LIMON.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
WHO. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS OKAY, SENATOR
GROVE, YOU HAVE BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY, YOU ARE HERE TO
PRESENT SB 1203.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
YOUR WITNESSES GET SEATED, YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SB 12. OH THREE,
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION FLEX
ACCOUNT FOR K THROUGH 12
EDUCATION. NOW, CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL SYSTEM IS IN CRISIS, AND
WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S A
BASE, A BASELINE. PUBLIC SCHOOLS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN ON THE FUNDAMENTALS OF
READING, WRITING AND ENGLISH AND
PROFICIENCY IN MATH AND SCIENCE.
DESPITE SPENDING $1,000 MORE PER
STUDENT WITH THE THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE, CALIFORNIA HAS
CONSISTENTLY RANKED BELOW THE
NATION IN ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
AMONG FOURTH AND EIGHTH GRADERS.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW, THE
LEGISLATURE INTRODUCES THOUSANDS
OF BILLS EVERY YEAR THAT CREATE
NEW POLICIES OR FIX OLD POLICIES
BECAUSE THEY SEEM TO HAVE A
PROBLEM. AND WE DO THAT, WE FIX
THOSE THINGS. TOO MANY CHILDREN
ARE FAILING AND WE NEED TO MEET
THE MIDDLE. THEY'RE FAILING TO
MEET THE MINIMAL EDUCATION
STANDARDS. THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT IMPACTS EVERY SINGLE CHILD
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIFE. WE
NEED A SOLUTION THAT WILL
DISRUPT THE STATUS QUO, WHICH IS
WHY I'M HERE TODAY TO GIVE
STUDENTS AND PARENTS OPTIONS IN
EDUCATION. TOO MANY SO CALLED
SOLUTIONS ARE FORCED ON KEEPING
OUR KIDS AND OUR STUDENTS IN
UNDERPERFORMING SCHOOLS JUST
BECAUSE OF THEIR ZIP CODE.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON EVERY
CHILD IN INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON
GIVING EVERY CHILD THE BEST
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY
COULD POSSIBLY GET AND PROVIDE
UPWARD MOBILITY, WE NEED TO LOOK
AT SOLUTIONS LIKE THE ONE I'M
PRESENTING HERE TODAY. WE KNOW
THAT PARENTAL CHOICE WORKS IN
EDUCATION WITH 29 OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE HAVE SOME FORM OF
PARENTAL CHOICE PROGRAMS. IT
ALLOWS PARENTS TO IDENTIFY THE
GAPS IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION THAT CAN BE FILLED
WITH ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS. WE
KNOW THAT SCHOOL CHOICE WORKS
IN. THE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
BLACK AND BROWN STUDENTS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE ACCELERATED
AND OUTPERFORMED THEIR PEERS. IN
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS, THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM, BUT THANKFULLY, AS I
SAID EARLIER, THERE'S ALSO A WAY
TO FIX IT. SENATE BILL 1203 WILL
ESTABLISH A CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
FLEX ACCOUNT OF 2024. THIS
INNOVATIVE LEGISLATION CREATES
AN INDIVIDUALIZED APPROACH TO K
THROUGH 12 EDUCATION BY ALLOWING
PARENTS TO CHOOSE WHAT
ACCREDITED SCHOOLS BEST SUITS
THEIR CHILD'S NEEDS, AND HAVE
THOSE STUDENTS SHARE OF
PROPOSITION 98 FUNDS FOLLOW
THEM. SB 1203 WILL CREATE AN
EDUCATION FLEX ACCOUNT, WHICH
WILL ALLOW FOR $8,000 TO BE USED
TOWARDS THE TUITION AND
EDUCATION EXPENSES. IT ALSO
CREATES A SPECIAL EDUCATION FLEX
ACCOUNT, WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR
$16,000 TO BE USED TOWARDS
TUITION AND OTHER EXPENSES THAT
STUDENTS HAVE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
A YOUNG LADY IN MY DISTRICT
WHO'S, NOT A MEDIUM LEVEL
FUNCTIONING DOWN SYNDROME CHILD,
WHICH WAS TRADITIONALLY JUST
WAREHOUSED IN A SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THE TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM IN A SPECIAL EDUCATION
CLASS, HER PARENTS FOUND A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND IT'S $9,000 A
YEAR, AND THEY PICKED UP EXTRA
WORK TO BE ABLE TO PAY THAT
$9,000 A YEAR. THIS YOUNG LADY
IS NOW THRIVING. SHE'S PLAYING
SOFTBALL. SHE'S DEVELOPED AN
ARTISTIC ABILITY WHERE SHE,
WHERE THE ART TEACHERS HAVE
WORKED WITH HER. AND SHE'S VERY
CONFIDENT. SHE GOES OUT AND
MEETS AND GREETS PEOPLE, SHAKES
THEIR HAND, ENGAGES IN
COMMUNICATION. WHERE BEFORE THAT
WAS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS IN OUR TONE
OF SOLUTIONS THAT PARENTS PICK
FOR THEIR CHILDREN, REALLY DOES
WORK. AND I THINK WE SHOULD GET
EVERY CHILD, INCLUDING THE DOWN
SYNDROME CHILD THAT I JUST SPOKE
ABOUT AND THOSE IN LOWER
PERFORMING SCHOOLS, AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE UPWARD
MOBILITY AND THE BEST EDUCATION
POSSIBLE. BOTH OF THESE FUNDS
MUST BE USED DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR, AND ANY UNDERUSED FUNDS
WOULD BE FROM THAT SCHOOL YEAR
WOULD GO BACK AND REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND TO BE USED FOR K
THROUGH 12 EDUCATION. THINK
ABOUT IT. UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
WOULD NO LONGER BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN LOW
PERFORMING PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THEIR
PARENTS COULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO GIVE THEM A GREAT
EDUCATION THAT SUITS THEIR
LEARNING STYLE. AND IF STAYING
IN THAT TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL BASED ON THEIR ZIP CODE
IS THE BEST OPTION FOR THOSE
STUDENTS, THEY CAN STILL HAVE
THAT CHOICE. THESE BILLS WILL.
THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER THESE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL THEIR
CHILDREN IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
BETTER SUITED FOR INDIVIDUAL AND
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS. OUR CHILDREN
HAVE SUFFERED ENOUGH THROUGH THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF EDUCATION
DISRUPTION, COVID SHUTDOWNS AND
REMOTE LEARNING. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BEGIN TO FUND STUDENTS
AND NOT SYSTEMS THAT DON'T WORK
FOR FAR TOO MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN. WE HAVE TO START
INVESTING IN THE NEXT
GENERATION. LET'S PROVIDE
FUNDING TO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PUTTING STUDENTS FIRST AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SCHOOLCHILDREN
UP AND DOWN THE STATE, BECAUSE
OUR FUTURE DEPENDS ON IT. I HAD
A WITNESS THAT CAME AND
TESTIFIED LAST YEAR THAT TALKED
ABOUT HER SON, THAT WAS SEVERELY
AUTISTIC, AND SHE GOT HIM SHE HE
WAS JUST BEING HELD IN A IN, YOU
KNOW, A CLASSROOM AT A
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL. HE
WAS NONVERBAL. AND THEN HE ALSO
CAME UP TO THE COMMITTEE, HE GOT
A TRAINING AND SO THAT HE COULD
IDENTIFY THIS IS A NONVERBAL
STUDENT THAT COULD IDENTIFY
THINGS THAT COULDN'T BE
IDENTIFIED IN CERTAIN COMPUTER
LANGUAGES. AND HE WAS VERY GOOD
AT IT. AND NOW HE'S EXCELLING IN
THAT, AND HE HAS THE CAPABILITY
OF GETTING A JOB IN CYBER
SECURITY JUST BECAUSE HE
RECOGNIZES THINGS THAT OUR
BRAINS DON'T RECOGNIZE. WHY
SHOULDN'T ALL OF OUR KIDS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCCESS AND
UPWARD MOBILITY HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS DOCTOR HAGEN,
THE PRESIDENT OF CAPITAL
CHRISTIAN SCHOOLS AND DESTINY
CHRISTIAN ACADEMY, DOCTOR HAGEN
AND ALSO LANCE CHRISTIANSEN,
DOCTOR EGAN, WELCOME. PLEASE
PROCEED. YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES,
HELLO. MY NAME AGAIN IS DOCTOR
SCOTT HAGEN. AND I HOLD AN
EARNED DOCTORATE FROM GONZAGA
UNIVERSITY. AND I WAS RECENTLY
AWARDED A POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP AT PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY IN NEW JERSEY, WHICH
I'M CURRENTLY A PART OF. FOR THE
LAST SIX YEARS, I SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT OF NORTH CENTRAL
UNIVERSITY IN DOWNTOWN
MINNEAPOLIS. MY UNIVERSITY IS
LOCATED ON WAS LOCATED ON
CHICAGO AVENUE IN THE INNER CITY
OF MINNEAPOLIS, AND WAS RIGHT
NEAR WHERE GEORGE FLOYD WAS
KILLED. I SOON FOUND MYSELF IN
THE CENTER OF THAT AMERICAN
MOMENT. I HAD THE PRIVILEGE AS
THE PRESIDENT OF NORTH CENTRAL
UNIVERSITY, OF OPENING UP OUR
CAMPUS AND HOSTING THE GEORGE
FLOYD FUNERAL. IT WAS SEEN BY
OVER 100 MILLION PEOPLE ON CNN.
I HAD THE HONOR OF ORGANIZING
AND SPEAKING AT THE MEMORIAL
SERVICE. IT WAS ALSO THERE THAT
I LAUNCHED ON CNN THE GEORGE
FLOYD SCHOLARSHIP, WHICH IN TURN
WAS COVERED BY FORBES AND HAS
RESULTED IN OVER $50 MILLION
RAISED FOR LOW ACCESS STUDENTS
TO COLLEGE, I SAY ALL THAT NOT
TO BOAST. I ONLY SAY THAT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT I CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT EDUCATION AND CREATING
ACCESS. I SPOKE FOR THREE
MINUTES IN 18 SECONDS AT THE
FLOYD MEMORIAL SERVICE, AND
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING HARVARD,
YALE, MICHIGAN, UCLA, PENN STATE
ALL FOLLOWED, AND HAS RAISED
BETWEEN 50 AND $75 MILLION FOR
STUDENTS AFTER RETIRING FROM
THAT ROLE AT NORTH CENTRAL IN
MINNEAPOLIS LAST MAY, I RETURNED
TO MY HOMETOWN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA, WHERE I
HAVE UNEXPECTEDLY FOUND MYSELF
NAVIGATING THE TRANSITION OF
CAPITAL CHRISTIAN SCHOOL ON
HIGHWAY 50 TO DESTINY CHRISTIAN
ACADEMY, ONE OF THE MOST
PROMINENT K-12 PRIVATE SCHOOL
ENTITIES IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH NEARLY A THOUSAND STUDENTS.
IT'S LOCATED ON HIGHWAY 50 AND
BRADSHAW. FOR A LARGE PORTION OF
OUR CURRENT STUDENT BODY ARE
STUDENTS OF COLOR, MANY COMING
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES, THE
CURRICULUM AND EXPERTISE OF THE
FACULTY AT THIS K-12 SCHOOL HERE
IN SACRAMENTO HAS PUT GRADUATES
AT VANDERBILT, CAL, UCLA,
HARVARD, UC DAVIS SCORES OF
OTHER UNIVERSITIES FOR MANY OF
THE STUDENTS, THE COMBINATION OF
A PRIVATE RELIGIOUS AND LIBERAL
ARTS CURRICULUM HAS BEEN THE
WINNING TICKET FOR THEM
EDUCATIONALLY. BUT THE FACT
REMAINS THAT THERE ARE STILL
SCORES OF THOSE KIDS THAT COME
FROM SINGLE PARENT AND EVEN TWO
PARENT HOMES WHO CANNOT ACCESS
THIS LEVEL OF EDUCATION THAT IS
FITTED AND TAILORED TO THEIR
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS. SB 1203 HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BE A
TRANSFORMATIVE POLICY TO CREATE
UPWARD MOBILITY AND NOT JUST
ACCESS, BUT GREATNESS, I KNOW
THAT IT ALL REQUIRES THAT IT
PASS THROUGH THE HANDS OF
LEGISLATORS AND SUBCOMMITTEES,
AND I JUST HOPE AND PRAY THAT
YOU WILL GIVE THIS POSSIBILITY A
LEGITIMATE CHANCE. PLEASE,
PLEASE, PLEASE DON'T LET THIS
CONVERSATION DIE. CALIFORNIA CAN
LEAD THE WAY. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS TAKEN SOME WONDERFUL STEPS
TO CONNECT WITH THE RELIGIOUS
AND PRIVATE COMMUNITIES OF
FAITH, TO WORK IN OTHER ARENAS
OF ACCESS AND DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO PEOPLE IN OUR STATE.
I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD
THE WAY IN, CREATE A WELL
INFORMED RELIGIOUS TOWNSHIP
BETWEEN PRIVATE EDUCATION AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO AS
AN EDUCATOR AND PASTOR, I
BELIEVE IN THE TAUTOLOGY OF
ACCESS AND MERIT. I BELIEVE THEY
GO TOGETHER. WE MUST INNOVATE.
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS SB 1203 IS
THAT EXACT PATH TO INNOVATION?
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION ALIVE. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR HAGAN. MR. CHRISTIANSEN.
WELCOME, CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN. LANCE
CHRISTIANSEN AT THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY CENTER. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OR IN SUPPORT OF SB
1203 AND SENATOR GROVE OUTLINED
A LOT OF THE CHALLENGES THAT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM FACES IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I DON'T I DON'T
WANT TO GO OVER ALL THOSE STATS.
YOU KNOW, THEM. BUT WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IS THE STATE
CONSTITUTION JUST GO TO ARTICLE
NINE. AND IN THERE IT SAYS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS TO PROVIDE A FREE
AND COMMON EDUCATION FOR ALL
CHILDREN OF THE STATE. WHAT IS
NOT SAYING THERE IS THAT THAT
SHOULD BE HOUSED IN A GOVERNMENT
BUILDING OR PROVIDED BY A
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM. IT JUST SAYS
THAT WE SHOULD FUND A COMMON
EDUCATION THAT'S BECOME
INTERPRETED TO BE THAT OF JUST
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS. BUT
WE WOULD ARGUE THAT PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ARE INDEED PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
AND SO WE LOOK AT THESE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTS. THERE
ARE OTHER, OPTIONS, AS HAS BEEN
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND I
APPRECIATE THIS CLARIFICATION.
THIS IS NOT A VOUCHER PROGRAM.
IT'S A IT'S A SAVINGS ACCOUNT OF
SORTS WHICH ALLOWS FOR THE MONEY
TO GO INTO A PRIVATE ACCOUNT
THAT IS SEGREGATED FROM SCHOOLS.
IT DOESN'T GO DIRECTLY TO THE
SCHOOLS. AND ALLOWS FOR A PARENT
TO REGULATE THAT MONEY AS WELL
AS THE GOVERNMENT HAVE SOME
OVERSIGHT. CALIFORNIA'S ON
LITERACY CRISIS. WE HAVE 1.7
MILLION PUPILS IN IN OUR GRADES
ONE THROUGH THREE, MANY OF THEM
WHO ARE FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES
. AND OUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE NOT BEEN,
NOT COME TO BEAR. WE WOULD JUST
ASK FOR PARENTS TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND AS YOU THINK
SERIOUSLY ABOUT THE BUDGET
SITUATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, YOU HAVE 100
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO DEAL WITH. THIS COULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHAVE SOME OF THE
COSTS OFF OF YOUR CHALLENGES. AS
OF THIS MONTH, 18 STATES HAVE
PASSED SIMILAR BILLS, AND WE
THINK THAT THAT CALIFORNIA COULD
BE THE 19TH OR 20TH, DEPENDING
ON HOW FAST YOU ACT. PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
THE BEST EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEIR KIDS, REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE. AND THAT'S WHY
WE SUPPORT SB 103. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION, YOUR
POSITION IN CHAIR? SAAMER PALKO,
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION,
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE,
AND FULL SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR GROVE, TOM
SHEEHY HERE ON BEHALF OF
PROTECTION OF THE EDUCATIONAL
RIGHTS OF KIDS, ADVOCACY HERE IN
SUPPORT TODAY FOR SB 1203. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE,
GREG BURT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR. BURT.
NEXT PLEASE. RICHARD MAHER WITH
AMERICA FIRST POLICY INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU, AND LET'S NOW HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE
OPPOSITION HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE, MR.
CHRISTENSEN, DOCTOR HAGAN, IF
YOU JUST MOVE OVER ONE SEAT, YOU
CAN YOU CAN STAY. JUST MOVE OVER
ONE SEAT, MAKE ROOM. NO, DON'T
THINK IT'S WEIRD, WHY DON'T YOU
MOVE THAT WAY? SO WE KEEP
EVERYBODY SEPARATE. WE DON'T. WE
DON'T. WE LIKE NOT TO
INTERMINGLE OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT. IT CAN GET UGLY, ALL
RIGHT, THERE YOU GO, WELCOME.
GOT SHARP ELBOWS. ALL RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING, KATIE HARDIMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. OAN, K¾T IS
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB 1203,
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW PROP 98
FUNDING INTENDED, INTENDED FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION TO BE USED FOR
PRIVATE SCHOOL VOUCHERS,
INCLUDING RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS. CTA
OPPOSES THIS EFFORT FOR MANY
REASONS. I WILL HIGHLIGHT A FEW.
FIRST, THE BILL SIMPLY
UNDERMINES PUBLIC SCHOOLS BY
DIVERTING DESPERATELY NEEDED
RESOURCES AWAY FROM OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM. PRIVATE SCHOOL
VOUCHERS ARE PARTICULARLY
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS, SUCH AS
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES,
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS, LOW
INCOME STUDENTS, LGBT STUDENTS,
AND OTHERS. AS THESE STUDENTS
CAN BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE ACCEPTED
OR TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD A
PRIVATE SCHOOL EVEN WITH A
VOUCHER. THEREFORE, THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT OFFER REAL
CHOICE FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. ALSO, I'LL NOTE THE
BILL HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THE STATE BUDGET. THE LAO
ESTIMATED A SIMILAR INITIATIVE
WOULD COST ABOUT 4 TO $6
BILLION, JUST TO FUND EXISTING
PRIVATE SCHOOL STUDENTS, THIS
WOULD EITHER COME FROM EXISTING
PROP 98 RESOURCES OR FROM THE
GENERAL FUND SIDE OF THE BUDGET,
DEPENDING ON SORT OF WHAT TESTS
WE'RE IN. AND PROP 98, SO CTA
BELIEVES THE STATE SHOULD FULLY
FUND OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
OPPOSES ANY SYSTEM THAT WOULD
ALLOCATE PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS TO
NONPUBLIC AGENCIES. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE,
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. CÁC MANCINI HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, CSEA HAS
LONG OPPOSED EFFORTS LIKE THIS
ONE TO ESTABLISH PRIVATE SCHOOL
VOUCHERS AND DIVERT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AWAY FROM OUR
DEMOCRATICALLY GOVERNED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS LIKE K¾T. WE HAVE
NUMEROUS ISSUES WITH THIS BILL,
BUT I'LL STICK TO THE
HIGHLIGHTS. THE LEGISLATURE OVER
THE DECADES HAS PASSED HUNDREDS
OF LAWS TO SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES, TO ENSURE THAT
HUNGRY STUDENTS ARE FED, AND TO
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
DISCRIMINATION. PASSING THIS
BILL WOULD MEAN PROVIDING PUBLIC
FUNDING TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT
DO NOT NEED TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAWS YOU'VE PASSED, FOR EXAMPLE,
TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL FREE SCHOOL
MEALS TO STUDENTS OR FREE
TRANSPORTATION TRANSPORTATION TO
FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH. IN
MANY CASES, THIS WOULD MEAN
FUNDING SCHOOLS THAT TEACH
RELIGION USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
WE'D ALSO NOTE THAT IN ONE STATE
THAT RECENTLY IMPLEMENTED A
PRIVATE SCHOOL VOUCHER PROGRAM
IN ARIZONA, MORE THAN 75% OF
INITIAL VOUCHER APPLICANTS HAD
NEVER BEEN ENROLLED IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, ESPECIALLY NOW AS
CALIFORNIA FACES A BUDGET
DEFICIT. SUBSIDIZING PRIVATE
SCHOOL TUITION FOR WEALTHY
FAMILIES SHOULD NOT BE ON THE
TABLE. THIS BILL WILL TAKE
BILLIONS AWAY FROM PUBLIC
EDUCATION, LEAVING THE MOST
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS BEHIND IN
UNDERFUNDED CLASSROOMS. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS, AND MANY MORE, WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE. THANK
YOU. OTHERS WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE. TIFFANY
MOCK, ON BEHALF OF CFT, A UNION
OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS, WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, YVONNE FERNANDEZ,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, OKAY.
SEEING NO MORE OPPOSITION, LET'S
COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
CONCERNS. ÓRDENES. SENATOR
SHOBERG, IN ORDER TO CARRY ON
THE CONVERSATION, I BELIEVE YOU
CARRIED THIS BILL LAST YEAR AND
THE YEAR BEFORE AND THE YEAR
BEFORE. I THINK WHAT I WAS
MISSING TODAY, FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL, NO OFFENSE TO
OUR GENTLEMAN HERE TODAY, BUT IT
WAS THE, THE MOM THAT SPOKE ON
BEHALF OF HER CHILDREN, THE
BLACK PARENTS UNION. IT'S HER
CHILD THAT'S SEVERELY AUTISTIC.
THAT WAS JUST WASTING AWAY IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND SHE
GOT A SECOND JOB IN ORDER TO
GIVE HIM CODING. AND NOW HE'S
WORKING ON SOME OF THE MOST HIGH
TECH COMPUTERS. HE'S NONVERBAL.
HE DOESN'T, HE DOESN'T THINK
LIKE WE THINK, BUT HE HAS THE
ABILITY TO DO THINGS THAT OUR
BRAINS CAN'T DO, AND IT GIVES
HIM UPWARD THAT TRAINING THAT
SHE PAID EXTRA FOR, ALLOWED THE
STUDENT TO DO THAT AND BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED, AFTER HE GOT
THAT EDUCATION. SO, YOU HAVE A
YOUNG BLACK BOY THAT WAS IN A
LOW PERFORMING LOS ANGELES
SCHOOL DISTRICT, AND NOW THIS
YOUNG MAN IS MAKING PROBABLY
MORE MONEY THAN ALL OF US,
BECAUSE HIS MOM TOOK ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MAKING EXTRA
MONEY TO PAY FOR THAT. WHEN PROP
98 MONIES. I AGREE WITH MR.
CHRISTENSEN, YOU'RE GUARANTEED A
FREE PUBLIC EDUCATION. IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO HAPPEN IN A
PUBLIC BUILDING OR BY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. AND THIS IS JUST AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LET MORE CHILDREN
LIKE THAT. WE HAVE RAN THIS BILL
FOR THREE YEARS. WE TRIED TO
FOCUS ON JUST THOSE STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS, AND THEN WE
TRIED TO FOCUS ON WE TRIED TO
NARROW THE BILL AND TAKE
AMENDMENTS. I MEAN, I'M A
CHAMPION FOR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
CHOICES SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE
UPWARD MOBILITY. BUT IN ORDER TO
MAKE, CONCESSIONS, I GUESS YOU
WOULD SAY, CAN WE DO A PILOT
PROGRAM WITH THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS AND SEE IF
THAT WORKS, AND JUST SHOW YOU
HOW IT WOULD CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES, ESPECIALLY IN THESE BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY'RE JUST TRAPPED IN AS
UNDERPERFORMING SCHOOLS BY THEIR
ZIP CODE THAT BILL FAILED. WE
BROUGHT IT BACK. WE BROUGHT YOU
EXAMPLES ON DISABILITY OR
SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS THAT ARE
THRIVING BECAUSE OF THE OUTSIDE
EDUCATION THAT THEY DID. BUT
LIKE THIS YOUNG LADY, CHLOE,
THAT I TALKED TO YOU ABOUT
EARLIER WITH THE SHE'S SEVERE
DOWN OR MID LEVEL TO HIGH SEVERE
DOWN SYNDROME. SHE'S A GLOWING
ARTIST. NOW SOME OF HER PIECES
GO FOR 35 AND $40,000, AND SHE'S
STILL JUST AN 18 YEAR OLD. SHE'S
IN DANCE AND SHE DOES CHEER AND
SHE THRIVES. AND SHE STARTED HER
OWN INSTAGRAM PAGE. SHE WANTS TO
BE AN INFLUENCER AND SHE'S CHLOE
OF BAKERSFIELD AND SHE IS JUST
THRIVING. WHERE BEFORE SHE
WASN'T OUT AND HER PARENTS
SCRAPED TOGETHER $9,000 A YEAR
SO THAT SHE CAN CONTINUE THIS
EDUCATION THAT SHE'S BEEN
GETTING FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
AT A PRIVATE, IT'S A HYBRID HIGH
SCHOOL. IT'S A TWO DAYS
EDUCATION, TWO DAYS AT HOME.
IT'S A HYBRID HIGH SCHOOL. BUT
THEY HAVE SPORTS PROGRAMS AND
OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL. I THINK
WE'RE FAILING OUR STUDENTS. I
REALLY, REALLY DO. AND AS I'M
ONLY HERE FOR TWO MORE YEARS, SO
THE OPPOSITION IS GOING TO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH ME BECAUSE I THINK
WE NEED TO GIVE STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY. I MEAN, I'D START
ANYWHERE. YOU GUYS WOULD GIVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO START. YOU
PICK THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SCHOOL. WE ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN
TO THOSE STUDENTS AND LET
PARENTS MAKE DECISIONS AND JUST
WATCH THE CHANGE AND WATCH THESE
KIDS THRIVE. AND THEY ARE THE
NEXT GENERATION THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT OUR LIFE.
AND I THINK THEY NEED EVERY
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCCESS. AND
AGAIN, THE WAY WE'VE INTERPRETED
THIS, THE CONSTITUTION IS IT HAS
TO BE A PUBLIC SCHOOL. WELL,
THERE ARE A LOT OF PRIVATE, A
LOT OF ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND THE
RESOURCES SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THE PARENTS. SO YES, I HAVE
INTRODUCED IT. PLAN TO BRING IT
BACK NEXT YEAR AND THE YEAR
AFTER. AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
SOMEPLACE, TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
. SO TWO QUESTIONS, MR. CHAIR,
TO THE TO THE WITNESSES. SO I
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO, TO OUR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ON
HERE. HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO
PARENTS WHOSE CURRENT PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING FOR
THEM IN THEIR CURRENT, IN THEIR
CURRENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY ZIP
CODE OR WHATEVER MAY BE
GEOGRAPHICALLY. BUT THIS WOULD
EMPOWER THOSE PARENTS TO HAVE
OPTIONS AND CHOICES, BECAUSE I
KNOW, I KNOW, AS A FORMER
TEACHER AND A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER, NOT EVERY SCHOOL HAS THE
CAPACITY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
EVERY CHILD. WE DON'T HAVE EVERY
EVERY PROGRAM AVAILABLE. WE
DON'T HAVE SPECIALIZED TEACHERS
IN THOSE AREAS. SO HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF THOSE
PARTICULAR PARENTS AND FAMILIES
WHOSE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING? UNDERSTANDING THAT,
WHAT DO THEY HAVE? WHAT OPTIONS
AND RESOURCES SHOULD THEY HAVE
IF THIS IS NOT THE CASE, AND
WOULD YOU BE MORE COMFORTABLE IF
THEY ACTUALLY NARROWED IT DOWN
TO A CERTAIN NUMBER OF GRAPHICS
THAT WEREN'T EXCELLING, OR IF
THIS BILL WAS NARROWED TO ONLY
PUBLIC, PRIVATE SCHOOLS? SURE.
OR YES. SO I GUESS I WOULD SAY
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS,
THERE ARE SOME PUBLIC SCHOOL
CHOICE OPTIONS LIKE CHARTER
SCHOOLS, OPEN ENROLLMENT, THINGS
LIKE THAT, I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, IF A SCHOOL IS NOT
PERFORMING AND STUDENTS ARE NOT
ARE STRUGGLING, WE SHOULD BE
LIFTING UP ALL OF THE STUDENTS
IN THAT DISTRICT AND IN THAT
SCHOOL, SO THE STATE SHOULD
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO,
TO HELP ALL OF THOSE STUDENTS, I
THINK IN RELATED TO, YOU KNOW, A
PILOT PROGRAM OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, I THINK THERE ARE MAJOR
CONSTITUTE ISSUES WITH THIS THAT
WOULD HAVE TO GO TO VOTERS, AND
SO, YOU KNOW, EVEN TO DO A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HAVE TO GO TO
THE VOTERS TO DECIDE THAT AND
MAKE MAJOR CHANGES TO OUR
CONSTITUTION. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
SEPARATION OF CHURCH AND STATE,
THE PROPOSITION 98 GOES TO
CURRENTLY GOES TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND IS COUNTED, THE ADA OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND I
ALLOW MR. CHRISTIANSEN TO
RESPOND TO THAT AS WELL, BECAUSE
HE STUDIED THE CONSTITUTION ON
WHAT IS THAT OKAY THROUGH THE
CHAIR OR NOT? YEAH. BRIEFLY,
PLEASE. I JUST KNOW THAT
ACTUALLY SUPREME COURT HAS
TALKED ABOUT THIS TWICE AND SAID
THAT THERE IS NO ISSUE THERE FOR
PUBLIC MONEYS TO GO TO RELIGIOUS
PLACES IF THERE'S NOT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. AND SO THIS WOULD
SIMPLY THE BLAINE AMENDMENTS IS
WHAT SHE'S REFERRING TO, WHICH
IS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. BEALL, AND SO
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE NO
PROBLEMS. YES. IT WOULD HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE VOTERS. SO LET'S
GIVE THE VOTERS A CHOICE. LET'S
LET THAT LET'S LET THEM HAVE THE
DECISION. AND MAKE THE DECISION
ON WHETHER THEY THINK THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS WORKING FOR
THEIR KIDS OR NOT. BUT THIS
BILL, THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE CONSTITUTION OR THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSITION. NO,
THERE WOULD HAVE LET ME MAKE
CLEAR. THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE
SOME CONSTITUTIONAL CHANGES TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR PROP 98 ISSUES,
AND IT ACTUALLY REMOVES THE OLD
AND DEAD BLAINE AMENDMENTS FROM
THE CONSTITUTION. BUT NO, IT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES. THERE IS A CORRESPONDING
SCA THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE PASSED
IN ORDER FOR THIS BILL. IS
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT. YOU
HAD ANOTHER QUESTION. SO JUST
JUST FOLLOWING UP ON THAT. SO
THIS WOULD THIS BE CONSIDERED AS
JUST, I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO PASS. SORRY, BUT, BUT IN THE
CASE OF IF THIS WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD, THERE WOULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL IT WOULD IT, WOULD IT
BE LIKE A BILL OR THERE'S A
COMPANION MEASURE, SCA NINE.
IT'S AN SCA WHICH WE ARE NOT
HEARING TODAY. OKAY. SO I'VE,
I'VE COVERED THAT IN ANOTHER
BILL. IT'S A SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. SO I
EXCUSE ME SCA SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. AND I
HAVE THAT BILL. IT'S NOT BEING
HEARD TODAY. IT'S BEING HEARD
ANOTHER DAY. AND THEY GO
TOGETHER. THEY GO TOGETHER. SO
WE DID COVER THAT AND THINK
ABOUT THAT. AND THERE IS A
DIFFERENT SCHEDULE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS. SO
THE NOT LATER THAN DATE IS JUNE
26TH, I BELIEVE. AND WE MAY OR
MAY NOT HEAR THAT IT'S IN RULES
RIGHT NOW. SO JUST, ONCE AGAIN,
I, I KNEW THE BILL WAS NOT GOING
TO PASS LAST YEAR. I KNOW IT'S
NOT PROBABLY NOT GOING TO PASS
THIS YEAR. AND APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT, BUT I WANT TO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
DO THAT TESTIMONY THAT I HEARD
LAST YEAR FROM THAT MOM WHO I
HAPPEN TO SEE QUITE A BIT ON THE
AIRPLANE GOING BACK AND FORTH ON
THERE. SHE'S PASSIONATE. SHE
SEES ME EVERY TIME SHE GIVES ME
A BIG HUG, YOU KNOW, FOR
SUPPORTING HER, I'M GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD AND MOVE THE BILL
TODAY, AND I'M GOING TO MY VOTE
TODAY IS FOR HER. THANK YOU FOR
HER, WHICH I WISH SHE WOULD HAVE
BEEN HERE BECAUSE SHE DID. NO
OFFENSE TO THE CURRENT
WITNESSES, BUT SHE DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB IN ADVOCATING FOR
HER CHILD. AND I KNOW THAT SHE
REPRESENTS MANY, MANY OTHER
PARENTS IN THE SAME POSITION
THAT SHE IS. SO I WILL BE HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL. I KNOW YOU
FOLKS YOU KNOW, ARE NOT GOING TO
BE THREATENED HERE TODAY BY THIS
VOTE, BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO REPRESENT ALL VOICES IN
EDUCATION, ALL PARENTS. SHE'S
MOBILIZING BLACK PARENTS ALL
ACROSS THIS STATE THAT ARE
HAVING TROUBLES WITH THEIR
CHILDREN BEING WAREHOUSED IN
THESE NON, NON PERFORMING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND LOW SOCIOECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY'RE JOINING THAT GROUP
BECAUSE SHE'S A FORCE TO BE
RECKONED WITH. AND IT MAY NOT
HAPPEN TODAY. IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR BEFORE.
BUT IT WILL HAPPEN BECAUSE
PARENTS RECOGNIZE THAT THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION, THE
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS FAILING OUR STUDENTS.
AND WE ARE IN BIG TROUBLE. AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT, I CAN TELL
YOU THAT SHE IS GOING TO BE A
FORCE TO BE RECKONED WITH. MY
HEART BLEEDS FOR THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE STILL TRAPPED IN THAT
SITUATION, WITH NO ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO HAVE THE UPWARD MOBILITY THE
ONES THAT WILL GET PASSED OVER
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
KIDS, THE KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS THAT DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS
, OR PARENTS DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THESE ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
ALLOW CODING AND ALLOW, YOU KNOW
, THEIR, THEIR INNER GOLD OR
THEIR INSIDE OF THEM AND WHO
THEY REALLY ARE TO DEVELOP AND
TO ACHIEVE GREATNESS IN, IN THAT
CAPACITY, AND PARENTS DON'T HAVE
THAT CHOICE. SO I THINK IT'LL
TAKE A FEW YEARS. BUT I THINK
EVENTUALLY THE LAME ARGUMENT
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED BY THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT DOLLARS, I
MEAN, WE ALREADY GET $1,000 MORE
PER STUDENT THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
RESOURCE. IT'S ABOUT DEEP. IT'S
ABOUT PUTTING THE STUDENTS
FIRST. SO SHE IS A FORCE TO BE
RECKONED WITH. AND SHE WILL BE
BACK. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
LOOK FORWARD TO HER HUGS MOVING
FORWARD AND MY TRIPS THROUGH THE
AIRPORT. SO WITH THAT I MOVE THE
BILL. I AM CLEARLY NOT TAKING
THE RIGHT FLIGHTS. NOBODY EVER
HUGS ME ON IT. I CAN MAKE THAT
ARRANGEMENT FOR YOU SIR.
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT. SO
MAYBE, SO YOU KNOW, I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY, MR.
CHRISTENSEN. YOU KNOW, ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE YOU. AND SO, AS
NOTED, THIS BILL AND ITS
ACCOMPANYING SCA WOULD CREATE A
PRIVATE SCHOOL VOUCHER OR
SIMILAR PROGRAM. WE CAN ARGUE
ABOUT THE TERMINOLOGY, BUT BUT
AS NOTED, YOU KNOW, THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN PUT BEFORE THE VOTERS
IN CALIFORNIA SEVERAL TIMES
BEFORE IT'S BEEN REJECTED. IN
2000, THERE WAS A PROPOSITION
PROP 3038 ON THE BALLOT, AND IT
FAILED WITH OVER 70% OPPOSED.
TIMES CHANGE. BUT LAST YEAR,
THIS COMMITTEE HEARD A SIMILAR
BILL, YOU KNOW, FROM SENATOR
GROVE AND SENATOR GROVE, I
DEEPLY ADMIRE YOU. YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE, AND I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AND IT
COMES FROM A WONDERFUL PLACE, IN
LAST YEAR'S, YOU KNOW, MEASURE
TWO, SB TWO, 92, SCA FIVE, THEY
WERE SIMILAR MEASURES, BOTH
FAILED, AND SO THE VOTERS AND
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES, MYSELF
INCLUDED, HAVE REAL CONCERNS
THAT THE WITNESSES FOR THE
OPPOSITION HAVE TOUCHED ON ABOUT
ABOUT THE PROSPECTIVE,
DESTABILIZING IMPACT OF
REDIRECTING PUBLIC MONIES TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND THE IMPACT
IT WOULD HAVE ON OUR BROADER
STATEWIDE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
DO THAT. AND, YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA ALREADY TO THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT, OFFERS A
HOST OF VERY DIVERSE PUBLIC
SCHOOL ALTERNATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES, CHARTER SCHOOLS,
MAGNET SCHOOLS AND A PROGRAM
THAT I HAVE LEGISLATION TO
EXTEND THE DISTRICT OF CHOICE
PROGRAM, WHICH WHICH ALLOWS
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES TO MAKE
CHOICES WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
PUBLIC EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
AND I WILL NOTE THAT, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE MANY INSTANCES OF
STUDENTS BEING FAILED BY THE
CURRENT SYSTEM. AND I THINK OUR
IMPERATIVE HERE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN. YOU
KNOW, THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO WE
DO THAT? I'LL POINT OUT, I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, TO THIS STORY, WHICH
IS VERY MOVING. YOU KNOW, THERE
ARE LIKELY I MEAN, SURELY THERE
ARE OTHER WONDERFUL EXAMPLES OF
STUDENTS BEING HELPED SAVED,
MENTORED IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS, IN
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS, IN OTHER
SITUATIONS. SO, YOU KNOW, LET'S
NOTE THAT, AND SO I'D SAY
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THESE
INITIATIVES, YOU KNOW, LET'S
FOCUS AS IS MY INTENTION ON
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION ACROSS THE BOARD IN
CALIFORNIA TO ELIMINATE THOSE
SAD STORIES. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, DESPITE MY ADMIRATION
FOR YOUR EFFORT, AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE SUPPORTING
WITNESSES. I'M GOING TO OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE TODAY, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? ABSOLUTELY SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS,
AGAIN, WE'LL BE BACK NEXT YEAR.
IT'S PUBLIC MONEY. PUBLIC MONEY
MEANS PAID FOR BY TAXPAYERS.
IT'S PUBLIC MONEY. AND IT'S JUST
AS MUCH, APPEARANCE MONEY,
THAT'S IN A LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE, BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITY WHERE THEIR KID IS
FAILING. IT'S THEIR MONEY, TOO.
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO USE IT. HOW THEY SO CHOOSE TO
BEST PROVIDE THE ADVANCEMENTS
FOR THEIR CHILD. AND OR IT'S
PUBLIC MONEY THAT BELONGS TO A
PARENT WITH A KID WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS, AND THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THAT STUDENT AND THEIR CHILD
WITH THE BEST EDUCATION THAT
THEY CAN GET, AND SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU, WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR CHO, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FINAL ITEM FOR SB 1203.
GROVE MOTION IS DUE. PASSED THE
SENATE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NØ NEWMAN NØ
OCHOA. BOGH I OKOBOJI. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ NÓ. GLASER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. THAT
MEASURE HAS ONE VOTE FOR TWO
AGAINST. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATOR ASHBY IS HERE.
WELCOME SENATOR ASHBY, YOU WILL
BE PRESENTING SB 1477. AND YOU
HAVE A WITNESS. WELCOME TO YOUR
WITNESS. WITNESSES. PLURAL
PROCEED WHEN READY. HELLO
CHAIRPERSON. NEWMAN. HOW ARE
YOU? SO GOOD. I'M GOOD. THIS IS
NORMALLY PART OF THE BACK AND
FORTH, BUT. OKAY. GREAT. GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, THEN WE'LL JUST
MOVE FORWARD A LITTLE DOWN IN
HERE. SO, YOU KNOW, THANKS FOR
BRINGING THAT POSITIVE ENERGY.
LIFT IT UP A LITTLE BIT. COME
ON. IT'S ED COMMITTEE. THIS IS
ALL FUN STUFF I AM HERE TO
PRESENT TO YOU SB 1477, WHICH
BROADENS OVERSIGHT FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO PREVENT FRAUD,
IMPROVE CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNANCE AND TRANSPARENCY, AND
HOLD BAD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE. A
RECENT JOINT REPORT FROM THE
LEDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THE
FISCAL CRISIS MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM IDENTIFIED
CONCERNS WITH THE LACK OF
NON-CLASS ROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL OVERSIGHT. MANY OF THOSE
CONCERNS CENTER ON ACCUSATIONS
OF FRAUD AND MISUSE OF FUNDS.
THESE ISSUES RAISE CONCERNS
REGARDING CONCENTRATED POWER AND
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST,
ESPECIALLY WHEN A SINGLE ENTITY
OR INDIVIDUAL HOLDS UNDUE
INFLUENCE OVER A CHARTER
SCHOOL'S BOARD. DODD SB 1477
IMPLEMENTS A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT LAW.
REPORT. STRENGTHENING AUDITING,
CONTRACTING, AND ENROLLMENT
POLICIES FOR ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THE BILL IMPROVES
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHILE ALSO
ENSURING BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY.
SEVERAL COMPONENTS OF THE BILL
HAVE BEEN SUBJECTS OF DISCUSSION
WITH VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY. MY STAFF
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH ALL SIDES AND FIND PATHWAYS
FORWARD WITH ME TODAY. ARE JOHN
MCCLURE, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LIBERTY CHARTER SCHOOL AND KIRK
KIMBALL, CHAU. ON BEHALF OF REAL
JOURNEY ACADEMIES AND VISIONS IN
EDUCATION. AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. SHIMIZU. I SEE YOU'RE GOING
FOR THE MIC. YOU'RE FIRST.
SOUNDS GREAT. YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, KIRK
KIMBALL QUÊ. AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED, ON BEHALF OF TWO OF
THE CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL,
REAL JOURNEY ACADEMIES AND
VISIONS IN EDUCATION, REAL
JOURNEY ACADEMIES IS A NETWORK
OF FIVE SCHOOLS IN SAN
BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES SERVING APPROXIMATELY
2400 STUDENTS. AND VISIONS
SERVES MORE THAN 7000 STUDENTS
IN SACRAMENTO. CONTRA COSTA,
YOLO, PLACER, EL DORADO, AMADOR,
SAN JOAQUIN, SOLANO, AND SUTTER
COUNTIES. IN RECENT YEARS, THE
CHARTER SCHOOL SECTOR HAS FACED
CHALLENGES RELATED TO FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT AND EDUCATION
PRACTICES, AND WHILE THESE
INCIDENTS WERE THE ACTIONS OF
ONLY A FEW, THEY UNDERSCORED THE
NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
JUST LIKE SB 1477, WHICH AIMS TO
STRENGTHEN AUDITING STANDARDS
AND ENSURE EDUCATION ACTIVITIES
MEET SAFETY, VALUE AND COST
STANDARDS. THE MAJORITY OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE DEDICATED TO
PROVIDING QUALITY EDUCATION WITH
INTEGRITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY. SB
1477 IS A THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE TO
A CLEAR NEED FOR IMPROVED
ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AUDITING PROCESS
BY REFINING AUDITING STANDARDS
AND ENSURING THAT EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES MEET COMMON SENSE
STANDARDS OF SAFETY. EDUCATIONAL
VALUE AND COST REASONABLENESS.
SB 1477 AIMS TO SAFEGUARD THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM. AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED, THE LEGISLATURE'S
ATTENTION TO THESE MATTERS,
PROMPTED BY COMPREHENSIVE
REPORTS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THE
ANTI-FRAUD TASK FORCE,
UNDERSCORES THE URGENCY AND THE
BIPARTISAN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED FOR REFORM. WHILE SB 1477
DOES NOT ADDRESS ALL THE ISSUES
IN THOSE REPORTS, IT IS A
MEANINGFUL AND MEASURED AND
RESPONSIBLE PROPOSAL THAT WILL
IMPROVE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY AND BE A
CRITICAL DETERRENT TO POTENTIAL
BAD ACTORS. THE PATH LAID OUT BY
SB 1477 IS ONE OF CONSTRUCTIVE
REFORM, AIMED AT ENHANCING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITHOUT STIFLING THEIR
ABILITY TO INNOVATE AND EDUCATE.
BY SUPPORTING SB 1477, WE AFFIRM
OUR SHARED COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATION THAT IS BOTH
INNOVATIVE AND ACCOUNTABLE, AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
MR. MCCLURE. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JOHN MCCLURE
. I'VE BEEN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LIBERTY CHARTER
SCHOOL IN MADERA SINCE 2020. I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP. OUR
SCHOOL IS A SITE BASED CHARTER
WHICH WAS FORMERLY KNOWN AS
EZEKIEL TAFOYA. ALVARADO ACADEMY
WAS THE SUBJECT OF A FCMAT
REPORT RELEASED LAST YEAR. THE
REPORT REVEALED MORE THAN 1
MILLION IN FUNDS APPEARED TO
HAVE BEEN USED FOR QUESTIONABLE
PURPOSES DURING THE 2019, 2016
TO 2019 YEARS. THIS INCLUDED,
BUT NOT LIMITED TO, THE HIRING
OF A HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE
INDIVIDUAL AS A LIFE COACH FOR
EIGHTH GRADE STUDENTS, MULTIPLE
FORD RAPTOR TRUCK PURCHASES, AND
TUITION FOR A CHILD OF THE
FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. THIS
AUDIT, DONE BY THE FCMAT TEAM
TOOK OVER TWO YEARS TO COMPLETE.
IRONICALLY, DURING THE SAME
PERIOD OF TIME THAT FCMAT
AUDITED FOR ALL OUR INDEPENDENT
FINANCIAL AUDITS CONDUCTED BY
AUDITORS ON THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S APPROVED LIST CAME
BACK CLEAN. THE AUDITING PROCESS
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS IS BROKEN.
HOW CAN A VOLUNTEER BOARD HOLD
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FINANCIAL IRREGULARITIES? IF AN
INDEPENDENT AUDITOR DOES NOT
RAISE ISSUES OF CONCERN? SINCE I
TOOK OVER, OUR BOARD HAS
INSTITUTED NEW FISCAL POLICIES
TO ENSURE THIS WILL NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN AT OUR SCHOOL. BUT THAT IS
NOT ENOUGH. BEFORE AND AFTER OUR
SCHOOL EXPERIENCED ISSUES, THERE
HAVE BEEN A LONG LINE OF FISCAL
FRAUD PROBLEMS IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS, INCLUDING A $400
MILLION CASE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
. IT IS OUTRAGEOUS THAT MORE
THAN $400 MILLION COULD BE TAKEN
FROM THE STATE, AND YET THE
STATE STILL HAS DONE NOTHING TO
IMPROVE AUDITS FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THIS BILL IS A
SIGNIFICANT AND THOUGHTFUL FIRST
STEP TOWARD TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND WE WELCOME
IT AND COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SUPPORTERS TO
MAKE IT EVEN STRONGER AS IT GOES
THROUGH THE PROCESS. THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING TO OUR STORY AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? PLEASE
COME FORWARD, ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE A TWEENER, MR. BRAMBLE.
TWEENERS GO LAST. GO AHEAD. YOU
YOU OKAY? YOU WANT TO COME TO
THE TABLE? YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES, SIR. MR. CHAIR,
SENATOR, SETH BRAMBLE FOR CTA.
WE DO HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS APPROACH, IF
CALIFORNIA PASSES AN INCOMPLETE
SET OF REFORMS TO NON-CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL LAW, THERE
WILL BE EFFORTS TO LIFT THE
MORATORIUM ESTABLISHED VIA OUR
2019 BILL, AB 1505. THIS
MORATORIUM PREVENTS ANY NEW
NON-CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS FROM BEING ESTABLISHED.
UNTIL WE FIX WHAT'S BROKEN IN
THE LAW, AND THE MORATORIUM
EXPIRES IN JANUARY OF 2026,
WHILE THE MORE TIME IS IN
EFFECT, THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
RADICALLY REDEFINE WHAT A
NON-CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL IS, CHANGING THE NAME OF
AN ENTIRE INSTRUCTIONAL MODEL.
AS I'VE SAID IN THE PAST, WHILE
THERE IS A MORATORIUM CURRENTLY
IN PLACE IS AN ATTEMPT TO AVOID
NOTORIETY LIKE SWITCHING CARS TO
AVOID BEING FOLLOWED. TWO
SERIOUS CONCERNS. FIRST,
RESEARCH HAS CONSISTENTLY SHOWN
VERY POOR STUDENT OUTCOMES AT
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE 100%
VIRTUAL. WE REPRESENT A LARGE
LOCAL CHAPTER OF EDUCATORS IN A
VIRTUAL CHARTER SCHOOL WHO HAVE
BEEN ORGANIZING AN EFFORTS TO
GET THE SCHOOL TO INVEST IN
STUDENTS AND TEACHING, RATHER
THAN SENDING BIG BAGS OF MONEY
TO A FOR PROFIT COMPANY IN
ANOTHER STATE. SECOND, STOPPING
FRAUD IN A LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THERE IS NOT A BRICK AND
MORTAR SCHOOL THAT YOU CAN WALK
INTO AND SEE TEACHERS TEACHING
AND SEE STUDENTS LEARNING WHERE
MUCH OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY IS
BASED ON EASILY MANIPULATED
PAPERWORK AND COMPUTER FILES,
HAS BEEN INEFFECTIVE AS PART OF
THE BUDGET. LAST YEAR, THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED AN EFFORT TO DEVELOP
SOME THIRD PARTY RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT HOW TO FIX WHAT'S BROKEN.
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THIS LÀ Ó
REPORT. IF WE WANT TO GET
SERIOUS ABOUT IMPROVING THIS
AREA OF LAW, WE SHOULD START
WITH THIS KIND OF COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH IS PROBABLY I DON'T
KNOW, 15 TO 20 RECOMMENDATIONS
IN HERE. THIS ONE IS LIKE MAYBE
ONE OF THEM. THE ELEMENTS OF
SENATE BILL 1477 DON'T EVEN
SCRATCH THE SURFACE. THIS BILL
WILL NOT PREVENT ANOTHER A3
SCANDAL, WHICH IS DETAILED IN
THE ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF THE
DETAILS THERE. BUT DO PLEASE
TAKE THESE CONCERNS INTO
CONSIDERATION AS YOU CONSIDER
THE BILL. APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY, LET'S COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, TO MR. BRAMBLE'S
CONCERN, WHICH I THINK IS
LEGITIMATE ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
PROSPECTIVE IMPACT OF THE
MORATORIUM. THAT'S THAT'S NOT
YOUR GOAL, RIGHT? NO, THIS BILL
DOESN'T TOUCH THE MORATORIUM.
MORATORIUM STILL IN PLACE FOR A
FEW MORE YEARS. SO WE'RE, WE
DIDN'T TREAD INTO THOSE WATERS.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY BASED ON THE LAO
REPORT AND THE FISCAL TEAMS
REPORT. PUT SOME PARAMETERS IN
PLACE TO DEAL WITH THE BAD
ACTORS IN THE CHARTER UNIVERSE
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. ALL RIGHT.
AND ONE CONCERN, I THINK,
RELATES TO HOW AN AUDITOR IS
SELECTED. AND SO THERE IS SOME
CONCERN THAT IF A SCHOOL CAN
PICK ITS OWN AUDITOR THAT
DOESN'T TEND TO WORK, GO AHEAD
AND RESPOND TO THE RELATIONSHIP.
I JUST WANTED TO RESPOND TO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
MORATORIUM. I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A REDEFINITION. IF I'M
READING THE ANALYSIS CORRECTLY,
ON WHAT A NON-CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL IS AND THE
MORATORIUM IS ABOUT
NON-CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW, A CHARTER
SCHOOL MUST BE AT LEAST 80%
IN-PERSON OR THERE, OR THEY ARE
CONSIDERED A NON-CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL. THERE'S A POLICY
PREFERENCE IN THE LAW FOR
IN-PERSON INSTRUCTION. AND THIS
COULD LOOK A COUPLE DIFFERENT
WAYS. MAYBE KIDS GO TO SCHOOL ON
A MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY OR
MAYBE 4 TO 5 PERIODS EVERY DAY.
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL THIS BILL
PROPOSES THAT A CHARTER SCHOOL
MUST BE AT LEAST 20% IN-PERSON,
OR THEY'RE CONSIDERED A
NON-CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL. SO IF THERE'S A FIVE
HOUR SCHOOL DAY, A STUDENT
REALLY NEEDS TO ONLY COME FOR
ONE HOUR A DAY. STATED A
DIFFERENT WAY A STUDENT COULD
COME INTO CLASSROOM ON THURSDAYS
AND THURSDAYS ONLY. AND UNDER
THIS BILL, THEY WOULDN'T BE
CONSIDERED A NON-CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL. THERE ARE
SERIOUS CONCERNS HERE. OUR
RESPONSE SHOULD BE COMPREHENSIVE
AND IN BROAD STROKES, STUDENTS
ARE NOT DOING WELL. INSTANCES OF
FRAUD AND ABUSE ARE GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY WORSE, AND WE HAVE
TO TACKLE REAL PROBLEMS WITH
REAL SOLUTIONS. THE RECENT LAO
FCMAT REPORT DOES PROVIDE A
ROADMAP TO GET STARTED, IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE IGNORING A VERY
LOGICAL STARTING POINT, SO WE'RE
CONCERNED. I APPRECIATE IT TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU MADE THE
ASSERTION YOU'RE NOT LOOKING TO
UNDERMINE OTHER WORDS. EFFECTIVE
MORATORIUM, I ASSUME YOU'D BE
OPEN TO INSERTING CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO THAT EFFECT. OF
COURSE. I THINK THAT'S WHY MR.
BRAMBLE IS A TWEENER, EVEN
THOUGH HIS COMMENTS ARE PRETTY
STRONG. WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN
PRETTY COOPERATIVE. THESE GUYS
ALL KNOW WHERE I LIVE. SO, YOU
KNOW, AND IT'S HERE WITH THEM,
OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH THEM ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE. BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT THIS DOESN'T I UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT ANY IMPACTS ON THE
MORATORIUM. AND MANY LEGISLATORS
SMARTER THAN ME HAVE TREADED
INTO THESE WATERS PRIOR TO ME,
WHICH IS WHY I'M ONLY GOING ON
TO THE SHORE BANKS HERE AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE MOST
EGREGIOUS COMPONENT, WHICH IS
HOW WE PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
OVERSIGHT TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
WITH REALLY EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH FUNDING
TO PROTECT EDUCATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
MORATORIUM IS A CONVERSATION FOR
ANOTHER DAY AND POTENTIALLY
ANOTHER SENATOR. BUT I WILL, OF
COURSE, CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM AS FAR AS
WE GO HERE. WELL, I MEAN, TO THE
EXTENT THAT, YOU KNOW, THESE
THINGS RELY ON DEFINITIONS, TO
YOUR POINT. SURE. YOU KNOW, I'D
ASK THAT YOU WORK WITH MR. YOU
BET. THAT'S AN EASY. YES. RIGHT.
EASY. YES, OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR CHOBOQ,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THREE OF THESE
FOLKS HERE CONTRIBUTING. IT'S
GOING TO MAKE THE BILL BETTER AS
WE GO. URGENT, I VOTE THANK YOU,
MADAM CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE. ITEM NINE, SB
1477, ASHBY. MOTION IS DUE.
PASSED. THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI I CORTEZ.
GLASER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK THAT MEASURE HAS
TWO VOTES FOR NONE AGAINST. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN, AND SO THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ASHBY, I THINK WE HAVE THE
CONSENT. OKOBOJI HAS. AND
CONSENT, AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
1410. WE HAVEN'T DONE. YES. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S DO IT. I'M HERE FOR
YOU. LET'S BE 14. TEN. THAT'S
RIGHT. I LOVE BEING YOUR VICE
CHAIR. WELL, I'M.
LOVING OKAY. PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
WATCHING. I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS, WHICH MAKES SB 1410
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
LEGISLATION THAT SUGGESTS
FRAMEWORK POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS, AS AMENDED. THE
BILL RECOMMENDS THAT DURING THE
NEXT MATHEMATICS CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORK REVISION, THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
WILL ENCOURAGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO OFFER ALGEBRA ONE AND
MATHEMATICS ONE COURSES TO
EIGHTH GRADE STUDENTS. LAST
SUMMER, THE BOARD OF EDUCATION
APPROVED A REVISED MATHEMATICS
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK THAT
SUGGESTS THAT ALGEBRA COURSES
ARE ADVANCED AND SHOULD ONLY BE
TAUGHT IN HIGH SCHOOL. THIS
SUGGESTION HAS BEEN HEAVILY
CRITICIZED BY PARENTS COLLEGE
PROFESSORS, AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS BECAUSE OF THE DECISION
TO NO LONGER OFFER ALGEBRA IN
THE EIGHTH GRADE, IMMEDIATELY
PUTS FUTURE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
STUDENTS BEHIND, ESPECIALLY
THOSE INTERESTED IN STEM FOCUSED
MAJORS. THIS IS BECAUSE CSU
REQUIRES FIVE YEARS OF MATH FOR
INCOMING FRESHMEN ENTERING A
MATH INTENSIVE MAJOR. IN 2014,
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED WAS
THE FIRST TO EXPERIMENT WITH
MOVING ALGEBRA ONE EXCLUSIVELY
TO HIGH SCHOOL. IN MARCH, AFTER
NEARLY TEN YEARS OF DECLINING
RESULTS, SAN FRANCISCO'S
PROPOSITION G, WHICH URGED THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO OFFER ALGEBRA
ONE THROUGH EIGHTH GRADERS TO
EIGHTH GRADERS, PASSED WITH 81%
SUPPORT. SB 1410 WOULD REQUIRE
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION DURING
ITS NEXT MATHEMATICS CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORK REVISION TO RECOMMEND
THAT ALGEBRA ONE AND MATHEMATICS
ONE COURSES SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO EIGHTH GRADERS. ONCE AGAIN,
RECOMMEND JOINING ME IN SUPPORT
IS DOCTOR ELIZABETH STAMBAUGH, A
MATH TEACHER AT LOWELL HIGH
SCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO, AND
DEACON JOHN WILSON, AN
ENRICHMENT PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
YOUTH IN WEST LOS ANGELES.
WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR ELIZABETH STRATMOOR, AND
I'M A MATH TEACHER AT LOWELL
HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M HERE TO SHARE MY THOUGHTS IN
FAVOR OF SB 1410. I RETURNED TO
TEACHING AFTER A 25 YEAR CAREER
IN SILICON VALLEY AS A SOFTWARE
ENTREPRENEUR AND EXECUTIVE. FROM
MY OWN START UPS TO LANDMARK
COMPANIES INCLUDING STEVE JOBS
COMPANY, NEXT, THE FORERUNNER OF
TODAY'S APPLE, I CAME BACK TO
TEACH MATH BECAUSE IT WAS CLEAR
TO ME THAT THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STATES, DIVERSE AND
DISADVANTAGED YOUNG PEOPLE, WERE
STILL NOT GETTING THROUGH THE
MATH PIPELINE, AND THAT LOSS
CAUSES TWO PROBLEMS. THEY'RE
MISSING OUT ON AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES, AND WE ARE
MISSING OUT ON THEIR BRILLIANCE.
ANY EFFECTIVE ENGINEERING
MANAGER CAN TELL YOU THAT YOUR
PROJECT WILL HAVE MAJOR BLIND
SPOTS, UNLESS YOUR TEAM HAS SOME
DIVERSITY ON IT. THAT'S HOW WE
ENDED UP DURING COVID WITH PULSE
OXIMETERS THAT COULDN'T MEASURE
BLOOD OXYGEN LEVELS ON DARKER
SKINNED PATIENTS. THIS IS A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH. WHEN
SFUSD BLOCKED ACCESS TO ALGEBRA
ONE IN EIGHTH GRADE, THE
COMMUNITY FOUGHT BACK. THAT LED
TO A RUBE GOLDBERG SYSTEM OF
ABSURD AND EXPENSIVE
WORKAROUNDS. AT MY SCHOOL, WE
MADE TRADE OFFS TO FUND EXTRA
SECTIONS OF NINTH AND 10TH GRADE
MATH COURSES SO THAT ANY STUDENT
WHO WANTED TO ACCELERATE COULD
DOUBLE UP, BUT THAT'S COSTLY,
AND IT SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
NECESSARY. SO SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY ARE SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST INDUSTRIES,
AND A HUGE NUMBER OF OUR K-12
STUDENTS WILL BE SECOND OR THIRD
GENERATION ENGINEERS. THEIR
PARENTS ARE EXTREMELY FLUENT
WITH THE PREREQUISITES FOR
ENGINEERING EDUCATION. SO WHY
SHOULD WE BRING THE POWER
STRUGGLE OVER REASONABLE ACCESS
TO ACCELERATION TO THE WHOLE
STATE? THIS MAKES NO SENSE. SB
1410 IS A SENSIBLE GUARDRAIL
THAT PROPS THE DOOR OPEN AND
PROTECTS ALGEBRA ONE ACCESS FOR
ALL EIGHTH GRADERS IN CALIFORNIA
. THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
NEW NONBINDING FRAMEWORK FOR
PUBLISHERS CONFLICTS WITH OUR
BINDING MATH STANDARDS. WE DON'T
NEED MORE MATH CURRICULA THAT
CLAIM TO STRADDLE THIS CHASM,
BUT JUST SHUT THE DOOR ON
ACCELERATION. WHAT HAPPENED IN
SAN FRANCISCO SHOWS HOW QUICKLY
THINGS CAN SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL
. SO I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB 1410. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE WELCOME
AGAIN. HI THERE. I'M DEACON JOHN
WILSON, EDUCATION ENRICHMENT
DIRECTOR, PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
WEST ANGELES CHURCH OF GOD IN
CHRIST IN LOS ANGELES. THIS
PROGRAM SERVES IN SOME WAY OVER
800 FAMILIES IN LOS ANGELES,
INNER CITY AND SURROUNDING
AREAS. WE PROVIDE COLLEGE ACCESS
PROGRAMS. FOR AFFORDABLE
COLLEGES, CAREER DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE ADVOCATES FOR FAMILY ON
EDUCATIONAL CHALLENGES IN SCHOOL
, AND OUR PROGRAM HAS HAD GREAT
SUCCESS IN IMPROVING STUDENT
PERFORMANCE IN MATH AND SCIENCE.
WHETHER IT'S OVER THE SUMMER OR
DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR. I HIGHLY
SUPPORT AND RECOMMEND THAT YOU
PASS 1410 WITH ANY IMPROVEMENTS
THAT ARE NEEDED. I HEARD SOME
WERE DONE OR ARE IN PROCESS, IN
ORDER TO JUST A MOMENT, IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT THE PRINCIPLE OF
STUDENTS WITH THE NECESSARY
PRIOR LEARNING SHOULD ALWAYS
HAVE ACCESS TO TAKE ALGEBRA AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL, EVERY MIDDLE
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA MUST BE
REQUIRED TO HAVE A WAY TO
PROVIDE ALGEBRA ONE TO ANY
STUDENT WHO'S REALLY READY FOR
IT. HENCE, THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LAW ON THE BOOKS TO WITH TEETH
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. I ASSUME
EVEN FOR REASONS OF EQUITY, IT
SHOULD NOT BE THE POLICY OF OUR
STATE TO DETERMINE THAT ALGEBRA
ONE BE TAKEN ONLY IN HIGH SCHOOL
DOES. AS AN INNER CITY
ENRICHMENT LEADER, I KNOW THIS
TYPE OF LOW REGARD OR ASSUMPTION
THAT DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS ARE
ALL AT THE SAME LEVEL OF ABILITY
IS CONDESCENDING. ACTUALLY, AS
IT IS, PARENTS IN THE KNOW AND
WITH FINANCIAL RESOURCES INDEED
GET THEIR STUDENTS ALGEBRA TWO
IN THE SUMMER OR THEY DOUBLE
THEM UP ON THE MATH, AS SHE
MENTIONED, ONES IN THE NØ AND
THE ONES THAT DON'T IN OUR PER
PERSPECTIVE, STEM STUDENTS,
MINORITY STEM STUDENTS IN MANY
CASES, MANY NOT. BUT BUT COULD
NOT HAVE THAT CHANCE TO DOUBLE
UP AND THEY END UP JUST
FLOUNDERING. FINALLY, IF WE GET
IF WE WANT TO GET MORE STUDENTS
TO HIGHER PAYING STEM JOBS, YOU
NEED TO ENSURE THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANCED MATH. AND THAT LAST
YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL, I DON'T
WANT TO GO THROUGH EACH YEAR,
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT IF THEY
DON'T START WITH IT IN EIGHTH
GRADE, THEY COULD LOSE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THAT. SO
LET'S BRING EVERYTHING IN LINE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WEBSITE. LET'S HAVE ALGEBRA IN
EIGHTH GRADE. WHAT DO YOU SAY,
FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THAT YOU VOTE
AYE ON SB 1410. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SEEING VERY FEW
PEOPLE, IS ANYBODY HERE LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE, SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS, IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS, SENATOR CHABOT,
YOU REFERENCED, YOU DO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS. I APPRECIATE
THAT, I DO, AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND ITS AMENDED
FORM. SENATOR CORTEZ, WOULD YOU
ENTERTAIN A MOTION? SENATOR
CORTEZ MOVES THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, PLEASE? THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, WE KNOW FROM THE
EXPERIENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT
DELAYING ALGEBRA UNTIL HIGH
SCHOOL DOESN'T SERVE STUDENTS
WELL, AND ESPECIALLY OUR BLACK
AND BROWN STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO WANT TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
FRAMEWORKS CURRENT SUGGESTION TO
DELAY ALGEBRA UNTIL HIGH SCHOOL
IS REVERSED. FOR THOSE REASONS,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE. ITEM 12 SB 1410 OCHOA
BOGH MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
Ã NEWMAN. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALL WOULD.
CUEVAS. WILK THAT MEASURE HAS
THREE VOTES, FOUR ZERO AGAINST.
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES, WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WHO WILL HOPEFULLY COME
BACK SOON. IF YOU ARE A MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE, WE'RE COMING
TOWARD THE END. I THINK WE JUST
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR BACK.
AND THE VOTE ONLY AS WELL, IF
YOU REMEMBER THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, YOU'RE
WATCHING SOMEWHERE. PLEASE MAKE
YOUR WAY TO 2100. THANK YOU. YOU
GUYS ARE GOOD. SURE. EVERYBODY
GETS GETS. THEY'VE YOU JUST YOU
JUST HAVE CONSENT, RIGHT? I'M
GOING TO FREE YOU UP. ALL RIGHT.
SO, MADAM, MADAM CONSULTANT, LET
US NOW, CALL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, WE HAVE, SB 1252, SB
1288, SB 1329, SB 1449. I THINK
THAT'S IT, DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT? SENATOR CORTEZ
MOVES THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILK. ALL RIGHT. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS THREE VOTES
FOR ZERO AGAINST. WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE
HAVE ONE BILL THAT IS OPEN, SB
1471. IS IT CORRECT THAT SENATOR
CORTEZ HAS NOT. RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT, SO LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL
ON THOSE TWO MEASURES. IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND. PLEASE PROCEED.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE TWO OF YOU. OPEN UP.
FILE ITEM SIX SB 1471. STERN
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TWO EYES AND
NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTEZ,
CORTEZ. GLAZER GONZALEZ, MÀ
CUEVAS. WILK OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO
WE'RE THE WHICH MEASURE WAS
WHICH 77 ON 1477. THAT HAS TWO.
AYE VOTES. IS THAT RIGHT. TWO
VOTES. NO, NO. WE JUST DID 1471
1471 ALEJO'S THREE, IT'S STILL
OPEN. AND THEN THE OTHER ONE WE
VOTED WAS 1477 THAT NOW HAS TWO
VOTES. IS THAT CORRECT? YES.
OKAY FOR HIM. OH, I'M SORRY, I'M
SORRY, I'M SORRY. I ASKED YOU TO
OPEN BOTH, SO PLEASE CALL SB
1477. I THOUGHT YOU CALLED IT.
OKAY FILE ITEM NINE, SB 1477.
ASHBY. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND
NO NOS. WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK ALL
RIGHT. THAT THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS THREE VOTES. FOUR
ZERO AGAINST, AND THIS IS A TEST
OF HER DISCIPLINE. HELLO TO
JULIE IN MISSOURI. IF YOU ARE
WATCHING, IF YOU MADE IT ALL THE
WAY TO 12, TEN PACIFIC TIME, AND
SO WE ARE LEFT. SENATOR CORTEZ,
YOU HAVE NOTHING LEFT. THAT'S
OPEN. WE ONLY HAVE THE VOTE
ONLY, DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
VOTE ONLY MEASURE SB 1435. THAT
IS, IT'S THE. IT'S THE ONE
MEASURE THAT'S UP ON
RECONSIDERATION. IT'S VOTE ONLY.
YEAH WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION.
APPARENTLY LABOR JUST ENDED. SO
WE'LL GET IT. OKAY. SENATOR WILK
ESTARÁ, WELCOME TO SENATOR WILK,
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE ORDER HERE
. I GUESS LET'S LET'S START.
WE'LL GIVE OTHERS TIME. SO WE'RE
GOING TO REOPEN THE ROLL FOR THE
MEMBER WHO WAS ABSENT, WHO IS
NOW PRESENT, AND SO LET US START
WITH MEASURE, ITEM NUMBER ONE ON
THE AGENDA, SB 895. AND YOU CAN
JUST ROLL THROUGH IT. OKAY SB
895 ROTH GLAZER, GONZALEZ
MORRELL CUEVAS WILK I WILK I. S
DO YOU WANT ME TO JUST GO? JUST
ROLL THROUGH IT. OKAY. ALL OF
THESE MEASURES WILL BE LEFT OPEN
AS WE AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS.
SB 1115 GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK HØI.
WILK I SB 1195 LIMÓN. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK I WILK I SB 1203 GROVE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, WILK I WILK I, SB 1471
STERN, GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, WILK I, WILK
I, SB 1388. I WAS HAVING A
MOMENT OF SILENCE BEFORE I CAST
MY VOTE. THAT'S WHY THERE WAS A
DELAY. QUIET REFLECTION ON SB
1388. OUR ARCHULETA GLAZER,
GONZALEZ, SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS,
WILK, NØ, WILK, NØ, BAD BILL, SB
1477, ASHBY, GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, WILK, Ã.
WILK I. WE NEED A MOTION ON 1368
OKAY, SO ON ON SB 1368 FROM
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH THERE WAS NO
ONE PRESENT, WHO MADE A MOTION.
IS A MEMBER PRESENT HERE WHO'D
LIKE TO MAKE THE MOTION ON THAT
MEASURE? WILK MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR WILK. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
VOTE. THAT'S FILE ITEM 11, SB
1368, OCHOA BORG. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NO Ó NEWMAN. NØ OCHOA,
BOGH. I OCHOA I CORTEZ. ITEM
NUMBER 11. THE LICENSED
PREGNANCY CENTERS
.
OKAY. GLAZER. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
NØ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK I
WILK I HAS TWO RIGHT NOW. THAT
MEASURE HAS TWO VOTES FOR AND
ONE VOTE AGAINST. ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN. SB 1410.
OCHOA BOGH. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK I WILK I 1410 Þ I FOR ME DO
YOU ALREADY HAVE OKAY. CAN'T
VOTE TWICE. SORRY. DO YOU WANT
TO, AND SO SB 1435. SO THIS IS
THE VOTE ONLY MEASURE FOR, IT'S
UP FOR RECONSIDERATION BUT
CARRIED OVER FROM THE LAST
HEARING, NO DEBATE WILL WILL
TAKE PLACE HERE. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? WILK MOVES THE MOTION.
SENATOR WILK FILE ITEM 15, SB
1430 502. OCHOA BOGH MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN ABSTAINING.
OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI I. CORTEZ NO.
CORTEZ. NO. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. NO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURE HAS TWO VOTES FOR TWO
VOTES AGAINST. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN. OKAY. AND LET US
LET'S GO BACK THROUGH FOR
SENATOR GONZALEZ. DO WE DID WE
AND I'M SORRY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THOSE ON AND OPEN
AGAIN THIS YEAR. LET'S DO
CONSENT FIRST. OKAY OKAY. ON THE
CONSENT. ME AGAIN. NO I'M NOT
I'M ON YOUR SIDE. WE'RE DOING
CONSENT FIRST ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NOW HAS FIVE
VOTES FOR NONE AGAINST. AND
LET'S GO BACK TO THE BEGINNING
OF THE ROLE. WORK OUR WAY
THROUGH, LET'S PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT FOR SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS TO GET SETTLED. WELCOME
SENATOR. I UNDERSTAND YOU WERE
CHAIRING ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
APPRECIATE YOU SCAMPERING OVER
HERE, WE ARE GOING TO REOPEN THE
ROLE AND PROCEED THROUGH ALL OF
THE MEASURES, AND THANK YOU,
SENATOR WILK, FOR COMING BACK.
READY? PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY AND
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, WE DO KNOW THAT
SENATOR GLAZER IS COMING BACK,
SO I'M NOT GOING TO ANNOUNCE THE
COUNT ON THIS ONE. SO, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE WORK YOUR WAY
THROUGH IT. OKAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GLAZER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
SB 885. ROTH. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
SB 1115. LIMÓN GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE SB 1195
LIMÓN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE SB
12 ZERO THREE. GROVE YES.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ NO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. NO SB 1471. STERN.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. NO. HE. HE HAD
ONE IN CONSENT. THIS IS THE
QUIET REFLECTION, BILL.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
. 1471. YES. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE SB 1388 ARCHULETA. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. SB 1477 ASHBY.
GLAZER. GONZALES GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS AYE SB 1368. OCHOA. BOGH
GLAZER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS NO.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. NO SB 1410.
OCHOA. BOGUE GLAZER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
AND ON THE VOTE ONLY SB 1435.
OCHOA BOGUE. GLAZER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WEEK. IT'S JUST VOTE
ONLY. YOU VOTED NO. BUT. SO IT'S
BACK ON RECONSIDERATION.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. NO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE. YOU ARE
CLOSED OUT ON ALL VOTES. WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR
GLAZER, WHO IS CHAIRING ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING RIGHT NOW WHO
WILL COME OVER. SO THANK YOU,
AND UNTIL SUCH TIME AS HE
RETURNS, WE WILL ADJOURN A
RECESS. I'M SORRY. WE'LL RECESS
THE COMMITTEE AND WE'LL BE BACK.
OPEN. ON. ALL MEASURES. LET'S
RUN THROUGH IT FOR THE BENEFIT
OF MEMBERS WHO WERE ABSENT.
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. GLAZER. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE FOR ITEM ONE, SB
895, ROTH. GLAZER. AYE. CAN YOU
TELL ME THE VOTE? THE TOTALS OF
THE VOTE, OF COURSE, FOR ITEM
ONE, SB 895 ROTH. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX AYES AND
NO NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. I FILE ITEM TWO SB 1115
LIMÓN. MOTION IS DUE PASSED. THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX AYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE THAT MEASURE IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO. THE PREVIOUS
MEASURE, I'M SORRY, IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALSO
OUT SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM THREE
SB 1195 LIMÓN. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX AYES AND NO NO'S, WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. THAT
MEASURE OUT IS WITH SEVEN VOTES.
FILE ITEM FOR SB 1203. GROVE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
REVENUE AND TAXATION. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND
FOUR NOES, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
NO. GLASER. GLASER. NO. NO. THAT
MEASURE FAILS WITH TWO VOTES FOR
AND FIVE AGAINST. DO YOU WANT TO
RECONSIDERATION ON THAT CHAIR?
NO, IT WASN'T ASKED FOR. YOU
DIDN'T ASK FOR. SHE DID NOT ASK
FOR IT. OKAY. FILE ITEM SIX SB
1471. STERN MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED. CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
AYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. ITEM EIGHT SB 1388.
ARCHULETA. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND ONE NO SHOW. BOG
GLASER. GLASER. NO. ALL RIGHT.
THAT MEASURES OUT WITH FOUR
VOTES FOR TWO AGAINST FILE ITEM
NINE, SB 1477. ASHBY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT
VOTE SIX AYES AND NO NO'S, WITH
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. GLASER GLASER. AYE. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM 11 SB 1368
OTOBOKE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO EYES AND THREE NOES, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING NO. GLASER NÓ.
GLASER NO. THAT MEASURE FAILS
WITH TWO VOTES FOR AND FIVE AND
FOUR AGAINST. FILE ITEM 12 SB
1410 OTOBOKE. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS, AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX EYES AND NO
NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER I
GLASER I THAT MEASURE IS OUT
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. FILE ITEM
15 ON THE VOTE ONLY MEASURE SB
1435 OTOBOKE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO TWO EYES AND THREE NOES.
GLASER CHAIR. VOTING NO. YOU
SAID Ó NOT VOTING CHAIR
ABSTAINING. I'M SORRY. SO IT'S
THE REVOTE FROM LAST TIME. NOT
VOTING. GLASER ABSTAINING. NOT
VOTING. ALL RIGHT, SO THAT
MEASURE ALSO FAILS WITH TWO
VOTES FOR THREE AGAINST. THANK
YOU, SENATOR GLASER. WITH THAT,
WE HAVE COMPLETED TODAY'S
HEARING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
EDUCATION, WHICH IS HEREBY
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU TO STAFF
FOR ALL YOUR GOOD WORK